[Music]
n
yo yo my
check bang bang n is
game What's Going On Let's do a quick
roll call for some Legends get in the
room in the building a little bit early
how my levels are sounding what's going
on Mason gamer what's going on Zach Ry
how you doing as
parade what's going on I see you Mike
Che uhoh we got the legendary Harold in
here early he was
ready I he he's never late that man is
ready so we just I doing roll call with
the live chat while they while he get in
the room for the for Sunday we got the
legendary H Goldberg in here now Omar
what's going on sounds very good okay
okay so I want to do some uh audio stuff
with with how we back but I just wasn't
check stream is good see if it's doing
okay hey I talk to you
B here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I get something here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and make it inflammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame that they
can saring up in the apartment they call
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting and range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest of start regardless back
we was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by coal I
got Don't Stop N that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoil them to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't he the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vult Tron with a gang cgas
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
krer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rign you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's Swit what you don't stop that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead I guess you
could say that I'm very spoil put them
to be your dog they Ain very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm a
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking of uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to fli the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
they can Saron up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting and
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when we was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I
[Music]
got keep that keep that going keep that
going go ahead look I guess you can say
that I'm very spoiled feeling to be your
dog thing very loyal but I ain't going
to hold you I ain't heard the boy you
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy krer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord
podcast right now as we speak and uh I
guess I'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say I'm better than money because you
can Bank on me being accountable I know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable I kill a beat and they
want to compare me to Freddy and Jason I
rather be Hannibal they be like why use
a video game just just be original y'all
to Dramatical I know it's random but I
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Saron up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still coal I got let's
switch what did you doing Don't Stop N
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going
look I guess you could say that I'm very
SPO to be your dog they very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't he the
bo you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertain until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the RS you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got let's
switch that up you do stop was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel them to be
your dogs they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Fredy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mine go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Aron up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to St regardless back when you was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got
what did you do Don't Stop N that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoil to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vult Tron with a gang of
cougar and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be handable
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is De Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but a man social love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's
[Music]
switch that going keep that going go
ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil them to be your dog they
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocs Twitter but I'm anal love
my city but I'm still Co I
got what did you do Don't Stop N that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you can say that I'm very spoiled
feeling to be your dog thing very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
here the boyal you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making vult Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that again
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing that real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being a canable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rigns you
just a Target when I'm I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on a
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got let's switch what you stop
that was dope keep keep that keep that
going keep that going go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
feel them to be your dog they very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the boy you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compar me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when we was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I
Gott
you that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoal feel to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that yoga fire flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to started regardless back when was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's switch what you do don't stop that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
for them to be your dog they very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the boy you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you I been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and
[Music]
um call Proclaim both loud and clear a
proclamation of invitation turn not on
me yet ear C
theis the river stence
[Music]
with I'mma just chilling watch Ste many
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then that would mistake me for adct
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give with that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get tossed
in the bushes by King David royalty and
not a pretender detrimental to a
Elemental what a avatar to a knee Bender
I got to be me I know it's my destiny
work too who cares if you fly if you
still a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be steo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if you really was that
dude K still be the king of the statu
since a juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
that it's cool and it's beautiful we let
you know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the L's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a L's
[Music]
day over let's do a quick mic check with
everyone let's start with the legendary
Harold Goldberg mic check while we are
live iron Lords yes that's what I want
to hear that's what I want to hear no
question Lord Ryan let's get a quick uh
mic check while we are live one two yes
yes there we go there we go no question
and of course the Lords Lord addict my
check my check uh can you guys hear me
yep good to go now and so once again
hello hello hello yeah yeah and King I
think Dr a come back he was here see
where's The King The King was he's
probably had a little camera issue he
may have to restart I remember had an
issue with mine but we will join in
progress here ye hear ye and we are live
welcome to the IR Lords podcast LLC and
also live on Lords of gaming.net episode
number
337 it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and today I'm very excited about
both our special guests and we've got
the New York game
awards Xbox developer direct Final
Fantasy 16 to Xbox rumors and po world's
incredible success to discuss so we are
going to get right into it I want to
introduce a lord whose passion for
marrying the worlds of education and
video games truly shines as relationship
Builders and ultimately a teaching
Catalyst for our underserved
communities and
introducing the executive director of
the New York video games critic Circle
and the former New York City Department
of Education Middle School educator of
the year the Lord of Zelda and now
balers gate and everyone's favorite
video game
teacher live from New York and making
his debut into the realm of the Lords
mob man Lord Ryan o Callahan how we
doing there doing great thanks so much
for having us I'm so excited to be here
I love an excuse to just sit and talk
people at
games that I get a chance to just talk
for for a long time about it so that's
awesome man good to have you in the
realm you're a lord at what you do what
you been uh getting a chance to to play
Lately any games lately you've been
playing so with the insanity that that
was last year I was like I got to fall
back into something real light and just
like over the past few nights I played
through
viewfinder just went through and did the
whole thing I love like games like that
like um portal and super Lial I just
recently played for the first time as
well so this was like a perfect like
Trilogy to do those three oh I like
those and I'm getting back into ghost of
sushima and then just this year hit and
then I never got to finish it so I I
dive back into that a couple days ago
just doing little task on the side
relearning how to actually
like Parry and noidea what I was doing
getting your stances down water stance
and all that stuff yeah yeah yeah I got
to get back to it too man I think trying
to remember if I finished the DLC was it
eeky Island and then the uh multiplay is
really good yeah yeah that's that go see
my actually I'll show you how much it is
over my heart I am a huge oh very nice
yeah go that's the one that I'm
currently wearing right now I just went
in and redid the whole whole C a that
was my morning was just like getting Jin
back to what I wanted exactly you got to
get your Jin fit right I respect that no
question and of course we have a
returning Lord to the realm whose iconic
journey within music journalism and
video games has motivated so many of us
to volunteer and join the legendary
circle of video game
culture introducing the award winner
author president and founder of the New
York video games critic Circle and the
New York game awards the Lord of video
games and its dominance on pop culture
and New York State's number one advocate
for his beloved Buffalo Bills
tonight live from the e side and making
his triumphant return into the realm of
the Lords my man Lord Harold Goldberg
how we doing
sir I'm good Lord now go Bills first of
all you ready are we nervous big one
it's a big one always nervous with the
bills but you never know what's going to
happen and I'm nervous about the New
York game awards too but you know I
think I think I think we've got we've
got it down so that we only have uh you
know maybe 20 tickets left to sell and
then we'll be sold out so that that'll
be great Neil dman will be with with us
yes yes we got some Neil dman sign stuff
oh you know I'm getting mine yeah yeah
yeah we get that exclusive right there
that son oh it's gonna be great GNA be
great man thank you for having me no
question it's you know have have Ryan on
it's like a dynamic duo here yes to uh
to talk gam I agree the circle is
represented quite well today so quick
question um before we get in as far as
your um gaming with all the craziness of
planning and everything you got going
has it been anytime for games cuz I know
this this upcoming week has got to be
stressful for you it's it's a little
stressful but uh I I started playing a
tiny game called Turn it boy Robs
a my son is playing that right
now no question so so so so that's cool
and I'm trying you know uh all all of
our nominees I'm trying to get back to
just a little bit before the show just
to to uh especially balers gate which uh
I got into but I didn't get like a 100
hours in yeah I'm in the same boat uh
but uh want to play that and then you
know I'm looking forward to what's
coming in uh you know February as well
so I'm looking as like what am I going
to review for for that for that month
that sort of thing nice nice man's
always playing games gotta love it no
question no question and of course you
already know we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those orual Lords of the realm
here at the round table with abbreviated
intros to respect our guest time that's
right
s blame s yeah blame the one who inro
always gets
taken my co-host the coost my brother
for another mother difficult game Cura
lord of the spin clap and the how of the
young wolf Lord addict of the addict
show how we doing
sir doing pretty good I can't talk a
whole lot right now I hear you brother
we appreciate you you're making it we
know you're going through a lot right
now I'm not going to get too long with
you as far give me your time
yeah but I know you've been playing
Power has that been uh it or anything
else
uh that's pretty much it power world
I've been playing Resident Evil Zero too
oh okay oh cool cool cool no doubt and
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the SRA damis the Lord of crowns
Messiah of IOP I have to say this this
begrudgingly cuz I lost vets and Lord
Patriot of the iron bank PC Master races
old Lord Sovereign how we doing sir I'm
doing very well thank you for that intro
beautiful I appreciate that you like my
enthusiasm every time I get to that I
love the
enthusiasm enthusiasm which which I say
Doctor Strange Love Dr Strange thank you
thank you for your
patronage than you for your sir I'm
doing good doing good yesterday was a
good production day got a bunch of stuff
done so that was good uh sometimes
Saturdays uh Saturday should be the lazy
day but it wasn't
happening but um I did manage to keep
playing a throughout the course of the
week uh Prince of pers of the Lost
Crown nice brother it that's a that's an
all-timer wow yeah it's a side mission
if you take it it freezes unlocks the
game so what are you playing it on not
me I'm not playing it I sto playing I
got something else I'm playing somebody
somebody hit me in in my DMs was like
don't don't take this question you're
going to lock up okay so it's like
people give you heads up and you you
didn't see fit to tell me to tell us
what it is thank you thank you for
your for your timely information I just
wow you said if you take a a in this
massive game you not now he's looking at
all his side quests and
Fe I I'll tell you in a second relax he
I appreciate that oh my God but no uh so
so far I haven't had that
thankfully but it it really is I when I
think about how much I love this genre
the Metroid genre and all the games I've
played over the years it's in there it
it is in that top 10 easily maybe top
five it is that good um when you look at
the team that made it and and it's not
difficult to sort of see why the team
that made it was the team that did you
know Rayman Origins Rayman Legends so
the platforming is impeccable um couple
that with the combat and the variety and
just the world that they built obviously
a Metroid Vania when you think about
Metroid Vania you think about having to
go back you know backtrack and and you
know depending on whatever you know
upgrades and powerups you get it allows
you to access different parts of the map
and there's a certain flow to that that
if you get it just right it just
constantly makes you feel rewarded for
what you're doing nice um and this game
has that in Spade so I'm I'm elated to
be playing this and that's kind of where
my head is right now just Prince of pers
lost Crown that's that's huge that's
definitely one of the best better games
that's came out already this year wow
that's High Praise from you no doubt and
of course we have the incredible hul of
this aka the EXs gamer o the profit of
Xbox swamy King of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the Undisputed leader
of the Xbox front line movement o belov
it Lord King how we doing sir I'm doing
fantastic I can't wait till
Tuesday oh yeah oh yeah yes yes I I plan
I plan to look dapp as
always suits ready yeah and I and I
can't wait to see what Harold's wearing
because I'm gonna wear my lucky suit man
my my lucky suit same thing as I wore
last year oh we got the L we bringing
the lineing in oh I love the line that's
about yes yes the line in the B tie
let's go all those SKS inside there help
me out I I didn't know who Harold was
you know cuz last year we went and I
just saw this guy in the corner like he
was just standing there and it was just
like a proud father watching like you
know how when you look for that approval
from your parents it's a it's a look
that they're really pleased with you and
he had just looking I'm like who is this
guy in the corner with this creepy look
right and I said he must be the
controller he's the controller behind
the SC yeah and you know come to find
out you know he was and I was just like
super enthusiastic to you know have him
back today and and the fact that last
year and and I'm going to tell
people always project yourself into a
space last year we went and we were in
awe but at the same time we had an
objective to become part of and we was
like it will be crazy dope within the
next five years that we'll be on stage
presenting something and you were
thinking that back then yes he speaks
things into existence yes yeah
my 90% of my books is you know focus on
meditation and projection and it's like
oh my God it's happening yeah and I said
you know we are ready for this moment
and we are looking forward to other
things as well but I was super excited
to get back to you have this
conversation with you today and I can't
wait I can't really wait till Tuesday
I'm like it's like a kid on Christmas so
no doubt great man no we're we're
excited we're excited too man we you
know Reggie's coming into town today
everybody will be ready to do some well
Neil doesn't have
to yeah Reggie and I and Sheree Shere L
Smith who's our third co-host this year
we we have to we have to do a couple of
rehearsals before for the big moment so
it'll be good we're excited about it
know we love the theater SVA theater
people they are good peoples and uh you
know and we have iron Lords coming out
coming back how this is this is crazy so
what I've been playing this week
um oh Vala oh you deep in it oh wow okay
I I waited I waited you know because I I
had faith in Phil and that he was he was
going to bring it to Game Pass right
also I was I didn't even have faith I
have fear wait you Valhalla or valheim
no no Val Assassin's Creed Valhalla old
H finally in Game Pass never mind I was
thinking about I was thinking about
Ragnarok Ragnarok okay
got I was like
what say oh they bend the
knee never mind mind third party games
truly are going everywhere so I have I I
purchased the DLC by mistake right and I
thought I got the game and I was just
like I did it was a big thing about it
but I got the DLC and everything now and
I got the game main game now so um you
know I played garage right yes and it it
felt cool it was whatever the moment I
put this game on it felt like old home
because I'm uh you know from Origins to
Odyssey to uh this valala I don't know
man I'm so addicted to the formula that
they put together the expansiveness of
how I want to uh you know Traverse the
world the stuff that I want to do and
you know it just goes to show you a
great game is always going to be great
no matter what time you do get it you
don't have to get it day one but you can
get it whenever down the line and it
will still have the same hook that you
know that you're into and I'm so
addicted I'm so addicted to this game
that I didn't play fortnite wow that's
big from you yes this man nor I got to
get my fortnite fixed every day I did
not jump on fortnite for the past four
days this is all I've been playing wow
that's big that's I got got to take you
seriously that yeah it's a fantastic
game and and if if anybody hasn't got a
chance to try it out and if you like
these type of games get in there now
yeah in Game Pass no doubt and of course
we have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading that
realness in the r of the IOP not telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear shout out to defining Duke
my partner Mr MD plays talking Xbox
direct shout out to ebontis and Tai guy
Travis of the last word we had bunge
Zone Gerald Ludy uh from the Bundy
Foundation we helped raise uh he well
they help rais with the game to give
program 1.5 million and y'all and um
it's for the little light programs
providing Comfort to children with
serious conditions in hospitals so very
proud of the team and them and he he was
talking about his work his charity work
there absolutely amazing stuff go check
that out um for me um it's been bald's
gate mostly bald's gate three I finally
spent a lot of time with it in the
beginning and now I'm like I think I'm
towards the end of act one and some beef
between the dwarves and some uh treel
like beings who I have to make a big big
decision on who I'm going to side with
so I had that been doing a lot of Tekken
7 prep and reference for Tekken 8 I'm a
huge Tekken fan this week yo your man
Eddie Gordo was debuted so s sof yeah
the iron B with like I I know I we'll
talk later hopefully we'll approve our
prove our
purchas hopefully or that but anyway or
I'm not approving or disapproving I'm
just just let's just be a little patient
okay okay got you fair enough fair fair
fair enough so I've been doing that in
preparation for uh Tekken eight and then
got a shout out adct man I I didn't I
only play like an hour or two of it but
I did fire up power world just to see
the insane craziness of what's going on
and yeah as a person who generally
doesn't like Pokemon or play Survival
games like yo you didn't get that creepy
uh thing that you don't like I was I was
the kid I was the I was the grow man at
the playground yeah
yeah now look it's like I don't know
it's like Arc Pokemon breath of the wild
and grounded had a baby like it's just
it's just it's it's a lot of elements to
it but from what I played it what I like
is the handh hold it because survival
games are too intimidating to me so like
they're like okay make sure you do this
go here there all the indicators on you
all right build your station get a club
go catch this one do G what is it like
the Pokeball thing and whatever they
call it but anyway Lo story short you
know I do see I heard you can catch
humans yes yes and and you can make them
make people work it has a lot of funny
aspects to that game but uh anyway
frames make people
work but we go we G to move on very Cas
topic for some but uh so real quick
because I know times um super chats if
we care we got a liot or uh we'll hold
off what'll hold off oh got we'll hold
off until after I we have companies in
the
house we'll hold off all for your we'll
get to you we'll get to you embarrassing
email let's get to it so look now that
we got into what the Lords have been
planned we got to shift our Focus back
to the New York video games critic
Circle Lord Ryan in his video game
system history his journey as an
educator and now executive director at
the Circle and of course updates with
Lord Harold and everything involving the
1th annual game New York game award so
uh Lord Ryan let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming so for me the the big
first was Sega Genesis oh like we like
especially like you know growing up or
like you know in your household you have
one thing or you have the other so like
console wars were wild but like the end
day finances right mom's not going to
say yes to the second thing okay so we
we got the Genesis and most of my gaming
history is me and my brother so we dig
on two-player Co-op things and Genesis
was perfect for that y so you know you
had obviously like your your Sonic the
Hedgehogs um we loved um Joe and Mack oh
remember the
C wild Tow Jam and Earl Panic on Funko y
I forgot about Tow Jam and Earl kind of
got that Pokemon thing right you're
literally catching
humans and then one that was the big
co-op on Genesis was Zombies Ate My
neighbors that is a forever favorite of
mine like I go back to that like because
now it's on the switch and I'll go back
to it and like just try to get as far as
I can that game is Relentless that that
that is like exactly like someone who
made arcade games was like I'm going to
make a game for a system and I'm not
going to give
any be a quarter eater regardless of the
fact system I cannot beat that game but
I will play it like
big fan no question gotta back you up
one second because you talk in my
language and I used to play obviously my
cousins and stuff like that but what did
you get a chance to play I'm try to get
some Genesis uh forgotten worlds um that
was like a shooting one that was a early
one um obviously the classic co-op on
Genesis I would say stre Streets of Rage
any Streets of Rage we we did a lot of
the beat them ups and like because I I I
was probably like like six or seven I
got you I got you so like a lot of it is
just like flash in the pan memory like
but like like we did um we love the
Turtle games but we liked hyperstone
Heist more than we like turtles in time
really when I say we liked it more it's
we had it is just you know when you're a
kid that's the thing right you like what
you have and that's it
right continue so you got going through
with the Genesis and everything yeah so
and then once we got through the
Genesis um like one random day my my dad
came home with PS1 and that was just
like big family event we were you know
going through and we still have some of
like the old classic full cases we even
have the you know how they used to come
with the sponges yes you like wipe off
those things just scratch your disc they
never backed in with the sponges and I
remember um like when the Twisted Metal
Show came out like my brother has all
our stuff and like has it organized on
shelves and I'll go hang out with with
him and I was like oh I got to see we
still have the Twisted Metal it's like
mint it's insane um but we loved all
those things and like my biggest
Playstation One memory let's go was like
that's when we started to like co-op
games weren't as abundant at the time
but we did a lot we would sit down as a
family and play a game and I was
probably like well PlayStation was what
like 98 is
around 95 oh 95 yes yes you are right oh
jeez so even low younger than I think so
this this this about my parents but we
would play Resident Evil together like
it was my my brother would be on the
controls because my my baby brain
couldn't handle tank controls it still
can't my brother would be on the
controls and then my mom and I would
just like sit and watch and would just
like talk about the puzzle so it would
be like get to the tiger head and a gem
in one eye and we're both like wait
there was a gem in another room
like let's go find The Gem and like
those memories were were so cool for me
because it was like the game wasn't
intended for that right it wasn't
intended to be this big Co-op game but
it became this this story and not not as
much of the narrative in that time
because I I don't think we were picking
up random journal entries and reading
them as a family but but like figuring
out those puzzles together like that
resonates so much for me with the
resident Series so much more than like
the insanity that it's you know become
how it's justess like it's just an anime
now yeah we did a lot of stuff on that
and then the the big turning point for
me was uh my brother got an N64 I think
it was like his communion and everyone
gives you the
the going out and getting the N64 and my
uncle for my I guess seventh or eighth
birthday got me Ocarina of Time oh and
that was like that was the first time
that I had a game that was my game and I
sat I played it I followed through I was
terrible at it I learned and like the
first big cinematic moment for me in a
game was like by the way Chic is Zelda
and like my
mind this is a story like this person
who's been helping me is the person I've
been trying to help the whole time this
is crazy and like that's when just games
became so much more important to me on a
personal level whereas they were like
this is what I do with my brother this
is what I do with my cousins when we
hang out but then it was like oh games
can be for just me yes and story can be
for just me and like from then like
because like like I said before when
you're a kid it's like you get one thing
or you get nothing yes I became the
Nintendo kid because you have to choose
because wasn't the money there wasn't
anything so I rode the Nintendo train
for a while my brother drove the place
Station train for a while and we would
like dabble with each other and share
and then you know then you become an
adult and it's like want and and things
start to to converge um but beyond that
like it was you know we had those mixed
consoles and we would share and play um
the the biggest game for me until balers
gate showed up and just ruined my
understanding of what a favorite is was
Final Fantasy 10 was always a favorite
of mine Fantasy 10 um CU it
at the time which one Ryan which one the
first one for the PlayStation and it I
loved Final Fantasy before that I had
never completed one okay because you
know when when you're nine years old
like you know like I was playing final
fantasy9 and I'm essentially just
learning like Old English through that
like like I'm like why are they saying
thou like what ises that me learning all
these different things and figuring it
out and Final Fantasy 10 came out in 01
so I was like 10 going on 11 and you
know it was the first jump into voice
acting and all of that um but I just it
was an easy game to start playing
because it was really simple term-based
mechanics it's Pokemon added four and
how you play it and obviously like I
knew that really well coming through but
what was funny is Final Fantasy 10 you
can argue it's got like the best like
gameplay in terms of a final fantasy you
could switch like in battle like there's
not a lot of final fantasies that do
that wow adct appr proof there's a
ripple effect into everything that you
choose and like yeah it'll tell you like
on the side like if I do this attack now
I'm changing the order and it became
really like methodical in that sense but
I I started to just really fall in love
with that the story and it started to
mean a lot to me but then as I was going
through the story it also had this like
real world conflict which was playing a
game and having an older brother which
is like if I for one second show that
I'm struggling something like let let
let me help you out you had one brother
I'm gonna beat this game and I'm gonna
make you watch me beat this game so I
would play Final Fantasy 10 I would wake
up on a Saturday at like 6: in the
morning and I would like sneak
downstairs and I'd play it on low
volume beat this game for myself I'm not
going to let him do it I love this and
but now it's like he and I love that
game and it's like it's just like our
like some people have like a sick movie
or TV show like you're home sick I'm
going to watch this thing I'm going do
this thing that that's that for me I
play that once once a year if I'm not
feeling great I go back to that game it
just it means so much to me I love it I
love the hit this real quick quick
Interruption Lor right we got the
breaking protocol slightly s we've got
the legendary hip hop gam in the chat
he's like shout out to my family the I
Lord you got my man Ryan and in the
building we lit we are up there in the
on the 23rd he's in the building for the
New York game know hip hop G is going to
be there yeah Hip Hop's in the building
I just had to shout him out man that's
cool but continue no that's that's an
amazing story and I love the aspect of
the the the competitive nature s
appreciate this with with with your
brother you know what I'm
saying like I love the fact that like
you were determined to to do so there's
no there's not going to be handholding
going to beat this of course yeah yeah
and like throughout that time like he he
was the PlayStation 2 owner in the house
and I had the Game Cube so like I I was
dabbling in that like forever Wind Waker
like is one of my as well like I love
all my Zelda games but something about
what they did with Wind Waker I think is
the most perfect thing from I I could
tell by the background you love
zeld my entire left arm is oh that's we
got you got to lead with
that put that back up put that back up
put that t back up to do without taking
off the shirt
it favorite one which I don't know if we
can get it in
is right here um really awesome tattoo
artist um in Long Island at Green Apple
Tattoo um Adam perel he's like the
greatest tattoo artist I've ever met I
mean did one and I was like I'm never
anywhere
um scanned your background and knew your
love for Zelda you know cuz I have those
those those statues back there those are
cute um and I was like he's GNA go into
Zelda he's going to go and you you went
right into but I didn't know that you
had a sleep now the Consciousness the
thought process in getting that sleep
cuz you're marking your body this is
going to be for the rest of your life
you're going in there and you have it
pounded in your heart I'mma do this this
is gonna happen it wasn't no bet that
you lost none of that stuff n this was
conscious thought 100% what was the
first piece that you said that you had
to get on first so it's actually a
little weird so I I had like one or two
the first tattoo I ever got which I
regret it is now covered up by the
tattoo was I got um from The Lion King I
got like the Simba that's painted on the
tree yes like it was cool great but like
I didn't understand tattoos I understand
tattoo culture placement anything so I
have this like little animal
cracker
the prime
spot luckily they didn't like light
Browns but um I just started to like
fall in love with tattoos and um I
watched a ton of Ink Master in college
and was like obsessed with that so like
I got to the point where I was like I'm
an
expert I didn't but I followed this guy
who was my who is now like my regular
tattoo artist and he was doing a
giveaway right and he was like I'm going
to you know give one free tattoo and he
does mostly anime and game
right my Alle this guy's great he lived
not far from when I lived on Long Island
and I started to notice on Instagram he
liked one of my posts and I was like
hold on a second I can manufacture this
right every other day I would post a
thing that I saw he made a tattoo of
nice right and then I was like he's
liking it
again again come getting this tattoo
because he wants to make what he wants
to make right he's not to pick someone
who's going to roll in and just be like
you know give me a sparrow he'll be like
he want to do something cool that he
could post so I was like let me push out
all this game stuff that I'm really into
and Loan behold I won so the the Ocarina
one that I did he did for free nice
insane and I was the the whole agreement
that I had and the thing that I believe
is if someone is a professional at
something and knows what to do give them
as much free reign to do what they do
as and let them be the artist so I was
like look I love Legend of Zelda here's
a couple of things but you pick what you
want to do because I trust that you're
going to do a good thing so he did that
one and I was like I guess I'm I'm gonna
be back I'm terrible with doctor's
appointments I don't make follow-ups
like my dentist is like be back in six
months and like you want to make an
appointment I like I'll call
you two years later let's get the
schedules open let's go you know it's
it's just been great the the thing for
me was Zelda like why I like kind of
going back to your original question
like what's the mentality why why do you
want to do that and the message from
Zelda that I always go back to that I
think means so much to me is like as
simple as it goes is the Triforce is
these three pieces right wisdom courage
and especially in the world today right
we see that great power can always try
to overthrow you but if you take wisdom
if you have the courage you can
overthrow any power yes that's always
been really meaningful to me just in my
life where I feel like I'm being pushed
down I feel like I don't have the
strength to do it I don't have the power
for it and and not to mention when uh
you know the person that keeps getting
the power is such an idiot so oh
my Gand like has all the the occasions
of the world and he always let his
arrogance just completely make him lose
like yeah the arrogance and ignorance
man combined it's difficult to parse
sometimes but yeah yeah courageous you
know people don't understand um the
mediums that we choose resonates with us
as growing adults I would take from
comic books the
um having the bravery and the courage
because I will gravitate to Marvel
Comics because a lot of the characters
didn't have powers or and they took this
responsibility upon their self to help
others and to do that stuff and I will
always go back to the characters and how
they made you feel because sometimes
that stuff wasn't represented in your
community or around you but you got it
from material and you wanted to exude
this stuff so the fact that you're
talking about courage and wisdom and
stuff like that and forms your trifecta
in life that's a beautiful thing because
it sticks with you to to this day and
you have it on your arm so whenever you
fall down on hard times or whatever you
go right back to the core values that
you put on yourself as a and that's
great that's fantastic I I really needed
to know more about it and as you I was
seeing your love for Zelda I just had to
ask that question yeah yeah man I love
it I love it fantastic stuff oh I just
want to make sure Lord Harold approves
we we approving of this Lord Harold this
Tri for
and what and what about Ryan's game
history anything that resonated with you
when he played well I you know Final
Fantasy series I mean I have uh Final
Fantasy was the final fantasy s was the
first review I wrote for Wired Magazine
way way back in the day and I
remember that Sony said well why don't
you come and see this game final fantasy
and I said I'm I'm a happy you know
happy to go see it I can't promise you
any coverage until I see the
game uh so
so they said well we're showing it in
Hawaii
oh and I said well I'm not you know I
guess I'm not going he said no no we'll
we'll we'll take you oh we G fly you out
okay to uh to to see this game and I'm
like all right and this is the first and
only time that someone had taken me
anywhere first class on a plan oh we
first class inai okay that's how they
used to do back in the day
got I would I would to get first class
for final that's not happening
anymore maybe that that potential uh you
know get to go to Hawaii and you know
chill for a couple days while you're
covered that I was like okay you on you
on your B okay maybe continue continue
you know I walk into the playing and
it's like oh you're in first class I'm
I'm walking back toward econom you go to
the your natural instinct was to go to
EC basically of back so I said well this
feels weird but so so I I get there they
they put us up in this
hotel and uh they said yeah Shaq stayed
in this room last oh Shaq was just you
know that's just this is his regular
room yes let's go let's go I'm goad
Harold I'm pocket watching
continue room service was crazy so then
we we we had this these series of
meetings with uh this guy Saka Gucci who
created the final fantasy series and uh
they what they really proud of beyond
the story and the RPG aspect was the
amount of Graphics they could put in the
PlayStation one so that's what they were
showing off and so PlayStation 1
graphics were good for the time but no
one had seen this kind of graphics on
PlayStation one before if you remember
those those those opening movies
and crazy good stuff so so uh I was
there there was a guy named Steve Kent
who was a Critic at the time one of the
top critics at the time we're both
looking at each other wow this is like
how did they do that you know I love
that portion like I see Zelda too like
how did they do that child childlike
sense of wonder
right we do our interviews and then they
take us to uh
to uh scuba dive in this Bay called an
NAU Bay this sounds like sounds like a
trip bu you guys with the white white
skin burning up in the the sun this
one Andy America he went on to be editor
of Game Informer so he went he could
swim pretty well so he went way out uh
looking for sea
turtles I love this
and he came back he's like you know he's
like he's got a weird look out his
face he had hit the coral man and his
like
legs oh no went too far man like you
know that's that's you you went off the
map he went off the
map they just just tell you go
back he wasn't listening to the
[Laughter]
notification yeah so was it was a it was
a good that's what I remember about
Final Fantasy 7 nice beyond the game you
know that it was they they were Square
was really proud what they had done they
felt it was like the ultimate in Final
Fantasy experience and people still like
Final Fantasy 7 of favorite that's me
that's me I'm the seven Fanboy but cuz I
remember to your point but what what we
consider it um King like was it
pre-rendered backgrounds no no not
everything oh you talk about the um how
good it looked
like pre render backgrounds with small
polygons with the polygons right and
then and then the Cinematic nature of
the like just with the opening and the
cut scenes like this the first time the
media so a lot of people thought the cut
scenes were the game yeah true all right
so to to to an extent it is the game
they just rendered it on a PC and it's a
video that you don't get to control but
our ignorant behinds did not understand
that at that time because we came from
actual Graphics in every game the fact
that we're watching this movie right and
the sound quality was second and none I
think nailed it with the voice acting
sound quality and everything from there
it and and how it started up I don't I
don't know for me Final Fantasy was
incredible yeah it changed the game it
changed the game for sure when I was
going to if you finish I was going to
ask R another question yeah of course
yeah yeah that's soon then I I wrote the
review they gave me like 300 words I I
have so much to say how am I gonna say
it but uh it was all good it was the you
know the first one of my first trips for
for particular line of work and it was
it was cool man I always remember that
that's awesome Harold's got stories for
days I love it like amazing I like the
Hawaii Story the best right now yeah the
Hawaii story for Final Fantasy like
never i' never been to Hawaii before
it's really oh me the cre salute so the
right like again you rocking at
Brother's PlayStation you're you're
Nintendo you're doing what you're doing
and then from there you just continue on
I just trying to finish up the rest of
the uh console hierarchy like the where
where it went from there so the the Wii
like was where I went right when we got
to that shift and I was really lucky
that at the time my brother was like
dating a girl who worked at an FY
one to the side and I believe if I'm not
I think the Wii dropped on my birthday
wow so it was like the greatest greatest
thing ever and like I I was so obsessed
with just like the me creation aspect of
that system Y and like it's funny
because like at the at the start of that
like the the motion controls like felt
so incredible and so like nuanced and
you look back and it's like some of that
stuff was just so and like really really
basic to to what we can do now with with
VR and all things but like it was such a
fun thing to do that I could bring
anyone in my family like we would bring
it to Thanksgiving and like everyone was
playing it absolutely my grandmother who
like who had like Alzheimer's and
Dementia like really struggled and
sometimes didn't know who we were but
play that with us she could grasp
because she understood the simple
concepts of bowling and we play it with
us and like so many memories that that I
have from her like are in those little
moments of being like Oh like we were
able to make her laugh again hang out
with her and like even though she didn't
know I was her grandson she had a good
time with me and that's cool I shared
that with with Reggie when we did um he
did an interview with my class back when
I was still teaching and I was just like
I I got to just say like thank you for
pushing for packing that in I never had
that moment and and that that's
something that means so much to me yeah
I I just want to stop you real quick cuz
that is so profound in the sense that
you know the Nintendo Wii opened the
doors for I felt so many non Gamers to
try gaming and and I remember how big a
boon it was at its time like it was
selling like hot cakes you couldn't find
it it was yeah New York right KB and
like it was the item I remember it like
it just it was like it was like we and
like tickle elbow or something like one
these are like the top things that you
couldn't find anymore but continue Ryan
cuz you are preaching in terms of the
Nintendo Wii and its impact people
forget how impactful it was yes I mean I
was like really ingrained in that and
that's when I kind of started drifting
away from other consoles at the time
like my brother was like working and and
would buy his own system so he was on
PS3 and Xbox 360 I would hang out with
him and play Guitar Hero and do stuff
like that but like it started to Wayne
at the end of the Wii cuz I then went
away to colge
I was busy with you know learning to
become a writer then an architect then
an artist then a teacher then not a
teacher than a writer again and then
somehow came back into being a teacher
and now running an organization about
teaching writing so it all came together
in the end but during those times I
didn't really play as much um like one
of my college roommates and I would like
hang out and play Super Smash Brothers
Brawl like in our apartment like
whenever and like we're going to go out
to the bars and I was like we're going
to hang out and play Brawl like I
Smash
Bro Smash
Bro was the most I was doing at that
time and once I got out of school and
like was figuring myself out took took a
lot of time my my brother and I you know
got back together and started hanging
out more and that's when like I think
like the new stage of of my interaction
with video games I wasn't just a player
I was then part of just the community
where like we would hang out and we
would like every E3 we would hang out
and watch and watch co- streams and
watch all the follow-ups and like that
became the the new part of our
relationship where it wasn't just that
we played games together but we talked
about the industry we talked about what
was going on and like I have just all
these memories like hanging out in my
brother's basement and him being so
excited for Fallout 76 and then 6 months
later him being so upset about Fallout
Reas but all of those moments were were
just so so big for us and like we built
this this language around that and like
I was just out of school I didn't know
what I was doing and he's a a union
worker in the city does building
management those was awesome stuff and
was making some good money and like he's
always been so like gracious to me and
like wants me to be part of that
conversation so he would just like he
bought me like the my first switch he
was like like oh I know you loved
Nintendo I know you kind of skipped out
for he's like but you're going to love
this you're going to love this new Zelda
game like you have to get back in and
then he was like you know you're driving
in out of work you need to listen to the
kind of funny podcast they they talk
about every single day like and then it
just snowballed into all these other
podcasts we were listening to and it it
became a really core part of my life at
the time while I was becoming a teacher
so then that's when it started to fold
into well games are now somehow going to
become part of how I teach because this
is part of how I'm identifying myself
and it just built and built and built
and now I'm suddenly here which I never
thought I would be yeah um but yeah it's
it's been a wild Journey but it's it's
really surprising to a lot of people
when I talk about like how important
games are to my everyday life to my
relationships to all to all of that um
but it's you know it's great to be able
to talk to like-minded people who get it
where it's like I need to sit and
explain it to you for half an hour no
it's awesome no no no no we love this
stuff and um I I think personally you
know it really resonated when you you
accepted your award as well and and you
were talking about that Journey at New
York game awards last year and um you
know in regards to you know uh joining
the circle so I I I really felt that
connection um it's tremendous it's
tremendous the the effect that that that
has in then I just want to quickly
transition because you set it up in
reference to you know teaching and I was
obviously you know in in the Bronx and
and and you know me in three4 of the
Lord's we know that that is a little
rough yeah you
know seventh and eth grade was it mod
Hall 3 at the time you know EOB treat so
um you know why was you know cuz this is
what I got from the speech like why was
marrying video games and and and and
education like so important to you so
there there was a point
where New York City Department of
Education did this thing where um they
had everyone do
mandatory like like bias training so
like going in and like talking with
people and you know like you're you're
told to do anything in a job that's like
outside of your your purvey of what
you're supposed to do you're like what
what a waste of my time I should be in
the classroom helping the kids and like
there was like a day off where I had to
go do this seminar and someone was
covered my classes and I'm freaking out
but it ended up being this like really
great thing where we were talking about
you know how do you make connections
with your kids like and it was always
difficult for me at the start
because I'm you know very different than
the students that I was teaching right I
grew up on Long Island going into the
South Bronx and my thought process on
was like how do I connect with these
kids and I I've seen a lot of
teachers who are just like I'm going to
adapt to be what the kid want me to be
and that doesn't work right that's not
genuine like like I remember like being
in grad school and someone's like yeah
I've been listening to a lot of hip-hop
I'm like you're a come
on like stop relationship or you're
trying to like and I think the heart's
in the right place right yeah they try
they try to relate but what I started to
learn and you know what I when I talk to
other teachers in in this place they're
like well just being
you is is enough right you be you the
kids who are connected to who you are
will'll find you and not everyone's
going to love who you are that's that's
the world that's normal so like I
started to like think about that and I
was like well I care about games I know
some of my kids care about games and we
I just started to you know bring that
into part of just you know you have to
sneak it in because you can't always do
it you've got Administration breathing
down like of course
right I'm not going to roll in with my
PS4 and my
backpack throw away your books like that
wasn't G to happen but I would I would
sneak it into like we would do like
non-fiction right like let's talk about
cause and effect and I might have pulled
like an article from IGN and we're
talking about like record sales like
what was the cause of the record sales
and we're looking into things like that
and then when I started to figure out
more and more what these kids liked I
was able to then pinpoint to like oh you
love this game game too like you want to
hang out lunch talk about games great we
would hang out lunch talk about games
and those relationships really started
to to build and Blossom um and then we
went into the pandemic and everything
fell apart but what what ended up
happening and I think I told this dur
during my speech last year was part of
what we had to do was we would check in
with the students who weren't showing up
to class or who would show up class but
their screens were black on on your Zoom
call right addict I'm watching you
got you ad me the kid you and your
teacher mod right now you looking at the
zoom call this is this is the pandemic
area that one kid Ain got his scen what
are you doing what are you doing so what
what ended up happening was like we
would be assigned different students to
do check-ins with and the conversation
from all of the other teachers was like
well kids aren't doing work they're
playing fortnite and I was like why why
do you think like they are and like were
times where it's like I should be
grading their papers right now but I'm
playing fortnite they just dropped the
Marvel pack you think
I'm in my apartment
alone running around as Captain
America so you know I had empathy
whereas all the other teachers were were
there to to place blame right look for
whatever this issue was and I started to
do do what I was doing then right is
Animal Crossing was huge I in my Animal
Crossing house on the second floor like
built a classroom and I would put it in
my slot and like then we were reading
The Outsiders and spoilers for The
Outsiders they murder it so I built like
the Fountain area and I had like a patch
of Blood on the floor and I found a
leather jacket for my Animal Crossing
character and I would like create scenes
from the book in Animal Crossing cuz the
kids were like oh I'm playing Animal
Crossing and then they'd be like okay
like Mr can you show us like your Island
and I was
like if you if everyone passes this test
those who pass can come and see an
animal crossing tour and like started
incentivize incentivize it I liked it it
became really really fun and while I was
doing that traveling I then found um the
podcast that Harold did with Reggie and
I started to learn about what they were
doing and I emailed the website I didn't
know I was talking to Harold at the time
but I was like love to be you know part
of this and it it took time because we
had to have a pandemic come to an end we
had to get administration to agree um
but I just started to Pepper all of
those things in and I would pull
memories from you know what I felt were
teaching moments in games if um I don't
know if anyone know like you know
Adventure or it's Colossal Cave
Adventure text based
RPG but tech text Adventure so my aunt
had an Apple 2 in her basement and
before we even I think had consoles that
was kind of just like my mom would stop
over and like have a cup of tea with her
and I'd be in the basement just playing
around on
the found adventure and I didn't know
what it was but then I started to learn
these really simple sentence
structures walk North open door and like
in really really simple phonics and
sentence structure right where we're
actually building sentences and I was
like this actually had a lot of impact
on how I was figuring out how to just
write as a really really young person so
I found a fully emulated version of it
on a web browser at a day in my class
where I had been doing these writing
workshops Where My Philosophy was come
hang out write you'll get a prompt I'm
going to teach you a few things on how
to combat writers block but the goal is
you're going to write for 30 minutes and
you're not going to stop you're not
allowed to stop and then it became more
and more creative on how we we launched
the prompt so one of them became all
right everybody he's this game called
Colossal Cave Adventure M here's how you
play it you have 15 minutes to play yeah
and then when the 15 minutes were up I
asked around like what' you do what' you
get into some people didn't even find
the door some people like died because
they shook a tree and a coconut fell on
their
head things happened but I was like
great so from wherever you left off this
is now the start of your story oh so
they were able to then take their
experience yes and move forward and I
was building more and more of these
these moments into to what I was doing
and then things finally leveled out with
working with Harold and ran the after
school program for for two years at my
school and like that was the most
gratifying teaching I had ever done I
built so many great relationships with
my kids I was connecting with students
on their levels and it worked and it was
never it wasn't always approved by
Administration they didn't always love
it
me low
sometimes on it be like you don't you
don't get it um but you know I I was
really proud of the work work that I was
doing then that's awesome and you know I
I miss having those moments and I'm
excited as we're moving into working in
more schools that I can go back into the
classroom and and do those things again
hold hold that thought right because I
got to be respectful of har he he's on
he's on time limit right now he's
getting closer so want to make sure we
get her out on time cuz this is
brilliant stuff and and go right back to
this education but I got to get her
before it goes as far as um you know
obviously introduced being introduced to
Ryan seeing him in the classroom and
then him joining the circle and then
before you go also just get us excited
about you know what's going on with you
in the circle and then um obviously the
game awards sure so um I I'll take it up
when from when Ryan contacted me we had
already been at a really cool school uh
up up in the bronze called
dreamyard uh prep school and then which
had become BR BX start BX start was
inspired by our work dreamyard so we had
had uh rudimentary and considered very
good journalism game journals of 101
class so we took that to uh to
Ryan and uh our young interns were ready
to be mentors as well
okay assistant mentors so they would
come with me or with Sheree or Whitney
MIRS to Ryan's class but we
honestly Ryan had already primed these
kids that this was G to be h a games
journalism class it's not just going to
be only playing games we did some
playing was after the after the work had
been done right and uh when it came time
here that I had raised enough money to
uh hire an executive director M um I
looked at you know the board I looked at
mainly me though uh 225 resumes right
and at the end we went back to Ryan
because there really wasn't anyone who
had everything that we wanted except
checked that right checked every box I
lot
this so it was important for us to bring
Ryan on so he's been with us about
uh six seven months now and uh and and
and learns more every day he a great
help to me you know was one person doing
it and uh which was me and it's not
enough to to make a nonprofit grow
enough so with with now that there's two
of us I think that you know we're we're
even even more uh powerful as a as a
nonprofit that seeks to help underserved
and nonous kids um Le about writing so
so so we're we're we're spreading out
we're growing we we this year we hired
uh twice as many insns as we had in the
past I think we have about 20 of them so
that's good and
really Barry the the important thing
about the New York game awards is that
it's a troan horse for our nonprofit uh
activity with underserved kids so get to
see all these awesome people you get to
see Neil Dr the I can't wait can't wait
uh you know I've known Neil since his
Uncharted days and I you I'll tell the
story of how uh Alysa from Sony said hey
you should talk to Neil Neil was sitting
well actually sitting on the floor at E3
up against the Stony Booth who is the
dude sitting down there so cool you know
and I sat down there on the floor at E3
with him we had this long conversation
that wasn't just about Uncharted it was
about you know books and and uh uh you
know the way we are now as people and
you know he was he was clearly U an an
important guy with a lot of ideas who
then came up with the last of us and he
really changed culture so that's why we
are honoring him with our Andrew Yun
legend legend yeah so Andrew Yun was one
of our founding members who who died uh
too soon so we named this Legend award
after we created a legend award because
of and Andrew passing because Andrew
himself was a legend so his his father
and brother will be there uh I think for
the first time Tuesday so we'll we'll
shout out to them but but yeah so we've
got this cool thing going called the New
York game awards you can find out
tickets at uh you can find we only have
about 20 25 tickets left but you should
come go to nyame critics. comom and see
if you can procure those tickets yes so
put the link in the description while
you talking keep talking yeah man it's
going to be it's it's going to be great
you know we've got uh really great
musician named Kim hackey or Kimberly
hockey and U I've seen her perform all
around uh Upstate New York in the cat
skills she is just gonna blow everyone
away with her her set and uh we've got
you know famous journalist named James
lead better who's going to do uh present
our journalism award
you know James I've known since the
1990s he was a media critic at the
Village Voice so if you don't know what
the Village Voice oh yeah Village Voice
was like a classic newspaper that was
kind of
counterculture and uhh James was keeping
uh all the media Types on their toes
because he was Fearless in covering so
he's still around he writes books now
he's the uh editor executive editor of
Observer which is uh
just getting better and better and uh
you know we have Reggie on stage as
usual
legend legend total Legend yeah yeah so
Reggie got awarded her 10th
Awards we were just honored to have him
and since he's from the Bronx he knew
that we were doing a lot of our work in
the Bronx he joined us as our board memb
so uh Reggie is Reggie comes and is is
co-host and Shel Smith
the first woman of color to run a tech
publication in the
world so Sheree will be on stage she's G
she's a Powerhouse yes love the gonna
rock the
house with anything she says so so we're
we think you know I've written the
script like three four five times now I
think SCP is script is good man it's
it's you know probably it could be
better but we've only we've got to do it
on Tuesday and it's pretty good right
now and then we
have and we have iron Lord with us and I
don't know if you know who they are yeah
these Lords gu these ey heard of them
they might they might be in the building
they might be S like they got
class yeah yeah yeah they've they got
class and they're gonna be on stage
presenting an award so it's gonna be
it's gonna be great Neil's bringing a
crew um I think hie gross is going to be
there hie was co-writer and Last of Us
two she's very talented uh uh writer so
she she'll be in the house as well so
it's gonna be great man I hope everyone
could come if they can't come uh watch
us on YouTube or twitch Absolutely I'll
put the link in the description go check
that out again if you could be in the
house with us like I said the New York
game awards on Tuesday come check that
out and then again if you can't be in
the house like you said Carol said you
can stream it and then also make sure
you support because again the work that
is being done here here for underserved
communities is truly special and just
kind of the marriage of Journalism and
video games is just really special and
last thing I want to give you your Kudos
is um I really appreciate how you give
the game developers their flowers right
and the focus be towards that because to
me they are the creators they are the
ones that give you know these experien
to life that as Ryan put like that truly
shape us that Inspire us you know he's
using it in in curriculum as a former
teacher and for us you know that made us
say hey this is something we want to do
we're older so you know we come from the
era where gaming was always frowned upon
you're never going to get nothing doing
that you know what I'm saying like you
know that kind of energy so to see you
guys give the focus to you know uh an
Neal and and obviously you know Phil uh
last year and just even the developers
giving them their time except the let
them let them talk because it's their
moment and get making video games is
hard making video games it's a it's it's
a tough business but I want to thank you
for that how I know you got to go get on
your yeah well you know one thing I want
to say is you know we you'll also see
our interns on stage they have to create
the show abolutely these are young
people that you know really uh are
deserving of awards themselves uh Neal
was kind enough to do the series of
interviews with
us and our our young students uh
presented him was really interesting
sometimes tough questions and Neal was
very gracious of his time he you know on
Instagram always
reposts what Ryan puts up uh of these uh
uh really cool interviews that that Neil
and our students have done so it's um
it's great all around it is for a very
good cause yes we need you to support
our
cause and to help us teach young people
in the Bronx and the uh in Brooklyn
where they they just think that uh they
could never get a job in games or
journalism Ryan and I and
Sheree R Gordon Isaac Espinosa were all
out there making sure that kids know
that they can get jobs and games and
jobs and games journalism or journalism
if they want
to powerful stuff man again wish I had
that when I was this is amazing oh man
any outros to how before he goes uh Lord
uh addict and Lord sof
absolutely I mean excited for Tuesday
happy happy to be invited back and uh
it's going to be cool to be there with
everybody with Neil and with you guys
again um yeah like King said last year
soon as we walked through the door and
we saw what it was as soon as we knew
that there was something New York
Centric it had to do with video games
everything you know we've loved video
games all our lives but it's it's always
been centered around the the West Coast
so to see you know as soon as play in YC
became a thing and we knew about that we
shout out to our boy Dan butko Danko
yeah so it was it was just one of those
things like anything that's that's
centered around New York City our
homeown we want to be a part of and be
you know and Aid in growing it as much
as possible so again thank you for
having us and see you on Tuesday no
doubt Lord see you guys on Tuesday man
thank you thanks for having me on Ryan
Ryan's gonna take it for y y you gotta
go we'll see you Tuesday
Legend all right Harold have a good one
brother Tuesday no question Tuesday man
we'll see you on Tuesday at the New York
game Wars take care take care take care
no doubt so yeah L Ry I want to get back
to you you know in terms of um like I
said you were you know my three stuff
t-shir in the Bronx and then you know
the challenges one thing you said like
the challenges of uh you know kind of
incorporating video games we's say into
the curriculum or just you know the way
creative way you're using it and the
reason why I I think it's really
important because s relat to us like you
know my mom you know was a teacher and
you know s my mom was youed to teach us
stuff as well so um to me it's like
video games was always the enemy in the
household like it was just that's just
how it was like I said you know you're
not going to do anything doing this
wasting time so like you kind of alluded
to this with the with the the challenges
of the board you know what I'm saying
with kind of that mentality and then
youp so how do you fight the good fight
to keep kind of getting that in
at the time I mean it's kind of like the
the tried and true of like ask for
forgiveness don't ask for
permission like because like you know
when especially with video games like
obviously it's changed a lot but in
certain worlds it hasn't right in the
world of Education when you know like at
the time I I was definitely one of the
younger people on staff yeah versus you
know an older generation who isn't in
that realm who doesn't understand
they're going to shoot it down from the
jump it doesn't matter how you pitch it
you have to prove it's worth yep and so
you know I was able to take like I said
those conversations that I had with you
know with kids when we were one on-one
or I was able to look at you know when
we even just wrote about games
journalism you know where that went and
then you know by the time it got
to you know I was you know I was seven
years a teacher by my fifth year I felt
like I finally understood what I was
doing um and I kind of just built that
confidence of like I'm going to create
something where people around me will
trust me so for me it was working on
creative writing my my bachelor's degree
was in writing and I built this really
strong community in my classroom like I
said where it's like the expectation is
you you write for 30 minutes and it
became this really regimented we do this
every Friday I play music mus in the
background we have a different creative
way of doing it and once you know they
didn't even like that concept which is
you know like if you don't like a
concept of like I'm going to get kids to
write for an elongated period of time
yeah like it's there's so much in in
teaching and there's so much
expectations and there's different
rubrics for grading teachers and when
you have so many levels of people
watching you it's really hard to do what
you think is best because you have to
ask permission you have to ask
permission and it kind of goes back to
you know what I was saying to King about
tattoos right I my belief is I trust you
as a professional and I will let you do
your thing right and I hit a point in my
career where I was like well you need to
trust me as a professional right you
need to trust that my intention is
what's best for the kids is what's best
for their
education and that's it I would just
start going from that point of view the
the only Reas reason why they were
giving you push back is because the
school system is not taught to think to
to um Foster free thought you you you're
bringing free thought into uh the
equation and that is a a a variable that
they're not comfortable with when I was
working for the New York City Housing
Authority I would bring video games in
to the the ecosystem in order to bond
with the children so I was resonating
with everything that you were saying
with don't change yourself to match the
children but be yourself so the children
can attract to you and it's you know
like you know um you know birds of a
feather flock together you know bees
like honey stuff like that is is those
Concepts in where you bring them
McGuffin you show interest in what it is
and those that satellite around will
convert those that are on the periphery
of the situation and I would bring um my
Nintendo I got a famicom so this is when
Nintendo wasn't here yet and I would
bring games up to to to Foster this uh
huge interest but the caveat was you
must behave yourself from
school um we will do y'all homework in a
timely fashion and then we will all
partake in the video game session
incentivizing it and that galvanized
them to the point where they will
automatically come in get that snack
open up their books get down to the
homework no problems before it was
rowdiness and
everybody understand shout out to the
riness you know they come in they didn't
have Direction and it will drive the
staff mad and I uh calmed it and what I
did with that and and I'm just going to
you know get off me for second but what
I did with that is because I had one of
my um senior directors come in and he
didn't understand why they were so quiet
why they was so studient and what they
were doing and what what was going on
here cuz it changed like that I explain
to him we had a budget for video games
in every community center after that
because with the initiative that I put
in it
transformed the behavior of the children
and they saw it it was tangible so I
understand that you have to show them
that it's able to work in in the
environment that will it will yield
results because the mentality is this is
going to disrupt what our objective is
and it's not what it is is going to
become a vehicle to get to objective a
whole lot faster and more efficiently
because you're bonding with the children
that will adhere to this oh part because
you're You're Building trust right
you're building through a shared passion
and like that you can't you can't create
that out of thin air
right and in institutions like that you
you know it's and I understand like even
as like an executive director right I
want to organize and make sure that
everything is regimented and there's a
way that things are done but you can't
regiment trust you can't regiment
relationships you can't do that you can
only bring yourself to that and bring
the things that you care about and like
that's exactly what you did yes and I'm
and I'm resoning with I know the
children that you were dealing with
going to the Bronx okay so you're coming
from a lot of children have single
parent households a lot of children are
dealing with poverty a lot of children
are dealing with a lot of issues that
children shouldn't be dealing with so
what you have to do is get past all
these barriers as you're coming in and
then you don't look like you're from the
population so now you have an extra
barrier that maybe I didn't have that
you have that you have to you know break
down in the children and trust is the
only way and children can smell a fraud
a mile
factual that's factual that's factual no
this is good stuff and then you know
you're doing this you know continue I
want you to finish your thought but you
had going I mean Ryan and and I want to
ask you something in reference to the
transition then from from there into to
a director because that's a big step
you're a teacher for a long time but I
just want you to finish and if you had
any more uh thoughts with reference to
yeah no I mean kind of just like
bouncing off you know like like what
king was saying is like
you know going into a room as an
educator and I started teaching because
I I knew some people who weren't good
teachers and the system is built in a
way that you complete x amount of years
and you're kind of bulletproof in some
senses yes um and I from you know
certain standpoints of course I'm all
for that um and I needed that in a lot
of Senses too right when you don't have
trust even when you're doing the right
thing but when I when I was looking at
some of these people who I was like you
shouldn't be in the
classroom the question was like what can
I do about that and like I can't do
anything about that person but the only
thing I can do is become the person I
think needs to be in the classroom right
and what I always said when you know I
went into a classroom when I met a new
group of kids when whenever I did
anything is I'm here to be with people
right of course I have this agenda of
teaching I have this curriculum I have
to complete but at the end of the day
I'm dealing with people first and you
need to know who these people are you
need to learn about them you need to
show your true self to them and and
connect with that because if you don't
do any of those things as much as you
can educate you're not going to get that
respect you're not going to get that get
any of it and you know like some years
that was harder than others you know
some years it some years it was insanely
better than others like I I had a group
two years ago um which was the first
year that I worked with Harold and like
they just vibed with me and like it just
all the stars aligned I don't know what
happened but like they thought I was
funny like I had kids who were like look
at this corny
like this group same material loved it
so like we really vibed together um
three of them are now interns at the
critic Circle nice so like I'm so
excited that I get to work with them and
talk with them and then I had a group
last year who was just like complete
oppos like get this guy out of my face
oh these kids man and like like I was
like Gob smacked to I was like I'm being
my truest self I've ever been you are
just not you're just not vibing with it
and that's okay like we'll figure it out
we'll you know and then you work with
people on an individual level and things
change and grow but you know it's it's
an everchanging ecosystem and like I I
miss a lot of that portion but now
being where I am like my perspective on
like why I made the shift was like join
the new I love what I was doing I was
really excited to have some sort of
impact and help right but you know I was
doing that for 30 60 90 kids a year
right now the goal is as we're working
on the critic Circle and expanding is
you know I can reach so many more
students with the thing that I'm
passionate about and hopefully really
spur big change not just in their
communities but you know in long term we
hope that it really changes the
industry what the industry looks like
from the inside because you know giving
opportunity to people who are either
unaware of the opportunities or are just
you know always not brought to the table
you know that that makes a change and
the hope is that we continue to make
that change and you know bring that into
the future yeah no this is this is
fantastic stuff because again you know a
lot of you know again we talked about
growing up we just didn't no we didn't
have these opportunities we didn't know
about them no one came to my school and
you know tried to implement or at least
relate to the passion that we had for
video games right so then you've got
that then you got the journalism aspect
then you've got providing opportunity to
say okay here is a path for you to the
games industry and I think that's
important you know even now you know
being at my age now like it you real
it's still hard like you still have
obstacles you know and me and S had deep
conversations about this recently you
know in reference to you know just how
difficult is it was always I guess for
me Laura it was always looked at as such
uh either from a playing video games or
you're not being productive or you know
when you're you know if trying to get in
gaming industry oh you know it's
volatile you need a traditional 9 to5
you can't do nothing with this like what
do you think you're doing kind of thing
so for for Our Generation it was always
kind of back burner and you you just got
lucky or you've been you know the right
situation type time so I think it is
important for the new generation right
to understand that there is a path there
and and providing that but what I I want
to talk to you about is in reference to
like I said the transition because you
are jumping now out of teaching you you
still have that that knowledge but now
you're moving into the New York video
games critical Circle and for some you
know and I'm sure for you like at so a
little part of you like it's a little
scary maybe you know so like what was
the thing that put it over the top that
says okay I'm doing this I am now going
to be the executive director I'm going
to accept this position to do this work
with Harold in New York video games
critic Circle yeah I I mean it it goes
back to kind of just like the first year
that we were working together which was
I I never thought it would be like at
this level that I'd be working with a
circle but I would always you know sign
off my emails with Harold like if we
were checking in on the class like you
know like happy to help if if you need
anything because like that that was the
truth of it like I really loved what I
was seeing and at the level that I saw
of what Harold was building and
implementing like I wanted to be part of
something like that even if it's
something I can't do at my own school
because I can't convince anybody and
then you know one year ago when I was at
the game awards like like you guys were
saying right like you walked into that
room and you're like oh yeah like yeah
like I knew how great it was in my
classroom and then I was like oh like
this is trusted by a
community and like people stand by this
they believe in this and like I want to
be part of that in any way that I can so
I I was ready to you know in my head it
was like oh maybe I'll be like you know
their summer camp counselor teacher who
helps out of the summer instead of doing
summer school and you know we had our
you know our back and forth Sports and
we were back at my school doing an after
school program and I was just uh I gave
Harold a ride to the train and he had
just kind of pitched this to me and was
like you know we're we're looking for a
new executive director would you be
interested and in my head I'm like this
is like Willie Wonka kind of nonsense
like why why are you trusting the kid
who just stumbled into the candy
store got on his face
so it took a little bit of time and I
you know I was like you know I I
definitely would like to to apply and
and you know talk you know more about it
and what you're looking for and kind of
just went there and it was like four
five months of just interviews and you
know answering questions and checking I
had to do a one-on-one job interview
with Reggie baby yeah yeah what want
let's go let's go let's go talk about
the interview process in my
life like being like I I'm having a
conversation with someone I respect so
much yeah and like grew up like watching
him on you know E3 things and like but
this also has like an end result that I
want those things I gotta play cool I
what I did learn really really quick and
like you know like it's a testament of
even just like this conversation we're
having right now is
like every time I've had to speak with
someone
within the games industry around this
you know initiative around you know the
nonprofit around the critic circle like
everyone is has their heart in it yes
and everyone is accommodating and
they're kind and like whenever I think
about like talking to people from job
interviews or through corporate
structures I'm always like I'm the low
guy on the totem pole I'm going to show
respect and like but then it's like oh
like we're all just kids hanging out
talking about a thing we love right like
at the end of the day day and um I I
spoke with I went
to um games for change for the circle
and I ran into um Andrea Renee from
what's good games and she fun oh yeah it
was my first convention it was my first
time like talking with people and I was
like I'm I sat down next to her I didn't
realize was like oh like like I know you
very like
nice so she picked up I think on how
like nervous I was but it was asking
what I did and I had said like you know
like this is my first big conference
sort of thing and I'm just used to
talking to like 12 and 13 year olds a b
she like here's the secret you still are
like she's like we're all just hanging
out talking about games like you're
going to have those exact same
conversations like you'll be fine and
like from that I was like okay I can do
this like I can handle this like I'm
knowledgeable about this thing like I'm
sharing this passion I can have these
conversations I can share what I love
and and we be good and and that
conversation like really just gave me
that push that I felt that I I needed to
just be like I can do this I'm not I'm
not having imposter syndrome anymore
part of this this is what I'm doing and
you know it's been it's been wild yeah
but but for for the job itself I went
through all the job interviews and did
the thing and I I got the email on the
bus coming back from field day I was
like just
compartmentalizing to the kids we're not
going to lose our mind we're not going
to get excited and you we just kind of
went from there and and now we're here
and now we're six seven months in but I
still got to ask you the question which
is you you're doing a big thing like it
the the step like as far as like again
as a person I relate as a person who's
always been in it and that's been you
know that's the path I'm supposed to be
doing I'm supposed to be you know kind
of thing and then to accept something
that is really in the games industry you
know like where is there any trepidation
like am I doing the right thing by
leaving cuz I have to put your business
out there like my mom's teacher I know
Board of Ed the benefits The Summer's
off the mon like there's a stability to
that right yeah so that's my part like I
want to know like was their tration like
okay let's go yeah I mean 100% right
like so um my fiance is a teacher as
well so like we are we are living in or
we're living in the like Summer's off
we're going doing what we need to do you
know um I had we had just bought a house
we getting married in July all these
things lined up and all of that is built
from you know I've for these last seven
years I got my tenure I've got benefits
good like I've got my retirement plan
going and now I'm like I'm G to make
this transition and it's like all right
I gotta pay the mortgage yeah yeah real
life let's get to the real life part
yeah I've already got like I got the DJ
booked
like yeah is this going to be a forever
thing will this work and you know it you
know I I talked with Harold I talked
with Reggie and like you know I I feel
really grateful in the sense that with
what we're doing right now and with what
I'm doing
like I have really strong mentor who
have been doing this whether it's you
know Herald from the journalism side and
what he's built here being able to check
in with Reggie who's on our board or Ted
who's on our board or Katherine who's on
our board and they share you know what
they've done throughout their lives and
you know are helping guide with what I'm
trying to do with helping you know make
the circle stronger um so like that part
of it meant a lot to me and that's like
I'm really passionate about games I'm
really passionate about education I can
do them both as a career the financial
part we can figure out we can we can get
that done we can lose Summers we can cry
that it'll be
okay you get to play games every day
yeah that's true that's true like I I I
was talking to my fiance the other day I
was like like oh like we have to do our
taxes like can I write off my games this
year write off my games this
year
work like like you said There Was Fear
because I was leaving the most well
structured career I could have wanted
right I could have done that until the
rest of my life and I would have been
happy y i loved what I was doing I
didn't leave on a sour note it wasn't
like I'm tired of teaching kids are the
worst like I loved teaching I love being
around kids I love like being in that
world like everyone when I told them I
taught seventh grade was always like who
who
seven where you're like I'm going to try
on every version of myself yes and I
from day one I was like 90% of teaching
is
improv today yes and let's go I will
take you for who you are today whoever
you want to be the good one the bad one
will see the reactions but like I'm not
going to tell you you're not who you say
you are like just be you it's cool feel
and I think that really benefited me and
I I miss those parts of it
but I I can see what this future can
and I want the the longevity of the
critic Circle and how it can expand and
and how the playing with purpose program
can expand and connect with more
students like to be part of that and to
have a say in what that is meant a lot
to me and you know like you know my
fiance and I had a lot of conversations
about it and you know the financial side
versus just the versus just like the
passion side and like I to be able to
wake up
20 feet from my office and you know do
something I'm passionate about every day
means a lot to me absolutely takes a lot
of discipline oh yeah takes yeah takes a
lot of discipline because you know um I
know a lot of people weren't ready for
you know work working at home or working
in their uh home
environment that level of discipline was
built up over the time with you getting
your curriculum getting to school on
time you know having that commitment now
is a different level of commitment
getting up doing that work right there
instead of saying let me get the extra
five minutes in bed or let me get the
extra five minutes doing this it it's
it's different and those people that had
to work from home during this pic we
found out some people weren't
disciplined they had to get back to work
but I guess that was part of the
training that I didn't realize right I
taught for two years in a in a
one-bedroom apartment now you know
manage this a little bit better yeah he
was always prepared for this space for
this moment no that that's super cool
super dope again I just I don't know if
adct still around cuz I know he's going
through I'm feeling well but I was yeah
I was going to ask you adct like um you
know we were talking for us but like for
you like does that resonate like did you
wish like when you were going to school
cuz you know ask the Young Buck of the
group you know as far as like you know
having programs that either introduced
video games into the curriculum and
stuff like that or just you know things
like the critic Circle which is you know
trying to show kids that hey there's a
path you know to to get into the games
industry through journalism stuff like
that would would you be interested in
that or you know is there what was did
you have any any of that when you were
in school no that that was that was a
myth
happen the problem is is there was no
money to be made so no one was going to
do anything like that so you know I
would say there's you know because of
how big the industry's gotten there's a
lot more money to be made so more people
are interested in doing it but when I
was growing up there there was nothing
like that it it was like go to call like
my generation was pushed heavy to go to
college like heavy so from the time I
got to elementary school you you need to
go to college this you need to go to
college for that that's what my
generation was
pushed that's interesting I'm glad you
said that cuz you know just here these
experiences and um you know again I'm
I'm just jealous I'm like damn if we had
like yeah yeahor I want to do it like
because if it's something that I wanted
like to be able to now give that to
is so sorry continue no like and and
like kind of just like going off of like
what what actually was saying is like a
thing that I noticed and you know
outside of the the games journalism
thing the one thing that I was really
able to reson with with the kids was um
my my mom was born and raised in Ireland
so like first generation she came over
here you know while like you know all
bombings and things were going on and
decided to you know change things up
find a better job and like her
perspective was always you're going to
do better than I did y so many of the
kids that I taught were in that same
mindset where it's like you so like 90%
of the kids are like my mom thinks I'm
going to be a doctor
um and that that's the path that I have
and that can be really difficult
sometimes is like when you have the
defined roles in your life already
planned out for you and even when you
set them for yourself too like I
constantly was like I need to be 100% in
this one thing and only this thing yep
until the end of my life and then I die
and facts this is the second week in a
row that that you know um coming from
expectations of the parents that they
put on the children yeah with Mari yeah
we had a Mari last week and it's it's
very the burden on your shoulders is
very very heavy you know even that
thought process of you telling your kid
you're going to be better than me well
how did you figure out that you were you
and how I'm going to because to the kid
you are the idol right you know the kid
is looking up to you like better than
you you God like what are you talking
about like how I'm going be better than
you so a lot of times we put our
imperfections on the children the
children don't get a chance to see our
imperfections we place these
imperfections on the children and say
you going to be greater than and that's
still just trying to become so these
processes is very hard but the the fact
of the matter is you're growing in a
space where all right now I got to teach
these children how to become and you go
into the seventh and eighth grade they
are becoming at this space m and you're
taking this agile approach to all right
I'm just going to accept the child for
who they are every day that mindset is
God send and now you're in a Critic the
critic Circle where you're dealing with
children that are becoming and you're
giving them a pathway too so I think
that's incredible to see as well you
know so this whole period of time I'm
like listening to you the whole period
of time you were like being bred for
this moment to you know embark on these
children this you know the knowledge I I
can't wait to get to class I was talking
to these dudes about that with the
critic Circle and in the thought process
I do have with education when it comes
to Children yeah yeah absolutely and
that that's a thing that like as we're
working on expanding is like a big part
is getting more people to volunteer to
be able to come into the classroom
because a big part is not just seeing
someone who is successful but seeing all
of the different ways that you can
tackle your passion right like I've been
passionate about video games my whole
life never did I think that teaching
would be the way that I could actually
share that passion there's all these
other ways where it's like if you're an
artist and like you just you know you
love drawing you love creating character
like there's a version of that in the
games industry if you're just good at
math like you can be an accountant in
the games industry like you can find
your pathway to the thing that you love
in a more unique way than I think most
people are ever aware of because think
you know games means I have to code like
yeah you think it's just programing I
got to be an engineer I'm bad at math
yeah I I haven't coded since I tried to
change the background on my
MySpace back to
my
remember yo for sure for sure now that's
real that's real and um shout I'm G
break protocol real quick he's l s s say
just ride had Miss his days playing with
the patients and Kan City Chiefs you got
share the same name as a football you sh
the same games of football oh yeah yeah
yeah my my Google Al algorithm is
destroyed
because appreciate it was great in
college like when I still had Facebook
and I was like people don't need to see
the
pictures no doubt no doubt you were you
I I want to get back to you so you were
about to finish I another question for
you were about to finish about your mom
and then her set path and you you you
were going so seemed like I mean good
good and bad right like as King was
saying like that expectation is really
hard but I think the other thing too is
like
the coming from an immigrant
family the importance of education is
huge yes and that was a thing that like
you know going in blind it was my first
time teaching going into the Bronx was
like parents really cared about their
kids education and they trusted the
teacher because of that yes they came to
this country from you know whether it's
Dominican Republic or or know whether
they came from Ghana or wherever they
came here because they want their kids
to be better so they trusted me and when
I saw that like oh you're trusting me
like at the time this like 20 something
who just rolled out of Leman College
like like I need to then do my best for
of course right and all of that just you
know really built
to I just I just really did love
teaching so much love teaching that's
it's weird to look back at it and think
on it and like be so far removed from
being in the classroom now it's like
it's it's it's weird on some dayss to
realize anymore Ryan you remind me of
and and K could will understand this we
had the same thing where there were some
teachers where we came up um that were
just very special yes um you know we
could talk about the Mrs Jacobs Mrs
Lewis twins uh one of them passed away
actually recently um but it was that
idea of this is a person who despite
coming into to a an environment that can
be less than uh welcoming to especially
especially new teachers especially Green
teachers that are green substitute
teacher you get sub
teacher man substitute teacher to get
that
work some of these situations and to see
that you're not you know because you
talk about the teachers that you've seen
that that that don't belong in the
classroom I guarantee you that a lot of
those teachers didn't start that way
right yeah they would just J by the
experience and and they thought the same
thing like hey this is a secure path for
me I'm going to stay here I may hate it
I may hate these kids at some point and
and that's you know obviously that's not
beneficial to anyone but that's the
reality of the situation and to see
someone like you who still like who
still despite you know having moved on
from it it is you know you still have
that love and that passion you remind me
of those types of teachers that we had
we have we had a few of them that were
just super passionate about teaching and
it made you forget about your
circumstances and for us i' be honest
like I I didn't my circumstances weren't
bad like that cogs were were you know
wasn't the case either there were a lot
of kids in our classes that we knew that
like you know they didn't have a great
place to live they didn't weren't eating
three meals a day or whatever and it was
you know and you could see them uh come
into these classrooms and these teachers
would figure out ways to sort of make
them feel welcome and say hey this is
you're here you're safe here you can
learn here you can be happy here um and
it's it's a thing that you just don't
see enough anymore because of how how
stringent and structured things are that
you know sometimes the empathy leaves it
a little bit and and to see that you
still having that passion for it despite
moving on from it is is is a special
thing so I think in general my question
to you is and you you've alluded to what
you want to do in growing the circle but
long-term like broad overarching thing
what do you see as the future for Circle
what do you want to sort of import
because I talked about how uh you know
New York is slowly but surely growing a
little bit in the game Space but
everything is so West Coast Centric but
I would really want to see New York sort
of explode as as as as um you know and a
corner of the industry that is
continuing to grow I know it's difficult
because when you talk about development
and stuff like that or whatever whether
it's development whether it's journalism
whether it's anything like that it's
just so expensive to be here that
sometimes it's you know it's difficult
so I I just want to know what what's
your broad ranging you know 10 15 years
down the line what do you see for the
circle I mean I think a big thing is
like I kind of talked about it earlier
with like you know in the pandemic is
like games were the enemy right they
they were the reason why kids weren't
doing well and flipping that story yeah
I think is is first and foremost really
important is like in in the The Wider
world now especially with games being a
multi-billion dollar industry right um
the the general public is not where they
were you know back in the 90s or even
the early 2000s when everyone's like GTA
3 is why we have shootings right they
still try damn video games this is the
this is the problem Mortal Kombat
teaches violence oh
yeah I've never seen you know a
13-year-old who learned how to pull a
spine but finish Subzero but but the but
changing that narrative and being able
to really look at games for what they
are which is a medium of Art and you
know looking at you know when you know
it was only seven years but you know the
seven years that I was in education
versus when I grew up and where we kind
of shifted on what was important to
teach where it's like I'm I'm so
grateful that no one told me to teach
where the red firm grows
like but like we have this idea of like
what is important to teach and you know
for us it was always we are reading
books we are only reading books books
are what it is books books books and
then when I was in college there was you
know a big shift into film analysis and
using film in in education and looking
at what that was when when I was growing
up like if a TV was coming on that cart
that meant the teacher was out sick got
we've got a subtitute doesn't know what
to do with themselves yeah right great
days yeah great day you s oh we going to
be just watching something all right but
there was never like curriculum around
that and it evolved into okay well like
we understand that film isn't the
problem it's the content right and
there's good content that we can teach
through film and then as I was teaching
I used comic books a lot and that was in
kind of ear what he's like my spirit
animal yeah we like we needed Ryan when
we was coming up bro continue my school
was really great in a lot of Senses in
that like they were really open to
trusting teachers and like I know I've
said like I got a lot of push back but
they also did give me a lot of trust and
okay in one of the early um my my first
year I even got to do it we had what was
called Talent period so you would spend
um one period a week a teacher could
teach whatever they wanted to as long as
it was approved so like I mean like you
got have some
sense get him out of the room Ted got
the puppet
good I can't I did have a puppeteering
class one
I but yeah but we had like a baking
class we had chess class we had all this
other stuff so I did um a comic making
class and what we would do is like we
would go in we'd hang out we'd read
comics and then my my concept was like
you would either create your own
character or you would put your own spin
on a character so like so like I
remember remember one student a few
years ago like made Bronx
Spider-Man B Spider-Man let's go he he
walked around with a boom box let's go
de
go let's go things like that were were
always really fun and I feel like I've
gone on such a tangent that I've lost
track of what the question was but um
you get but like yeah like I I just I
always loved being able to do those
things and now now I've got it back
where where are we going in the future
so that became more widely accepted from
when I first pitched that you know and
they were like I don't know and you know
I did my due diligence and I knocked on
the right doors I had someone come in
who was an editor at Marvel Comics I did
you know um met with my class and talked
to he did the the Rocket and Groot
series and he talked to them about how
that came to be and walked them through
the Marvel process and then they took
that into making their comics and it was
really fun and I think we're kind of at
a precipice right now where like we
games are less the enemy and we're just
about to get to that Peak where we're
being more comfortable with them being
on the classroom and I think from a
wider range from the Department of
Education from you know whatever powers
that be that can really look at the
really strong benefits of what games can
do whether it's through what we do
through journalism whether it's even
just through analysis of narrative
because like I've never experienced a
better narrative than in a game yeah
like those are the stories that stick
with me because I lived them facts right
because it's it's active you're
participating in it even if it it's not
a even even the most cinematic game it's
not a passive thing because everybody
extracts something different from it
right so yeah I think this it's funny I
was listening to a conversation Around
Just Books uh recently and it was that
idea of like what are kids learning in
the classroom nowadays like are you
teaching what does The Catcher And The
Ride do for a kid today in this mind
modern setting not a whole lot like you
can you can get context about writing
and things of that nature and you can
have deep discussions about it but at
the same time is it engaging them in a
way that is going to matter to them and
cause them to continue to be interested
in what you're talking about right or is
it just going to be this abstract thing
so it's like when you talk about comic
books when you talk about bringing these
people in you know you're keeping them
invested in things that they already
probably like and then you're also
showing them a possible path forward
that is different from what the norm and
what possibly their parents expect from
them so I I think that's a great thing
and and continueing to expand upon that
just it creates people that learn how to
think at an early age because a lot of
times Elementary education right even
into junior high school high school is
is so structured that you don't have
those deeper conversations around the
subject matter it's about you need to
learn this you need to memorize this and
I think one thing I went I went to a
private school for high school so it was
small and it was more you know sort of
like a college environment where you
were always analyzing everything you sit
down at a round table and literally
analyze everything so the learning was
different because you were learning to
to sort of dissect things and think
analytically very young instead of just
saying okay this you have to memorize
this the test is um next week or
something like that and it and it it
what it does is allow it opens you up to
seeing all these different Pathways
forward and this was in the you know in
the 90s but again not everybody had has
the opportunity to be in an environment
like that you know you come back to the
New York Public School System it is very
structured it is sort of stringent and
you know that can feel suffocating to a
kid that is not interested in any of
that stuff that's being taught so yeah
that that's that's great that's amazing
no it's fantastic stuff I do want to
transition I think I'm Sor no please add
please go I was going to say I think
you're going to see a lot more people be
more open because I still see even today
you know parents are still resistant n
you ain't doing this gaming stuff which
you talking about like but what I
noticed when the rise of content
creators and streamers happen that's
when the parents were a little bit more
open-minded to it because it's like okay
not only you know is is my child going
to you know learn multiple different
types of skills he's also going to work
for himself for the most part so you
know I I would
say cuz they're already starting to to
push like content creation and stuff in
college
cuz all all content creation really is
is learning video editing marketing like
you're literally just learning all like
all these skills together and and it's a
way more sustainable than like get a job
working for a company because we've seen
how bad this industry is a lot and just
laying off half the STA for no reason so
I you would see uh that stuff being
pushed in colleges but not pushed into
uh the school environment the reason why
is because the school environment is
structured in a way to build same mind
workers the thought process is you go to
work you go to school from 8 until 3 and
is teaching you how to sit behind the
desk how to take a dictation how to
memorize and how to do the same
routine College you pick your courses
College you start to flex independent
thought in independent Pathways and you
only achieve that by getting to college
what you're trained to in curriculum in
in lower schools this is why we've
changed from the industrial remember we
used to have wood shop you used to have
different Craft um stuff you you had
different programs these stuff was made
to build a different kind of worker
those workers that would be able to run
a shop Management workers and stuff like
that I think we regressed as far as
school teaching goals I think it it
teaches how to be the employee and not
the manager we used to be taught to be
managers and college will teach you to
be supervisors and
owners now you see the rise of the
influencer is teaching you to be the
entrepreneur spirit I think if it's used
wrong it would create a vacuum when it
comes to work environment but if if it's
utilized properly it will create more
CEOs in smaller Pockets that can employ
more people because let's say I start a
channel I'm the CEO I need an editor I
need a cameraman I need this so you in
turn start employees and those employees
can you know dictate different work to
other um employees as well you you will
build a structure I think the school
system is ripe for that now teaching
young influencers to become
entrepreneurs and CEOs across the boards
and I think you will have more of that
happening but I I I don't think that
they're ready for that type of free
thought yet interesting now this is deep
deeper discussion in reference to you
know high school and obviously exactly
we can go on forever on that part but I
I do I do want to transition you know to
um main event which yeah which is um you
know the the the the 13th annual New
York game awards and and obviously you
know the Lords we attended you know our
first one last year we were completely
blown away you know to just to see all
the efforts being made by the circle and
then obviously you know good friend to
the realm Phil Dominus Maximus really
Spen as we call him in the real well you
know he received the you know the Andrew
Yun Legend award and then um you
yourself you won an award you know what
I'm saying was Elizabeth Elizabeth
jetting gram educator of the Year award
so first of all just you know about that
how excited are you about this year's
Awards what do you most looking forward
to you know it's it's been exciting
seeing it on the the other end right
like last year I was there as you know a
participant I was there to you know
receive an award to hang out and do an
Afterparty and have a glass of wine with
Reggie that was wild oh yeah yeah I saw
the pictures the pictures is fire I like
the pictures always pinned to the top of
the yeah you kept that pin you got you
got the Reggie yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you know you can't go back now how let's
go but like from that end you know
thinking about like how I felt and how
excited I was to be there now being on
the back end of it it's like how do I
make sure that everyone who who comes
through feels that same way yes right
because I think you know going back to
you know everything we've talked about
games is like the thing that I love the
most about games at the end of the day
is it's a the game A Game's ability to
create a community right whether it goes
back to you know you know sitting on the
couch with my my brother and my mom and
we had that little community of we're
going to figure out these puzzles in
this game whether it's you know hanging
out with the cousins on the holiday
playing Super Smash Brothers in my
cousin's room or it's you know the the
larger thing like this being able to
hang out and talk to people who who care
about something similarly and so
passionately um and that was such a
wonderful thing to to see and feel in
that room so to be able to help make
that happen again for more people um is
the thing I'm most excited about um my
eyes are bleeding from staring at
spreadsheets all these different
websites but you know at the end of the
day it's going to be worth it hope these
dark circles we be gone by Tuesday no
question Tuesday is about to be lit
another highlight of of the game was she
is who again what Harold alluded to
early before he left which is the
legendary Neil dman and and obviously
him being celebrated you know as a
luminary as far as you know his impact
on the industry un char series you know
obviously the last of us both of them
you know you guys uh the interns at the
Circle got a chance to to interview him
you know which I thought was cool and um
he has some really profound statements
about you know being influenced and and
getting in the games industry and and
and and how you know representation
matters about seeing yourself right you
know and then obviously the choice in
reference to Ellie and and how people
would would come up to him in reference
to these type of things you know how
excited it for you to see have Neil in
the building oh like be be H and like
first and foremost like anyone like
watching or listening like if you have
not seen these interviews like go to the
New York video game critic Circle
YouTube I got you um Neil was so kind to
take time to sit down and take questions
from our interns and answer them like so
honestly and openly um like he even goes
into talking at one point about just
like like you know like how brutal
people can be in the comments right yeah
like like he you know he made a very
divisive choice or his team made a very
divisive Choice yes in one of his games
um and you either love it or you hate
it but at the end of the day like maybe
don't you know go online telling someone
to kill themselves about you know story
and like I I respect like him being able
to to bring that into the conversation
um and just to you know take time
because like I said like the bringing it
back to the kids bringing it back to the
education that's the most important
thing to me and to see that he's already
you know going that extra mile like
before even getting this award like has
been so gracious with his time and and
that and you know that's meant so much
like I'm excited just to be able to like
thank him in person again you know and
you know hear what he has to say when
when he receives that award um it's it's
it's going to be a great night like I I
I look I look up to you know the kind of
writing that he does like you ruffle
some feathers that that means that you
you did something that that caught
attention yeah no absolutely and I love
what like you said what you mentioned
and he said about you
know I think he said like his team to
the effect he tells his team like yo
don't get on social media you know what
I'm saying because it's crazy out here
it's wild in these streets and you know
people are really nasty but he talked
about also the flip side I highly
recommend you guys check it out I put
the uh Link in the description you know
to go check that out with the circle
it's great interview by the interns and
stuff like that I we've got 10 videos
total yes yes so that I'm hoping to try
to stream them together and maybe get
them into like one big audio podcast
that's you know something to work on in
the future we're a small team so you
know if and when we can get to it I'd
love to do that doubt yeah it's a great
listen and I'm just I I'm over the moon
that he like is going to be there and is
accepting this year can't with yeah
super dope man we super excited and
again the circle's killing it right now
and love the nonprofit work and in
reference to again serving the students
serving underserved communities you know
video games being at the backbone of the
culture the Lords will be in the
building you know what I'm saying all
four of us so that'll be cool and um
yeah man we're super excited I just
wanted to before we we close up with you
in reference to the question we we
always ask every Lord in the realm the
big one there no pressure now you got to
you got to really think about this one
all right now we talk about your top
five video games or franchises of all
time all right three months ago this
would have been a very different list
2023 all right let's go ruined us and
and I'm actually grabbing my phone
because I keep I keep oh you keep this
on the phone oh you ready he got his he
got his goat list ready in case anybody
pull up teach that's the teacher he was
like hold on hold on what you talking
top five Co top five all right I got you
so here we go because it's it's shifted
it's been it's been a weird year I could
have rattled this off instantly from
memory all right um number five is Final
Fantasy 16 from this year
wow I don't like I think get him off get
him off we lost right come on we lost
right don't get him like that
so wa I got to hit it because you good
for you break it down break it down
because this is a controversial one cuz
a lot of a lot of the traditionalist
break it down stop being messy stop
being mess for a lot of
traditionalists there was a lot of
resistance against saying it it was a
diversion for the jrpg m so break it
down for you why 16 is is the goat on
your goat list let's go to just go on on
the play style I
think play style I don't think has
anything to do with what makes a Final
Fantasy game at the end of the day it's
a Final Fantasy game because the people
who made it are the people who make
Final Fantasy games Paul I trust the
Creator oh
boys be quiet Young
Buck let me stop let me stop seem like a
cop out but
continue let's go Final Fantasy Battle
Is In The Middle continue that case any
game that differentiates from its core
and switches stuff off I got said well
you know the the the developer say it's
the next one from first person to third
person or first person they said it's a
resent evil right you got you got an
unruly student in his
Zoom I support both Resident Evils I
don't know but like I think for for me
narrative is a huge function and I think
I think give you that they have a decent
narrative and like I I've I've mentioned
my brother multiple times I think that
relationship between the two brothers
and their story that's why just really
struck a chord on for me
um also coming off of Final Fantasy 10
which we'll get back to because it's
definitely up near the top is I love um
like aons summons whatever you want to
call it depending on what game you're
playing and I really enjoyed the way
that they actually built those into the
base gameplay for your character and
like you could switch those things out
and like I had the certain summons that
I preferred but they all kind of worked
in different ways um it took me by
surprise because I didn't expect to like
and like you know to you know to give
credit you know it's it's definitely
more um Kingdom Hearts than it is Final
Fantasy and it's play okay um I also
grew up on Kingdom Hearts so that just
felt like it worked Final Fantasy 15 had
a very similar play style too so I think
it seems to be kind of where they're
shifting seven remake still has that
more action action based into it I
prefer a turn-based um so I didn't
expect to love that as much um but I I
don't know I just I really enjoyed Clive
and Sid and that whole cast of
characters if you can really shout out
to Ben what's the Ben oh my god oh he
destroyed that role I go for it he was
so good in the demo that it made me get
it I was all right cuz like what how it
obviously concluded yes I was like oh oh
okay well continue continue yeah when
when we were putting together um stuff
for the awards because he's nominated
for for acting like we have like
obviously clips from all the stuff and
we were like we can't just have clips of
him screaming and
cursing other ones that were those are
all so good those are the best ones
too so yeah I mean just it's I will say
and this is always a caveat I have like
if if you have GG app that's like what I
use to like rank all my games and my
caveat is like recency bias definitely
sometimes sure that's fair and it could
it could always change this might shift
and leave absolutely 16 big fan of it uh
number four number four I want to say
something real quick I do agree with you
like on how they handled summons I will
say that I think the best way of Final
Fantasy games implemented summons was 10
AG because it felt more natural
than okay so we got we got Final Fantasy
16 let's go with the go number four is
Last of Us twoo oh King is in the
building that's yeah yeah I care wait to
talk Neil oh my
like the thing that I I love about that
game is um we we talked about like
school and education and stuff and like
you know what do you get from books
versus what do you get from games and
like the most impactful quote that I've
ever heard from books and it's still
brought around is You Look To Kill a
Mockingbird adct as Finch you got to
walk around in someone's skin right they
are and that's like what a game does
best right you walk around as that
character you complete their actions
whether or not you have a choice and you
feel
more because you did it you're part of
that story so whether or not you know
playing The Last of Us One whether or
not you agree with what Joel does you do
it right when you get to last of us too
whether or not you agree with what Ellie
does you do it whether or not you agree
with Abby you do it and it makes you
feel that way even stronger because
you're going against your instincts and
I think that's why people are so
passionate about what Last of Us two is
whether you are the kind of person who
said you ruin the franchise harde I
think that really enhances it because I
don't have to agree with what every
single character does but I can justify
my feeling through going through those
actions and I'm of the camp I think like
Abby is one of my favorite video game c
oh you and King are about to be best
friends I completely agree we can hang
out we can grab some drinks wow this is
crazy everything that he's been saying
I'm talking about from the moment he
lock step K has been saying these things
what you're saying verbatim is what you
been saying but continue Abby Abby's
amazing and listen I love the fact that
they made you do what you had to do you
couldn't avoid it you could you could
stop playing if you wanted to but if you
were going to continue playing you had
to do what you need well well there
there was an I'm not going to get into
spoiler territory but at the end of the
game you are playing as Ellie and
there's a final moment
I put my controller
down yo
yo Ryan this is eer say that when we had
I said the same exact thing yeah when we
had our
discussion were you crying at this
moment cuz I was crying I was very
overemotional but I I was like I think
they're going to make me do something I
don't want to do and I want to see is it
part of the game that if I put this down
it won't let me do it right do I
actually have a choice in this
can I Stand Back From This Moment yes
and I stood there for a solid like
minutes guess I have to do this F so i g
go through and you know the game does
what the game does and again spoiler
friend who wants to go back in but like
a game has never done that for me I
really I felt like the game was going in
a
direction and I felt against where I
thought the game was going Y and like
to me that's moving y you you mentioned
Catcher And lry before and like what
does that have to I read that book that
I hated it as but what I learned is you
can hate something
productively right like I didn't like
that character in that book I'm not and
say like JD Salinger is the worst writer
ever no I don't like this character I'm
gonna Analyze That character's choices
and honestly his good writing is why I
hate that character and that's how I
feel about the last of us and that's
what you realize right I read that book
in like seventh or eighth grade and then
then I read the book again after H being
in private school for two years and then
all of a sudden I understand Holden
callfield I understand where that
character came I went to school with
guys that were like Holden Coffield to
be quite Frank so it's like it's you're
right it's just it's context and if you
being ready for that type of for that
you know that type of Storytelling and I
think yeah Last of Us was was that King
and I had that conversation like so many
people hated it I'm like know I adored
every second of it and I hated it at the
same time because it was so dire and
then you know for me the dire nature of
it was what was to be expected I think
coming out of the first game I said you
know what whatever happens after this
this world has shown that it is
unforgiving and it doesn't forget MH so
you finish that game and you say what
whatever a sequel is to this game there
will be consequences to pay yeah I knew
that going in yeah and I was I you know
I wasn't sure that they would have the
courage I wasn't sure that they would
have the courage to do it and when they
did it that's when I fell head Overhills
in love with I don't I don't and and the
fact that it was so so aggressively dire
and
hateful it was just a perfect
exemplification of what Ellie felt
because in that world there is there is
nothing that's telling you I should not
feel this way there's nothing that's
telling you I'm going to have
repercussions for acting on on these
feelings uh the the the world will will
level itself out at some point and
you'll you there will be repercussions
but you can still do whatever the heck
you want um and even just like the
cherry on top of that is like again no
spoilers but at the end like the the
picking up of the guitar and just like
everything that that one
what your
chican written in just that one frame
and like I like I like sat back I like
text my brother and I was like the
guitar and he's like I know
right we we felt it but like yep yeah
like that that story just like sits with
me and I'm really fascinated to see how
the show's going to handle it because so
much of that they're gonna let you down
I you know there's there's absolutely no
Neil is in the building though it is
they're they're gonna do it different
and like if I look at like they have to
you can't yeah no choice you you can't
feel that same way like I said like
you're controlling the character that's
90% think what makes it feel it but like
they did with the with the bill story
and like they have Creative Solutions of
telling
stories handle it yes but
like I I don't just like
with and like relationship and learning
who they are
and yes exactly stop that's goat talk
this is goat we got we're only on number
four yeah we're only number four we we
can continue this conversation literally
turn yeah we we continue this at the New
York game awards we we get deeper what
he has a little time free TI after we
all swarm Neel andate about how great
you know he is we got the two we got the
six Final Fantasy 16 we got the last of
those two number three is Legend of
Zelda Wind Waker okay which um like
speaking on on the the statues my my
thing that I I will search for forever
and never get because it's so expensive
is there's like a wind waker one of the
boat and I can't find it for under two
grand so
if I know I know I know who makes it too
yeah it's absolutely incredible I know
you're talking about like I want it so
bad I also want to get the the king of
red as a CH again another another story
but the thing that I I I love the Zelda
franchise it's my favorite franchise
overall obviously went over um when I
was like in the womb my parents were
playing the NES
version itated
in they loved it they had the map they
would write on the map
and I didn't know they was Gamers like
that oh I didn't it was really just like
that one at least that's what they tell
me like but they I don't know like my
dad likes games every so often like I
got him the um the PlayStation mini nice
nice he'll play like Twisted
Metal but the thing that I I love about
um Wind Waker and why it's my favorite
Zelda game is I think it's the one that
handles Story the best in it's not just
like in a lot of them link goes on the
journey because he's the hero yeah and
it doesn't always answer why does he why
does he become the hero why is he going
on this journey and in Wind Waker it's
his sister is kidnapped right and like
you can justify and understand okay I'm
gonna go on this journey to save my
sister and he doesn't become the hero
until he goes on that journey to find
his sister and sees what the state of
the world is yeah and that's when he
decides it's time to do it it's not just
you know I'm you know doing my duty as
part of like the realm and my princess
is stolen right it's at the CORE family
and then you learn and then all of those
things build and like and it's just
beautiful like that it's a lot of people
don't know but there's like four
timelines for for Zoda oh yeah there
there's a timeline for an Ocarina time
if he goes back in time or if he doesn't
go back in time there's a timeline if he
dies yeah because um all these games
there's just variety of what like a
different timeline that they went into
like breath of the wild and teers of the
kingdom is like supposed to be like
neither before Skyward Sword or after
because uh in Skyward Sword they talk
about like in scard Sword like King's
favorite there's that's right tell the
truth there's like civilizations
floating in the air yeah and they think
that you know tears of the kingdom and
uh and breath of the wild led to the
separation between the people uh the
goddess's people and like the regular
people of Hyrule yeah I'm curious if
Nintendo will ever like finalize that
time like they built the branching one
and then like breath of the wild seemed
like it converged all of them somehow
like I don't know I'm interested to see
if if uh Nintendo ever give give some
facts on that but the the thing about
like in the moment and when we look back
people now are all always like when wi
Waker is so great we love Wind Waker not
when they came out when you were on the
playground in 2002 saying that you were
playing Legend of Zelda the wi Waker on
your GameCube everyone was like you have
a GameCube what are you doing what are
you doing but like but but I would
always argue like with you know the
other kids and they'd be like oh well
like this game looks so real look at the
water and like blah you look back that
didn't look like nope like like I'm
standing under a tree and it's two
circles at a Cross Point it's not a tree
like it looks like the decorations my
mom had for
Christmas and you look back at Wind
Waker and like it wasn't like obviously
like graphically yeah you know realistic
but it was consistent with every single
part of itself yeah water was animated
the same as the little wisps of air and
the characters were animated the same as
the trees and the rocks and like there
was just a Fidelity to that world that
felt real and it's stood the test of
time they they did a really good job
promoting that CU When the GameCube came
out it came with like a uh a zeld of
Collector's Edition that's like way too
much money these days but on there was a
demo yeah on that was a demo for for a
wind waker y so so we got Wier it was
like the first dungeon you got to play
which is great yeah yeah so that one's
always with me and then number two is
Final Fantasy 10 which yes I went into
to a lot but like I think
the there there's a lot of similar
themes in Final Fantasy 10 that I see in
Last of Us two which is like you have
three characters who have a very similar
background of like what's motivating
them and you're looking at how they
handle it differently where it's like
everyone has a dad who was famous for
something and how do you move through
this this world and you know how how
does your your family's
lineage affect how you you act and like
you have tetus who's just a little jerk
and hates his dad you have Seymour who's
become an absolute monster and kills his
dad and then who like respects her dad
and wants to do best for her world and
they you look at it it's all the same
but like there there's just so much of
that game that like I don't even know
how to put into words like there's
Nostalgia there's the the Aon fighting
system I think Yun is the greatest
character that Final Fantasy has ever
put out
[Music]
I think by by the end of uh cuz what's
funny is like by the end of that game
all of those dad the only one that you
could really respect with Braska like
yeah all right so we got that we got the
Final Fantasy and what what's what you
got number one for right now balers gate
changed the
game I didn't see it coming I didn't
expect it okay it was just
like you know like especially now like
working you know essentially in the
industry like there's a pressure of like
I got to play everything and this year
it was like you got to play everything
and everything is 100 hours of gameplay
so are you GNA do that um so you know I
kind of was like picking and choosing in
what I play and balers gate I had never
played anything like it like the
especially playing it not on mouse and
keyboard I was playing on controller
controller using that bumpers yeah
moving through the wheel system
the wheels you got get used to that it
took me forever yep there were there was
a solid five hours of like just constant
dying and but learning from those
mistakes and I've
never in the like probably in the last
like 10 years if a game did that to me I
would have put it away y That's Right
fail but then going back to the Sega
days like I've probably paid four levels
of Sonic the Hedgehog but I probably
played them 700 times each
because you just you go and you go and
you do it again and you play you play
and you play and that's kind of how I
just felt with balder's gate is like
there was something in me it's like I
keep dying I don't know what I'm doing
but I still want to do it yeah and I
want to learn and then there was just a
turning point where okay this makes
sense I'm like oh if I throw this bottle
of Grease people are gonna fall over oh
that bottle of grease that oh now
everyone's on
fire you learn and you learn and it just
every single moment in that game felt
important and I've never seen that in a
game before the closest I think I've
seen that is in Witcher 3 where like
most of those side quests still felt
like they were part of that world
building part of that larger story but
every single thing I did in balder's
Gate like had consequence yes not only
did it feel like it had consequence it
did have
consequence and like that just felt so
masterful to me and I made like I made a
vow in the early game of like I'm going
to let anything happen and I'm going to
move forward and you're you're just
going to let it happen because that
that's the point of the story
it's if I'm looking for the one true
pathway like there isn't yes you have to
just let circumstance happen and
hit so and I want to replay and and try
to do things a little differently um but
yeah without going on for an hour and a
half like balder's gate just really
opened up my eyes to I think the genre
so like I'm looking for you know similar
games that you know are doing that yeah
ter base and then it to me it also had
like a from a story the writing player
choice and you know I come from those
that BioWare background it felt like
that a lot of Mass Effect energy like
everything had impact but yeah to your
point like yeah you
it's powerful and I I love turn base as
well it it was I I had the same
experience to you it was very
intimidating at first just learning was
so much to it but then you started get
in that flow on boarding sucks the on
boarding yeah on boarding is rough and
once you get it then the next time
you're playing it you're like man I
can't believe that part 6 hours done
pass and I'm still playing this game and
you're like that's what it really sinks
its hooks in so I'm with you on that
part and and it did a really cool job of
like if I think about like games like
Final Fantasy 10 that I love there are
party Builders like you kind of expect
like where your part is going to go and
like I was in like act end of act two
like getting more characters I like is
can anyone be a character like I didn't
know what was Happ and I'm constantly
like falling in love with more
characters and making tough decisions of
like well I guess lizel is staying at
camp today even though
she's at the camp but Hon's the guy now
like my number one like figuring all
those things out like I really felt like
I was conversing with those people and I
was part of that crew and I was that
player character in a way that I've
never experienced in a game I love the
list no doubt final question for you
favorite console of all time and
why I know yeah I mean I think it's
GameCube oh first Game Cube reference in
the I it's like I was in maybe second
sixth or seventh grade when it when it
dropped I think that's like the most
formative time to just care about
anything I remember being in like one
one of the first science class doodling
like was it one of the first games per
GameCube Luigi's Mansion hell yeah he he
said hell
yeah Luigi's Mansion Rogue
Squadron that's when Luigi got his shine
it was a Year of
Luigi continue I'm sorry we interrupted
you right continue no all good yeah I I
there there were so many things
in like I I just felt so ingrained in so
many of those games I remember just like
daydreaming in class of like wanting to
play Mario Kart and like go home and and
play specifically the Double Dash oh
adct this is his stuff right this this
your games I'm sorry you like in pocket
with adct right now I think yeah good do
you the the Double Dash like like had
that feature of right you could play you
know two different characters and Swap
and it was really clever and how you
could create your build but you could
also play it that you were both playing
in the same cart so you could do a
two-player mode but you're one cart and
one person's in charge of throwing
things and then if you swapped you could
switch to driver dad always wanted to
play with
me and number one he's not good at
it he refused to drive he always wanted
to be the guy who just dropped things so
he just want to sit there and hit like
trigger button that's it and then the
third thing is he would only pick
Waluigi who had the worst item in the
game so I was like could you at
least you at least pick a Koopa Trooper
so we can get the three sh blue that's
right like he's like no he's like I like
this this wiry
guy not it's not it's the worst one
here so I had to go through and I played
that entire game with him just like me
up front as a Koopa Trooper because I
respected our team and wanted good items
and him just in the back
respected
respected but I have those memories
which is so great and it's like my
favorite thing about games right is like
like I have that weird story with my dad
like the so but GameCube you've got
Resident
Evil again even going back to my PS1
still don't know how to play it but I've
watched my brother play it watch people
play it online at this point Wind Waker
um yeah a Sonic Adventure 2 battle like
definitive for me I love Simpsons road
Rage the taxi ripoff okay that one was
insane I what else was on there Paper
Mario Thousand your
door can't wait for the Remake GameCube
love I love it Mario Party 4 Mario my my
fiance and I play Mario Party probably
once a week which is just like testing
whether or not this
relationship if you survive a game of
Mario Party oh yeah yeah yeah it's real
it get real it get real that's a fact
last call out for GameCube
ssx3 everyone needs to stop talking
about tricky being the best one oh we go
SS did it better took an amazing
mechanic and built like this kind of
open World System where you could go
through all of the courses at once but
then you could also do them alone as
races you could customize your character
based on your wins and you could choose
any of the characters who came from
tricky or new ones and they all had
their modifications I was obsessed I
100% that I had everything it was the
wildest thing that I was like never into
I wasn't good at Tony Hawk or any of
those kinds of games but I loved SSX 3
so you go all for three so tricky I to
chat you stand on business with great
yeah but three did it better it took
what tricky did so well and I just
Amplified into something more what I
love about your choice you go against
the Green a lot yeah you go against what
what everyone else tells you supposed to
be the consensus you have your in the
pocket you break it down why I I I love
what you say I like the GameCube
reference uh as being the number one I
think the GameCube was
Nintendo's most experimental
console I really enjoyed the GameCube it
was the the little mini disc yeah
remember the mini the
shape it was the first hand like it's
like that little lunch P travel wherever
you want to gos it was the first console
that they paired up with another console
manufacturer was Panasonic which was
essentially the same form factor it was
just more robust and had different stuff
it was the first console that they did a
remote control controller that was the
wave bird they did a lot of different
things with the GameCube that forms
their opinion on how they make consoles
now really AB salute man and they had
the it was like a little base and I
still have it you could that you could
play um The Game Boy games in the Game
Boy and Game Boy Advance on your TV I
also had an attached screen that clipped
into that weird little and went on road
trips we had a battery
pack I was just tearing up ssx3 in the
back seat it yo I never knew about that
cuz that's when you checked out yeah I
checked out of them wasn't about that
that dle but I still have the screen wow
yeah I remember that for me it didn't
hit as much but the system but I
remember I remember like the Resident
Evil if I'm going to the Resident Evils
were really good on game and I think
they had like zero yeah zero remake 4
remake I think four was an exclusive for
a
while it came with the um the chainsaw
controller
yeah expensive I wish I time n
tremendous gaming history love what
you're doing in the circle Lord Ryan o
cahan in the building again brother
thank you for stopping about it your
stories Journey tremendous um love Yeah
hearing about this it's going to be fun
I want to get you as far as where can
the people find you what you got going
on let them know what's going on so for
for myself if you want to find me on
Instagram Twitter it's Mr Ryan o CM r r
y n o c um for the C where NY
vgcc across all um
socials um go to nyame critic.com donate
if you like what you heard and what
we're doing you know we're we're pushing
to expand and reach more schools and you
know help more kids and get them
involved in the industry um yeah yeah
man I salute to you man I love what you
do I'm putting the links in the chat so
they can go follow and support and then
um yeah Lord adct little outros for L
Ryan before he had out you seem very
very passionate about a lot of his
choices which was interesting but uh
took effect no okay okay I got you I got
you it was like my my jaw just every
time I move it would just hurt sorry
move and talk I appreciate you coming on
uh you know I Tuesday will be the first
day I meet you I I have to uh I have to
fly from uh Virginia all the way to New
York MH uh so this is going to be an
interesting I've been to New York York
before but that place is uh it's
terrifying country boy I don't be I I I
I don't like cities in general Seattle I
don't know Seattle was more terrifying
than New York really I don't know there
was something about Seattle it was
gloomy yeah there was something about
Seattle I don't ever want to go y'all
like them alleys I know what yall ain't
like no we got no I I don't mind the
alleys like it just felt like it's a
feel yeah it felt like it was like
like it felt like it was The Purge like
I'm watching The Purge like the
apocalypse was there wasn't enough
people around no it's just gloomy the
place has a f to it okay all right well
there we
go y funny so it was it was rainy while
we were there it was rainy it was rain
salute salute adct on that rainy
depressions oh my yo you got to stop
with your your Seattle slander
anyway Lord up little outro for Lord
right s him on his way an absolute
pleasure man I'm so happy to to see that
you're part of the circle in this big
way now and you're you know you along
with how are going to sort of be leading
the direction of this thing for the for
the foreseeable future and and to see
what the plans are and to to have
education at the core of it and have an
educator Educators at the front of it is
is a special thing because I really do
think that the biggest biggest obstacle
is just getting the information to these
kids that there are so many different
Pathways forward to do the things that
they love and that they're passionate
about and that they're just they don't
have to be closed into this this
singular sort of path and and to to they
need to understand that and they need to
see people that are thriving in that
space to also feel like they have the
ability to do it so it's a pleasure for
us to be a part of it I'm so excited to
be there Tuesday and present this award
and just to continue to to grow as part
of this organization because I think big
things are coming and I think it's I
love the fact that it's a HomeTown thing
for us cuz again these are things that
we wish we had when we were growing up
so absolutely in the big scary
City scary City man Big B scary City
sound like a game
title l g they need to make it a
simulator man New York oh my God you was
finded 40 42 Time Square
Shing his
name what GTA 3 is surv
City he was born in fine dead no doubt
Lord King outro to to Lord Ryan oh man
Lord Ryan uh I can't wait to meet you on
you know face well I met you last year
in a Jace you know because you was
getting a award and to see the
transformation from last year to this
year it's it was really quickly and um
it's it's
an inspiring tale to be honest with you
now me and you share a lot of things a
lot of things AC the board bonded this
episode really well and um I just
appreciate you still having that
enthusiasm for the children because you
know every time I see children learning
or growing in the space um I understand
that there are cups that need to be
filled with great new energy kids need
more options growing up right and and
you know we have less options in New
York City now then um we had when I was
growing up when we had you know we had
PLL programs we had a whole bunch of
different programs that we were able to
uh interact with our community and take
pride in our community so um the fact
that you you know struck through a lot
of this stages now and you saw the
transformation from early on but to
still have that Vigor in your heart to
teach and to express growth with
children and now to be part of it on
this uh groundbased level this is
fantastic and I cannot wait you know to
shake your hand on
Tuesday absolutely we'll see you there I
can't wait oh yeah absolutely yeah man
looking forward to it again absolutely
play they it was it was dope to actually
uh get a chance to break bread with you
a little bit um after when we I think it
was Jordan miners uh book yeah yeah
which I still have them or I bought four
copies that day I got to give those
three their copies that I still get
keeping our stuff he's supposed to be
giving what you mean keep well it's good
that you're coming out of Virginia so
you can get it in person
yes you will be flying back that's my
make it out of New York's airport oh my
Lord depends on which one you're flying
out of but that's the
whole Jersey yeah we come to Jersey City
we come to Jersey City it's all good H
probably your best option y because you
already know how New York traffic is
going to be how crazy it's going to be
but I want to give you flowers we got a
chance to to break bre talk a little bit
there and thank you for being patient
cuz we finally got this done get you in
the realm talking to the people love you
your journey brother it's been fantastic
looking forward to Tuesday getting the
chance to see you man the legendary Ryan
o Kahan executive director New York
video games critic Circle an absolute
pleasure enjoy your day bro and thank
you for your time this was a lot of fun
thanks so much guys we'll see you
Tuesday no doubt see you Tuesday Hope
just if I get to New
York this guy's crazy he got to get
through his quest game'll see three of
you on Tuesday
that part no doubt right salute astop
par King astop par King you said uh how
do I feel about opening up for a
Playstation
podcast
um okay I I what is he referencing what
is he referencing what does he mean um
I'll let y'all elaborate on that part
but it's Colin and I are different you
know I really like Colin
his um idea ideal and ideas about things
aren't as different from mine um he just
doesn't know the Xbox ecosystem and then
had he you know built his Digital
Library here and his memories you know
here it would be a whole different thing
and I'm pretty sure his passion will
work but you forget to to mention Matty
plays is over there Matty plays and you
know Cog do to finding the Dukes are
over there and they're over there
holding their own up against you a
Playstation home so I think I'll be
doing the podcasting realm well by
opening up for the PlayStation cuz you
know I already know you going open up
mess you got to leave with
Excellence I already see how this going
to go we go we going to rub a little
green all over you know what I mean oh
you you going put some GRE you you show
it up to the LSM house with and you
going to repa the situation green we
going to Thug This Mother
Out how that goes well we open it again
for those who do not know cuz we're
talking in
circles don't you do the Cat wheel don't
you do
that we out the iron Lord podcast will
be also opening you know what I'm saying
for Sac symbols 300 and um that will be
also at the theater that will be live in
New York City we've been doing a live
show we will be the open app for the
sacred boys as they celebrate their 300
so come check us out we'll get the uh
link and all that that good stuff once
the official stuff goes live but the
announcement was made you know so we'll
be back so we got we going to be8 theat
two times we be the the you see that
that's you see the symbolism 300 this is
spart oh you making it the SP okay I see
what we doing I see what we doing you
know what I'm saying so yeah like it it
is it is it's a a tremendous opportunity
shout out to last Stan shout out to
Colin shout out to Dustin shout out to
Ben shout out to Chris Ray gun the whole
team more surprise I don't want to SPO
if he hasn't said it but there will be
more surprises you know coming through
but for us you know doing a live show is
something that's really important for us
and um King has been pushing this for
the beginning it it just the Stars
aligned and you know again for the
people who are PAX East Brothers we are
still doing PAX East we're not
cancelling it and we're doing both there
a lot on our plate but we're able to
figure it out and it it's just dope to
have the communities come you know what
I'm saying and like King said you know
what we got to get in the community
that's what I want to say you know we
all have opinions all of us all even all
four the law we do not agree with each
other literally every show there's
always some topic that we be like
whatever but the thing is we got to
understand you know in gaming it's okay
we got to be able to agree to disagree
respectfully you know what I'm saying
and I know look Colin got strong
opinions I got strong opinions and you
know King got strong opion years and got
strong years so it's going to be fun but
the thing I like about it is we all
respect each other and at the end of the
day it's about the video game so come
check us out it's going to be lit we'll
get you the details as we approach solve
add any thoughts on that announcement
before we move
on sounds good let's get it man let's
get get get it it's going to be
interesting we still have to figure out
what we're going to
do we going to do it or we just going to
be us and Wing we got we we going to
have a topic we'll s
sh fun I think uh yeah this is a moment
we've been waiting for I think you know
we just got to go out there you know
sees the moment and and have fun um and
yeah shout out to shout out to Colin and
the team for making it happen because
again it was one of those things where
it was kind of happening behind the
scenes and then coming out in the skin
tight Xbox onesie yo we not doing
that I'm coming out I'm coming out of
the skin tight Xbox on Z with Croc oh
that's a terrible visual horrible yo
where the cha on I'm have like four five
Xbox CH oh man it's crazy crazy addict
any thought like I don't know you I
don't know but yeah we listen it was it
was not going to happen and then we find
out the date kind of moved around and uh
we were able to make it happen so this
is this is amazing this is amazing
absolutely no there would be no Cog with
the Croc stop that um shout out to astop
King you know what I'm saying he better
be in the building shout out to my man
Haj you better be in the building adct
any words on that you're in New York
show up yeah yeah ad's good unless you
don't show
up you are in New York so I don't I
don't I don't blame you yeah no it is
what it is no doubt no I mean comes down
to it's like look you you can disagree
with all you want on Callin in terms of
some of his opinions they are pretty out
there but it's like you can't you cannot
look at me with a straight face and not
tell me that man's not passionate
towards the gaming industry yeah for
sure and it's like I might disagree with
certain aspects and certain things he
says but at the end of the day it's like
I got to see that passion there and that
passion is there a lot of people doing a
lot more that you could tell they that
there ain't no passion there you you
want to hear me talk about how broke
Sony is oh stop it moving
on uh yeah dror Strange Love they would
they they will be a VIP meet and greet
prior to the show you put it out there I
I don't know I don't know that we are
are that's not for us really but we comp
beting oh so get that exclusive access
to S behind the
scenes that one on what with s oh we
going to have we going to make sure that
we talk to them Reggie goons that we
going to see on Tuesday about coming
back in March making sure that we you
know that we're protected you know yo he
c c Raider said this going to be a
champagne room
yo I cannot no sex Shi yeah no no I
remember I going get this the spe the
SBA theater Reggie goons the go ready
get the goons ready just in case a wall
a wall of them protecting us ready walk
with some goons yeah he got the shooters
he got the shooters yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah Rober Kell yeah it's going down
brother yeah it's going down Lord's
coming to New York
yes sacred 300 if you are if obviously
if you're here you're listening to us
your fans and we love that and
appreciate that if you're in the tri
state
area show out man show we going be we
going to be and we coming in hot you got
two places to see us you got the
American uh the American got the New
York game awards yeah this Tuesday it's
Tuesday if you if it's too early for you
pause you got us in March you know pull
up yeah and we we we're going we coming
in hot from packs Xbox front line there
I want y'all all to have your shirts so
like ah coog will
die continue you going to say something
I'm sorry you the worst part about this
I have to go to New York twice yes yes
yeah bringing you to the city that's
what I'm talking about multiple times
you going to be a bad talk in New York
be veteran yo adct is going to have on
that red velor suit we going to get on
that red Vel suit with
the
CRS so we when we get you on the train
attic when you get on the train you got
to say you got to do this you got
[Laughter]
go and then you just we're just going to
leave you alone and see what happen see
what
happen anyway you want to get the super
chat s we got business to play you want
me to do get what to do I business not
not yet cuz the business let's wait till
Co yeah but uh Let's do let's do the
superat we got how we we got a lot yeah
we got a we got a decent amount yeah let
me take my little bre okay we got Craig
holigan shout out to Craig hooligan put
the CR in the chat gifting one IOP
membership appreciate that brother and
we have Andre Doyle $2 Super Chat what
up and God bless y'all hash Xbox wins
Ash no ps6 shout out to you we thank you
for letting us know how you feel Andre
Doyle appreciate you then we got KJ Wars
85 member for seven months Lord gold put
the crust in the chat for KJ Wars then
we have Cali Rex 01 $2 Super Chat salute
to the iron Lords on this fine day
salute to you sir appreciate that we got
Craig hooligan once again $5 Super Chat
I heard Colin agreed to be the closer at
the upcoming IOP live show he's such a
nice
guy I appreciate
that wrap it up
B appreciate you guys feel that way
that's that's that warms my heart but
shout out shout out to the the sacred
boys I appreciate that he got Dr Strange
Love $5 Super Chat Sab I heard you like
Indiana Jones well I have a similar game
we could play including whips and
[Laughter]
leather shout out to you appreciate the
the the
support thank you for your
patronage we got Big Mad MO remember for
42 bus Lord bronze shout out to the
Lords in the realm Xbox Dev direct was
fire we causing motion sickness out here
hashtag to the next season # no ps6
that's right let's keep them thumbs in
the air letting them know they up out of
here up out
messy blooding they snow
boy we got Donald Taco member for eight
mon Lord silver I'm in church right now
but the Lord ain't G to stop me from
Catching the
Lord how's he doing it yeah just can't
let my girl find out yeah earbud you got
earbuds on it's how you has one earbud
one earbud on away from the white
that's he's probably facing the aisle
and she's on his I'm just amazed ad how
he's able to pull that off acting like
they confiscate your earbuds when you
yeah like it's the Lord's Day the the
other Lord say like
yeah I'm I'm listening to the realm as
we
talk
continue that's wild there we have
masokista $5 Super Chat how y'all liking
the newest XBox exclusive power world uh
we people people playing it yeah I Game
Pass don't
work you in trouble
today then we have Michael Santiago $5
Super Chat this is the tune medic if I'm
not
today we celebrate excellence in video
game journalism
between uh log loget and uh New York
video games critic Circle New York is
where the future of Journalism lives New
York stand up shout out to you brother
hope to see you to see you Tuesday
hopefully you there hopefully there we
go hope you there then we got Robert
kellet $10 Super Chat Lords log that in
the building $10 Super Chat bless day
Lords coming back home from my DC trip
and it was wonderful is beautiful
spending time with family was great and
the Sonic Symphony was a was magical
can't wait to travel more nice okay he
go off side man he goes off side salute
then we got zip Davis $5 Super Chat zip
with the drip new year new year new beef
hello Lords just sending in my first ooh
we of the Year o Zip Zip Zip I was
listening to a recent episode of a
summon sign you you got to let Brad know
he's got to say it with one o he said he
was like o we you
got s you you got to look at uh Rick and
Morty man
you you got to look at Mr Meek man look
at
me there we
go gotta go up a couple of octaves coule
octaves on that one hilarious then we
got this one from Sage which we read
already say did Ryan Kahan miss his days
playing with The Patriot did he chap
yeah
I there we got Doctor Strange Love Again
$2 Super Chat Final Fantasy 16 haters
smell take a shower
fools Final Fantasy 16 fan you got
Robert kellet once again $2 Super Chat
yeah my man Ryan you got amazing
taste nice
nice then we got Doctor Strange Love
Again $5 Super Chat Neil really
underestimated how dumb gamers are when
crafting Last of Us 2's narrative they
don't deserve that
Masterpiece where that's messy that is M
he didn't dump it down enough for the
master there we have Joe Repco AKA flame
shout out to Flame loget finest remember
for 39 months good afternoon IP who knew
that in three weeks we would already
have 2024's biggest game with power
world I can't believe what's going on
it's a movement yeah it's insane brother
shout out to you article think that's
just all the dudes that grew up on uh
Pokemon and want to shoot some stuff is
outside now clearly that's the thing
even the people liking it even if you
hating on it you're going to see some
value in playing that
game we click clicks are out there oh
yeah shout out to shout out to Flame L
got the article up there let me see that
we got you got you got Sage member for
33 months ago Colin is passionate about
Xbox no longer being part of the gamees
in
you're ridiculous you being messy you
being messy oh
yeah we're caught up wegh up no doubt no
doubt all right cool we oh don't you got
one more just came out oh we got
Hollywood rules $5 Super Chat happy
Sunday to my New York City and West
Virginia cousins have a great show Phil
needs to scope up power as get B okay
you got you you got like the the poll
question that's what's up so let's get
into last week
poll poll results are in the people have
spoken with the Xbox developer direct
recently announced which game do you
think will have the biggest impact the
winner oh this was super close this was
almost a tie by percentage points with
33.9% of the votes so coming in people
said the biggest gain that would have
impact by a smidget is a vou interesting
coming in that second place that was
right next to vow
33.2% of the vote was Indiana Jones
people felt it in their bones it was
going down third place at 25% hellblade
to and at last place at 7% of the vote
was I don't care y'all better stop
frontting on COD and the ABK acquisition
shout out to those in that put the vote
in uh Lord addict man the people were
were high on the valv coming in do you
think they got that right yeah I think a
v is
is probably going to be their best rated
game this year no doubt we got see how
it's going to go down no doubt and then
we got some Pat question we got a few
they're good this week they really good
shout out to um they did they thing they
did they thing this week he says it as
opposed to other week all the weeks you
know n it be di down man it be dipped
down with the w I like dip down dip down
is the but he always get us to fight
like he always trying to create beef
between the Lords that's what he always
go go shout out to Donald taku he said
okay we used to make fun of inside Xbox
because they would show up and talk a
long time about a hella not of nothing
because they had no games to talk about
except for third party multiplast it was
basically a useless show wow he feels
strongly about this now Xbox has so much
content including day one game pass
drops that a monthly inside Xbox could
potentially be amazing now devs of
upcoming first-party games of Big Game
Pass games could talk about their game
and show new footage as well do you
think Reviving it now would be a good
idea anybody can jump in who wants this
yeah um they could revive it now and
have me pull the charge um you know
since my man Larry not there you know
call a king you know slide up there and
we can do you
know we can knock this out the park
let's go do it I think you know me and
Jeff Rubenstein to be a nice uh okay so
you want to bring it back as long as you
were involved oh yes of course Xbox need
to holl at you I mean if it wasn't for
me they wouldn't have a movement where
they wouldn't have a push what movement
was that that that's the Xbox you know
hold the line movement then we had
advancing line with Sarah B you know
hopping out to the queen hopped out
there was like now we will advance on so
we need we need Xbox Advance the line
um God this listen and it could go every
month Xbox advance in the line and
that's how the show would be and you
know we come through we riding the the
you know the game pass train we all hop
out Bo I got I got I got I gotu bro
clearly this man to work
y you need come on we got them man we
got them on the Run let's G them down no
doubt adct s does Xbox inside Xbox need
to come back based on all of the content
or no no they're good you good all right
no doubt add I mean solve your thoughts
why you trying to stop my bag
at you trying to stop your bag try to
stop my bag at you supposed to say hell
yeah supposed to come back let's get
this rolling stop playing adct come back
Ki
David I mean I don't know I mean they
got the dev direct and what else the
Showcase right I don't know I mean they
they have more than enough stuff to
figure something else out I just don't
we'll see what they want to do with it I
mean because Dev directs they're only
really going to do when these games are
closer right so I don't expect you
expect what one Dev direct per year I
mean who knows if they're talking about
the games that they expect to be coming
out that year so it's one per year so
they have to figure out another way to
talk to the
community so yeah I think there's
something for sure so definitely yeah
holl at King cuz King GNA be that's my
brother that's my brother that's my
brother yeah that's my brother yeah
thing is I'm I'm good unless y'all give
a k a back that's where
I I'm good on it otherwise we let's go
let's go I think developer director
they're in a a good pocket with that
show but if they want additional show
sure absolutely H is I just don't see if
they don't cuz again like unless they
want to do stuff with games that are
further out then we'll get multiple of
those or at least two of them if not
then you expect to develop the bre once
a year kind of at the at the start of
the Year let you know what's coming um
and then after that it's just a showcase
summertime showcase or whatever the case
may be so yeah they have to figure out
more ways to talk to us no doubt shout
out to n day micros we need IL operators
in car salute we need that bag too
salute salute all right so next one user
not found that's the homie all right so
I hope everyone is having a great Sunday
my question to the Lords this week
pertains to the news we got about Halo
on Friday which addressed how infinite
will be updated going forward no more
seasons focus on operations Forge based
improvements Etc I feel like it's going
in a similar direction to Master Chief
collection in a way we also keep hearing
language from 343 saying how they'll
keep updating infinite but their main
focus is on future Halo games for a
while I've had this feeling the next
Halo game is much closer than we think
it is to be honest I think we could hear
news about it by showcase 2025 what are
the Lord's thoughts on the potential
next installment in Halo and when we
could hear more as a bonus since they
said future Halo games plural it's me is
it me on a bit of hopium that we could
see more Halo spin-offs in the future
what's the lord's dream Halo spin-off
slj mixup Maybe rvo horror another ODST
game lock spin-off Orbiter spin-off but
not just limited to that not limited to
that but just some quick ideas hope all
have a great rest of their Sunday and
week ahead I like this one from new and
now found start off with addict on this
one because I know he's passion about
Halo what do you think that um you know
in reference to the shift to Seasons now
you know how they said you feel you know
like I say it's going in a match Chief
Collection as far as infinite and that
Halo I mean that 343 said that they
would be working on future Halo games
you know and the rest of his points in
reference to spin-offs in the genre and
is the next Halo closer than we think I
do think uh the next Halo is closer than
people think but I don't want people
thinking oh it's coming out next year
something like that right I think I
think you could see an announcement you
know relatively soon uh but I don't even
if we get that full-blown announcement
don't expect the game for at least
probably
2026 Maybe yeah and my thing is like the
the condition Halo is in now cuz it
doesn't matter what they do with Halo
infite people are going to remember what
Halo it started out as so it's just like
my mindsets like take as much time as
you need just when that comes out that's
it like okay okay no doubt Lord solve
your thoughts on Halo how they should
handle it are they transitioning is it
closer than we think spin-offs where you
at I don't know that it's closer than we
think but I do think that you know
they've jumped into development one way
shape or form uh you know kind of with
both feet now so the idea that you know
the expectation that they're moving on
to Unreal uh kind of means that yeah
they're going to stop working on Halo
infinite right um what's interesting
about the verbiage is multip when they
say multiple games right and that could
have just been whatever but at that
point you stop to think are are are they
thinking about making a live service
component
again and building that off of the
Unreal Engine five version of you know
and just leaving leaving infinite behind
and have it be this thing that stands on
its own and like I said it's not going
to continue to be updated uh in terms of
more content per se so um it's
interesting to me if they still want to
follow that route because again the same
sort of pitfalls still exist right are
you if you are going to do that in new
engine and you want to build it off of
that are you once again ready to deal
with the idea of a Content road map and
putting a specific team on this thing to
continue to build it out and and and
make it a a living breathing game in the
future uh I just hope they really learn
the lessons from infinite and be like
okayy can we do this is this something
that we want to do or something that
I've suggested in the past it's like hey
just go back to making a great Halo game
with a great campaign
a great multiplayer component that they
add to over the of two or three years
and then you move on to the next one and
I I don't see why why we live in a world
while that's not a possibility anymore
that's not worth it for them to do so
they could do both um I'm excited that
they're moving on I think unre Engine 5
has a lot of possibilities in terms of
you know how the look of the game can be
the feel of the game I'm excited for
them to have to have Hardware now I'm
sorry an engine now if that is the case
that multiple people in the industry
know how to work with you can bring in
it's a big deal you can bring in
contractors now that could you know hit
the ground running you're not on
boarding a whole bunch of people
slipstream right it's slipstream and and
the thing is didn't know in the
beginning right we didn't know in the
beginning that slipstream was based off
of Old Tech when I heard slipstream I'm
like oh this is a new engine and forward
facing it was new but it was built off
of Old Tech so by the time when they get
to to to having to make content for Halo
infinite the tech debt is so high that
it's like we're not able to do the
things that we wanted to do and then you
know things go downhill with know the
story so I I think that's super
interesting and we'll see we'll see if
it if it's just we're going to stick to
a core Halo game with a great campaign
and great multiplayer component or we're
going to continue to do that in addition
to a live service game that's going to
be interesting and then the spin-offs
yeah I mean I really do think like when
you think about all that Halo has to
offer MH I would love to see Side
Stories I think one of my favorites one
of my some some of my favorite games in
the in the entire franchise are you know
uh
ODST um reach with a different team
right Point um I love that and then
continue obviously continue Chief story
so I I do think you know give it his
time to breathe let people forget about
it and miss it a little bit but come
back come back with with with with a
real plan about how to move this forward
yeah um so yeah we we'll see but I think
leaving infinite behind was going to
happen soon you know at some point and
it is happening sooner rather than later
and and it's a little sad considering
how much you know people are liking it
again now right and they got that that
content Cadence going right so it's a
little sad that this is happening but
the reality is you only have so much
bandwidth right so no for fair fair um
I'll Kings back so I'll jump in um Kings
back oh oh he wants to talk about this
yes King so um your thoughts on on the
future of
Hal yeah well um I totally uh expect you
know uh for us to launch with the new
console in 2026 oh okay for us um also
know that uh we'll be doing you know
spart and lock uh and the
team uh you know I I won't be taking off
my helmet in the video
game okay so you you stay true to the
cour G you helmet because a lot of these
guys think that I'm a
Mandalorian I'm I'm beholden by
Mandalorian Creed I mean you do keep
your helmet on in the game the majority
of the time because I'm in a vacuum of
space most of the time okay okay you
know and I don't have a breath M I have
this helmet on for
so I'm at my face you you choking under
the carbon
dioxide process
the process you know in the movie
theater you know I'm trying to get the
ladies okay I feel you smooth with it
you smooth with it yeah but um yeah we
we're moving away from Seasons we're
going into operations because we found
out in Seasons it really wasn't working
out for us we get a chance to drop out a
little little drop packs here now right
right right you know we get to make it
happen um and and like I said I would
love for the world to see exactly what
Spartan lock and the rest of the teams
was doing we we had big things
popping off over
here we're trying to make it for the new
console launch
2026 oh so we dropping oh so you coming
okay you tried to make it for the next
for Xbox x coming in hot okay yeah yeah
coming in hot we keeping a boot on Sony
neck
hash to keep the
moving um but what what I what I would
say is you're on to something we're
coming and we won't take our helmets off
why he got the beard it's the beiging
out okay that's enough you're seeing too
much we see too much you got in man you
got to you know what it is it's it's
atrio in his helmet Atri
Atri john7 this is we can't trust this
master chief King we can't
TR anyway look I agree pretty much all
the stuff you said I don't know what the
master chief is is ding but oh look yeah
I I think it you know for them to
transition from what is it to what is it
um Seasons I mean operations or whatever
it is no more seasons to me that's the
ramp down right that's the ramp down
that's the indicator that you know it's
it's in a good place as far as the
multiplayer now you'll probably get map
packs some you know some content but
it's going to be spaced out I do think
it's a mass and chief collections type
situation and I do I'm going to infer
that they have probably already started
working on whatever the next iteration
iteration of Halo is so yeah it only
makes sense yeah so that makes sense and
um look you know for me my whole thing
is now that the vision has changed cuz
my vision was okay infinite you know and
then maybe do like a live service bottle
where you bring in campaign stuff but
now that that's scrap so to speak I feel
now you do you know a clean slate you
know I I have to agree I know a lot of
people it's controversial but the the
the issues we hear with reference to
slip stream is that contractors come in
it's SP flip space thank you I knew it
was I knew I was saying it wrong you
know the issue we hear is that contract
they have they had a lot of contractors
to help out when contractors come in
this is a very bespoke unique engine and
if you don't have that experience it's
going to be tougher and you it's a
carousel people rotating in rotating out
so it's better in my opinion to go
unreal you already got Coalition in the
building who already has that experience
and you get if you're going to still
continue to use contractors
that's the more universally known engine
that's have more experience with so now
now with that being said to the people
who are against it I will give yall this
Halo has a very distinct feel and you
got to nail that in a different engine
which I'm confident you know they they
will so yeah man addict's Avatar is
killing me that it is funny and um yeah
man so I think that and um as far as the
spin-offs yes cameras on I don't know
what you guys are talking about you're
ridiculous
you ridiculous I actually like what he's
doing I didn't I didn't realize that the
mouth was moving on the a I actually
like what he's doing I like the fact
that the mouth moves that's what's up
yeah that's what's up the I I don't get
what you guys talking about
Avatar he's do it my beard ain't never
look so fresh you clean right now you
clean so we see what happens we'll see
what happens and I do want spin off yeah
for sure different genres different
stories all that keep it going keep the
LW popping there we go so um all right
we got big afran 14 hey IR Lord long
time first time first off I want to say
for all you guys do keep and keep doing
you you guys are the most entertaining
podcast I listen to with all four of you
bringing your own unique expertise and
taking to the show and making it a high
quality show keep it's it's it's really
like 15 of us if you count all king's
personality true salute salute on that
big you got a couple too there then yeah
yeah yeah right now he's got one right
now you rocking right now your man right
now look like what you going to call him
New York
Chic no I would never put New York on
any kind of know that's kind of new
yorkish right there you got right there
you got the bubble vest on what's up the
bubble the be be you got the little
sticking out the
top then I'm GNA have to switch it
because you compared any way sh or to me
to New York yeah you're New York now so
all right let me finish the Xbox
development direct this year was a solid
a minus for me it was awesome it hit in
all the right ways it fell fast straight
to the point amount of info we got for
each game Portland we got gameplay from
all the five games showed Vision the
Mana was nice a profile looked great
with his gameplay hell play looked
stunning as always in releas a AA looks
good for Forex players and in my opinion
Indian Indiana Jones stole the show a
first person action adventure mixed with
third person is definitely exciting
unique not some do some Tomb Raider
Uncharted clone overall the show was
great but to my
disappointment I kept seeing controversy
about Indiana Jones being first person a
certain fan base online downplayed the
game using bad faith arguments like
saying if it was third person they would
have played it or Xbox need third person
action invention games and they can't
even get that right I even saw someone
say Xbox just needed to copy Uncharted
and they dropped the ball the most
egregious one was them saying
firstperson games gives them motion
sickness apparently but plays psvr
doesn't it's ridiculous that every time
Xbox comes out with a showcase or
develop a direct we have to go through
this negative downplay of it even when
they're great my question to you guys is
do you think we'll ever get to a point
in Xbox life cycle where everything and
anything Xbox will be judged accordingly
and won't be nitpicked and judged to an
unachievable standard also what do you
think of Indian first person this is a
big one let's see he he got he felt
passionate about this adct you are up
where you at with this do you
agree um I definitely understand
people's like mindset when it comes to
wanting a third person I think the
biggest question here is it's okay to be
disappointed that you wanted a third
person where I lose you guys is where
you act like what they showed was
horrible like they didn't show you bad
game play like that that looked very
promising gameplay
to another point where even I wanted to
see a a third person game but when I saw
the gaml I'm like you know what machine
games knows how to make first persons so
I'm gonna let them I'm gonna let them
cook and see what it is then I'll make
my judgment when the game comes out but
it's just like and then people have this
weird concept where it's like the only
way to make games is the third person
aspect they're like oh you know first
person ain't really done captivated yeah
cuz you guys never give any of them an
opportunity to do it o like imagine like
every single game you see is third
person because that's what the way the
industry seems they want to go it's just
like look like third person does a lot
of things well but it's just like we
cannot act like machine games hasn't
done set Pieces good in first person
like it's like if you want the first
person Market to grow you actually have
to give developers the fre the
creativity to play those games now if
you end up getting the actual game and
you don't like it that's a different
story okay you know I gave it a shot it
it isn't what I wanted to be they should
have did third person I'd respect that
more but to come out to say it's not
third person I ain't I ain't buying it
because to me that just shows me what
game system you play on oh that just
shows me what platform you on N that it
shows me and I'm GNA let you finish it
just shows me something totally
different but I I'll get into it but
watch because I'm glad you said that
exactly thing that you said right there
cuz it's just like it's one thing to be
disappointed it's another thing to try
to bully the devs into doing the game
how you want it to be
made it's like but see what's what's
funny is you didn't see because I'm a
huge first person I love Fallout I love
all these games you did not see me going
a I'm mean huge Arcane fan yeah huge you
did not see me saying I want first
person why' they make third
person it's like look some games are
better for what and here's the thing
like what they showed me
easily Indiana Jones could be a valid
first person action adventure but if you
guys want to already put a stamp on it
before we even see really anything
because what did we really see we saw
some good Snippets of gamepl some good
traversal that's all and no hands on yet
like no one's played it right so it's
just like it's crazy to me that's why I
said like look people say oh it's not
because of PlayStation I disagree you
guys want everyone to make PlayStation
games
so because let's be real here look okay
look I'm not saying PlayStation invented
that type of games uh game all I'm
saying is they made it more mainstream
yes and to me when you look at something
like that it's okay if you're
disappointed don't even play it don't
buy it but don't try to don't try to
bully developers into into making a
certain type of game because to me I
want all of gaming to get better and if
people are only focusing on one type of
style of games how is the rest of the
industry supposed to grow assembly line
assembly line I feel you I feel you K
solve your thoughts are people being
disingenuous and your thoughts are the
Indie first person thing getting into it
um I might as well because be during my
uh yeah so
my one thing this is going to be a theme
for me in in in talking about this
develop a direct don't give us the whole
direct just yet though yeah no no no no
I'm just going specific but the general
theme is like I had to get over
what I wanted and what I got at the end
of the day you know you come in you want
something you have expectations or
whatever and then you have to you have
to accept what you got and and and talk
about it fairly and that's where someone
again they're they're always going to be
bad faith arguments about anything it's
conso Waring it's GNA happen somebody's
gonna make up some random thing about
something that that makes no sense right
so whatever that's the disingenuous
arguments are nothing new here of course
so I went and in my initial reaction was
disappointment at the fact that it
wasn't a third person game and the
disappointment stems from this the two
main franchises that this uh have
cribbed the most from Indiana Jones
because make no mistake they've cribed
from Indiana Jones is obviously
Uncharted and Tomb Raider right Tomb
Raider to the point where they they
rebooted it and made it even more like
Uncharted uh it's funny cuz you know
Tomb Raider came right cribed off of
Indiana Jones then Uncharted came cribed
off of Tomb Raider right and then Tomb
Raider came back and cribed off of
Uncharted again so and to me it was just
like I really wanted the opportunity to
have Indie the the originator of this
have his own third person game with that
level of production value that level of
fidelity understand um right so I was
initially disappointed at that and even
looking at it as through the lens of the
hybrid model I was like okay they could
have gone hybrid the other way where
it's like I love the fact that you could
you give me the puzzles that's what I
thought they were going to do H the
other way give me the puzzles in in
first person right so it could be more
interactive and it's just not you know
it it doesn't feel as gamified if you're
doing it in first person like that I I
feel like that would be cool and then
the action sequences the fighting you
come out into third person and you give
me a robust fighting system where you
know you know Indie uses he uses
everything at his disposal right and
that way also when it comes to
animations when people talk about first
person animation first person animation
is still even at the highest level can
be a little weird right you know we
we'll talk about about later but you
know it could feel a little stiff
sometimes you got to get it just right
so to me but what I saw of what you know
in Indie I enjoyed in terms of like him
grabbing the Nazis up punching them in
the face I thought the the the the the
faces that reacted well um I want to see
what they do with the whip right because
the whip is to me when I looked at that
I'm like wow I know machine games is is
good for when it comes to the cinematics
um when it comes to the set pieces
Wolfenstein any of those Wolfenstein
games play New Colossus know they can do
that and the crazy thing is if you
really think about who was making this
game who was behind this game and Todd
Howard it was easy to infer that this
would be more of a first person game
that person game that that is just their
expertise right um the these developers
a lot of them came from Star Breeze and
tyon that made escape from butcher Bay
OG Xbox that we that was something that
was nobody expected that game to be as
good as it was it had no right to be as
good as it was so I have no doubt that
this is going to be a great cinematic
experience so I put aside my initial
sort of worry about that
mhm I just think the argument it there
dis like I said they're disingenuous
arguments the genuine arguments that
come from people that kind of say look I
I just I like the third I wanted it
third person I do feel in some ways that
it just feels like Xbox runs from third
person over the show to action adventure
apart from hellblade they run from that
like the plague for whatever reason like
they don't want to be they don't want to
have that direct comparison because when
they have the opportunity to do it they
don't do it right right we're going to
see
blade blade coming yeah it is coming
right but I just up until now I can see
that argument where it's like anytime
they have a chance to do something that
couldn't be on the level of comparison
to an Uncharted or or Last of Us
whatever they go a different direction
and I think here when you look at the
teams that are making it it makes the
most sense that would make this game
right um when you know when you say oh
it's going to be we thought it was going
to be most immersive by doing it okay
whatever you you're you're leaning into
your strengths just say that don't say
this one is better than this one or
whatever lean into your strengths this
is the game you're making okay okay like
that A A lot of that is still sort of
it's its marketing speak or whatever the
case may be but I just think when you
consider the team that's making it and
you consider what we saw I think it is
going to be a a package that is well
worth the wait um I'm excited to see
what they do in first person with the
whip and everything it's funny that they
had to still pay Harrison for for his
his
likess shout out to Mari cuz he looks
like he's you know 35 whatever yeah I
think she should be happy yeah you'll be
happy his butt you know what I
mean it's like I said last week it would
be really hard to make a game without
his likeness because like he he's been
he is Indie he you know you're right
there's not another person he is Indie I
wonder what happens with that franchise
if they just Sunset it when he dies or I
don't know what but age him so you yeah
he'll live forever we have I do think
they'll eventually
we got replace him with some we
him but uh yeah I saw a couple of the
technology we do have the technology but
I saw some I saw a couple of podcasts
where people were like ah this thing
looks amazing I wish it was I it wish I
wish it was on my
PlayStation we'll
get I mean it is what it is you this is
a conversation that's going to happen
and you know Xbox is finally games are
coming out that are people across the
pond are looking at like oh hey man I
like that hey hey man well there's
something called Game Pass there
something called PC if you don't want to
get an Xbox or whatever um they all got
powerful PCS don't they yeah so so they
say so
they po up but uh I was I I like the
game I like the game I got over you know
my initial disappointment about that but
um I trust machine games um I trust
machine games uh I know Todd's hot
vision for it uh you know that first
person stuff I'm excited to see how deep
they go with the puzzles and stuff like
that um it was weird when I saw the the
stealth stuff I'm like did Arcane help
them with this aspect of it cuz you see
first you give me all your bars and but
this is the bars for for for Indie
that's Indie okay and then you going to
give it a bar cuz we missed you okay I
got you they but they did that though
like people act like machine games
didn't do this the so-called woke
version of the
Wolfenstein um you remember of with his
two daughters the you know that game I
forgot oh no that game that game wasn't
whack because of wokeness that game was
whack because it was like a looter
shooter no but well people wanted to you
know attack on the wokeness to it that's
why they didn't play it but if they get
a chance to play that game that I like
they didn't know that it was stealth
elements inside the game yeah 100% yeah
Young Blood to me if they had made that
game if they had made that game Young
Blood Young
Blood
that's I will never forget it
now if they had made that game because
it wasn't machine that made it proper
per se right um you know they tried
something else whatever
um yeah I think they it would have it
would have been better as just a story
based sort of thing but they tried to do
something different with it whatever I
love it I trust machine when it comes to
when you play if you play the the the
New Order and The New Colossus um yeah
so um I trust them what we saw look
great um I think a lot of what we saw
was on PC so again we it's another thing
a lot of people I don't know that we saw
a lot of Xbox footage per se in this
direct this PC stuff very nice and crisp
looking um I don't know when it's my
team I'm assume the best
anyway which is PC yeah well well you
know you know hey man we all develop we
all team we all we all we all developed
from some place right you know
PlayStation joints look good till they
get home tell the TRU Shane the devil
let's be let's be shout out shout out
but um I'm excited for the game I'm
excited for it King uh are these
arguments disingenuous like uh my man is
saying uh big Afroman and your your
thoughts on the the whole you know Indie
first person drama well it's it's
completely disingenuous because these
are the same individual that so Sony put
out the other day um what was that game
from Gorilla Games Kill Zone they show
concept art from Killzone 3 and how you
know they give a a look back on a decade
of uh you know Killzone and what it
could have been and these people were
going nuts oh man oh I would love
another Kill Zone man your kill Zone's
crazy did you see the art a they let
that go you know they oh they messing up
man kill kill on first person I thought
you got motion
sickness wait a second wait a second
here so what you say that about psvr too
he say how they have motion we a even
get on that cuz they ain't even buy it
but um they a even bu don't even don't
even bring up the fact that they they
talk about PlayStation VR2 that is not
relevant to that fan base because they
did not support it is a passion project
for small develop for for small
individuals like myself that I have an
Xbox those guys don't buy anything and
we know where they are now but and this
is another thing you hear some uh people
on panels talk about they just paid off
their PlayStation 5 and how can they
afford to get Indiana Jones if it's not
coming to the PlayStation um you know
ecosystem my it's not my fault you bet
on the wrong horse that's one two if you
have your PlayStation on layaway oh man
let me this is not pocket washing this
is not pocket shaming these are
different priorities okay you know these
are luxury this is not something that
you need to do this is not essential to
living this is not water this is not
eathing this is not clothing this is not
housing if you have to put it on layway
I think you should not be gaming I think
you need to get stuff in
order what about the the the system that
Xbox has where you can pay monthly XX
ACC that's lay
away that's not lay away let me explain
what that is that's person having good
credit and having
priorities what you're saying people
that do layway can't have good no no
listen listen there is no program for
the PlayStation ecosystem that allows
you to get the console and pay it off
through whatever you doing there's no
program it's called lay away from a
third party now that's called here's
some of my money I'll be back Tuesday
for a hamburger today
not the whippy so we don't do we don't
do whippy stuff over here this is real
progam that we have for people that uh
you know putting their life in order
anyway don't try to do real stuff addict
I mean you're the one that doesn't make
a I didn't you I you was talking I just
said one thing say hi and I was it bye
oh bye he making anyway
adct so I I guess we just got to let you
talk uninterrupted don't even question
anything King says like King does for
you adct okay well no first off you
interrupt me all the time let's not act
like let's talk about to
dat stop stop bringing up old stuff ad
yeah messing we got to grow
continue anyway Indiana Jones first
person looks really great um I thought
it was a stroke of Genius to say that
we're not going to do what is expected
we're not going to do uh what has been
done already there's a reason why you
don't see
Uncharted it got stale there a reason
why you don't see uh Tomb Raider every
year you know that formula how many
times you going to raid a tomb and do
the same thing or or you go to a big
budget you and your brother you got to
come up with different scenarios
different
stuff it got stale the sales reflected
that it was flat so you wanted them to
come out and do the same thing that
y'all got tired of but why got to be I
don't understand what this everybody
thinks you got to come out third person
game and is got to do the all the same
thing why is that the case I don't
understand that we don't need to do what
they're
doing what and and and you know here we
go that we found out that they don't buy
games so why we have to do with what
game is popular this isn't the this is
the business of selling games so you
you're you're you're you're you have to
go to what your fan base is about lost
them
chat listen we lost them completely
listen this is the business of selling
games right which Xbox does not do a lot
of well I mean obviously they doing
something good because they're making
more money than the competition the
competition tell nothing sell I did not
selling games well I I mean I don't know
I mean numbers dictate different things
I heard I heard Walmart was burning
copies of stuff the other day well I I
don't know you got to show me your
figures I don't know now this this is s
this is The Sovereign News
Network well he has no he has no
he
letur let me go to the video oh my God
can we get through this Patriot question
please we get to the topic I just wanted
to talk my talk this is getting upset
with me they get up with you I don't
even understand anyway thank you
microsof
up because I said that they wanted to do
something different actually they did so
what how is that making something up
they actually showed you they show them
Pro Lu August coming for s in the chat
he say Starfield was the number three
selling game on steeve how is Xbox not
selling game s don't pay him no M leave
him Al Al over there oh here we
go they sell it on Xbox they sell it on
Xbox they sell it where it's available
where they can sell Xbox does get the
revenue nice in a roundabout way
I mean they did Mario sell on
Playstation no right it's not there I'll
accept that argument wholeheartedly when
they're a third party oh you know what
how about your knees man oh we going
there we going there today we going
there today listen I don't want your
knees I just want you to take that
Messiah crap off top of list so let's go
for that let go listen gra go for what
how title for title let's start let's
start doing something different because
you right now this s News Network title
wow oh you to check oh this
get about this oh this I don't have to
reportedly be disposing of physical
copies of the Xbox series X exclusive
Starfield marking down the price to
three cents and implementing a point of
sale
block I'm what tit you get rid of what
ti you get rid of so King wants to get
rid of Messiah so I don't have to say it
no more all right what's the what's the
bet let's go come on we not doing best's
the BET King what's the bet the the bet
is you said that um they're going to be
going third party right I when did I say
that I said when they go I will accept I
said when I will accept that argument
wholeheartedly we're third party whole
heartedly I'll accept your argument
whole stop trying to this doesn't work
on me K you understand it doesn't work
on me right I'm sound like running no no
no y'all heard y' heard what y'all
wanted to hear I heard what I want to
hear I don't want to do that intro so
yes I think you running s you running
get him y was talking at the same time I
wanted to get straight to what you was
talking
about now I just saw you back down
back psychopath like y Phil is terrified
of Y psychopath is why which is why
they're not saying they going PD party
that's all right back he don't he don't
want that smoke with you sh you good he
his knees was shaking I know that's all
good but I want my Messiah next
week can I
get move we got move we
got Let meish My Fault by fault let me
just wrap it up with I like Jones and I
like the direction they
in they interrupted you a whole
second it it was a sabotage they they J
you they you it was is the weird looking
they trying to assassinate you go they
trying to assassinate you go co co It's
the weird looking white guy over there
in the yeah that guy I don't even know
who that guy is he look like a sketch of
a sketch of another
guy oh man look like what they put on
the wage posters at the police station
look W add is when he hears knees he
jumps in he's
like seen this man
anywhere look I make quick pretty much
agree with mostly what y'all said shout
out to man or what was his name um big
afro man um look of course there's going
to be people with bad faith arguments we
know this we know this we know that if
it's not on the platform that you like
to play on a lot of times dudes would
not everybody but some dudes will all of
a sudden have all these magical reasons
as to why not and this that I will
defend the people on the other side to
say look it's okay to be disappointed
that you may have wanted it in third
person I for me I was the person that
said yo I wanted coming into it like I
wanted it to be third person so we could
see Indie and all I was the guy that
said that obviously I do know it's
machine Gams so at first when I heard it
especially I'm going tell you why I
think a lot of people for some who's in
that camp the disappointment hits is
because AR I blame
Arcane
Arcane they out of nowhere cuz we came
in condition blade is going to be first
but this is Arcane right so they ain't
going so when they we go we see Dinger
come outside on the game awards and say
third we oh this is the new direction
must be Xbox is going or something we we
just attribute one Studio's action into
like everyone's going to do this so I
blame myself for that in in that respect
but to machine gain's point and what
here's the thing and I said it on Duke
you could be disappointed that it was a
third part that's fine but if you going
to sit there and say that I'm with
addict 100% if you going to sit there
and say that what you saw on the screen
did not look fun did not look Innovative
at least they're doing something
completely different and where I agree I
believe it was s whoever said it where
it's like the
OG those guys were based Uncharted
literally is based off of the OG off of
Indiana Jones and then put it in the
space tomb rated they based off of what
Indie so if Indie does come out in that
way it is they going to look at Indie
like you biting them when they they was
based off you so there's a part of me
that does understand machine games you
know uh like their understanding of why
they're doing this I get it I get it to
be disappointed but I'm not going to sit
there and say what I saw was was whack
and oh it was terrible n I'm not doing
and then also In fairness ain't none of
y'all played this game yet so to sit
there and say like that that part I'm
going to push back and say it's dis and
G how about we play the game see if they
execute what they going to execute right
and then make a judgment so that's where
I'm at with it again if you going to say
that you you don't want to play fine
that's about you oh I like what I saw
ain't nobody going to stop my fun I was
like yeah I came in disappointed and
then I was like oh oh no okay they they
might be on to something you know what
I'm saying and then it gives them their
unique flavor on this that's all it's
cool so that's where I'm at last
question dieago padr hello Lords no
questions uh just dropped by to
congratulate you all on being the
opening act for Last Stand media's event
enjoy the moment as much as possible
have an awesome show salute salute
salute you already know we can finally
get to topic three l p in the CH he's
like what y'all doing the power top it
relax I know you play like 30 hours we
you get to
that you want me to get these super
chats oh yeah yeah sorry I forgot about
those let me see let me see we got power
boss member for one month Lord bronze
let's go power world Dev on Xbox
confirmed it's on Xbox and steam and
will not come to PlayStation why is this
cause for celebration oh man cuz Kong
will die that's
why oh speaking of which there is an
update on that with the let me not to
thr instigate but apparently um yeah
there's a tweet that's going by um that
someone pulled up I guess they were like
well power world is coming to PS5 and
then I believe the community manager at
pocket pair that's for power world they
said he put their back then June 4th
power world won't be on Playstation only
Xbox and steam so then I guess they
double down like N I get it's coming and
he just tweeted today eight hours ago he
said this old tweet is suddenly doing
the rounds apparently needs clarifying
so the above posted said ploud world
will be released on PS4 PS5 Xbox and PC
I replied that it won't be on
Playstation which was and still is
currently true and that it will only be
on Xbox and Ste team and that is still
true he said but then yo this is wow he
just but then he goes he says but then
by no means a this by no means a
statement that power will never come to
PlayStation please don't twist my words
to perpetuate silly arguments this is
getting
crazy I think I think listen 2 million
sold
in coming place it's coming Place n not
unless Xbox got anything to y going like
yall going to like the
poll like if Phil if Phil sees this like
the this is this is Minecraft level of
uh we see that far I I I wouldn't I mean
I'm talking about what the start like
come on they just they just was born
right this is one of the most incredible
but let's let's stay by Bo for the time
wait talk talk po
again then we got let me see we got BT
Maverick 70755 Super Chat can we get
cold East or cold Eastward to make the
sizzle real for ilp's LSM show oh my God
y'all being messy I know what you doing
stop it I know what you're
doing uh just stop being messy salute
the coach salute the Colin hate it when
my my friends go at it but I have to
stay out of it Call's out of pocket for
that listen I I'm over the hell went
down yeah just I hate it when you know
you know how like you got people that
you cool with and then you know it's be
a disagreement so I'm like oh man what
we doing yeah you know what I'm saying
so look it is what it is obviously
people allowed to do what they want to
do that's just my feeling you know I'm
not going to judge what no other man is
doing but nothing to do with you they
got nothing to do with me that's just
how I feel it I'm going to move
on then we have con artistic $5 Super
Chat can you see clearly in the helmet I
want one for writing my EU okay um I see
clearly enough that is not a helmet for
you to be riding around them with for
real you will die sir just like
Kong
oh man then we have GSD AKA getting
stuff done $5 Super Chat machine games
made escape from butcher there you go
butcher Bay before they were even
machine games Indie stealth will be
crazy I hope so I hope you really do
have that option like for me give me the
opportunity I'm just going to use the
whip all day and nothing else tangle
people up you ain't hear what they
saying there's a controversy about the
whip we going to move on we going to
move on we going to move on it just
funny you said that but we going to move
on oh is it oh word
it's some social thing oh God hold on
let me get that Halo after this is crazy
how Cognito moved on the topic showing
he won't speak out his look bro I got so
many friends and a lot of them Yo dud
some dudes just not going to get along
right so for me it's like unless it's
like yo if I see two dudes really going
at it disrespectfully and it's like
y'all taking this way too far right
that's different but dude is going to
agree to we got to learn to agree to
disagree you know what I'm saying yeah
and obviously I have my side or I feel
but as long as you know it ain't nobody
ain't taking it to no Next Level I'm
minding my business I'm staying out of
it got nothing to do with me like that
so that's where I'm at on that kog has
brought many a person to the table to to
to to squash things to squash and to
your point speaking of said individual
since you you so concerned about Colin
you know I remember there was a time
when him and and Grub were going at it
and I I didn't like where it was going
in that one and then I jumped in and I
said something the public so I'll step
in if I see something crazy this light
we got to stop being emotional just
because we don't like someone's opinion
that's it that's what they said that's
what they said you feel some way a
different way that's fine but don't get
all in your feelings way it's ah you
know I'm saying I can't believe like
come on it ain't that serious it's video
games continue every we got J J Max must
have happen no something went down no it
went down it went down I'll ask you
later what up I never know anything yeah
every me talk we got J ma $5 Super Chat
I'd rather be a second class citizen and
the and the first class weirdo # grave
we the boys we outside X I know exactly
what he's talking yeah there was was
that that podcast it's the same exact
podcast where they was broke at and they
couldn't afford um to finish paying off
they their PlayStation and um yeah I I
saw y'all anyway so there was like they
called Xbox uh Gamers second class
citizens and because because
everything's supposed to come on on
PlayStation I'm glad that that was
verbalized because that's exactly how
you guys feel you guys feel that we are
we should have nothing we should have no
rights and you guys are entitled to
everything it's
[Music]
over over we had your boo on our direct
now you gotta find out can't we all just
get get when you think we're second
class citizens and you can't even pay
for your hobby so we can pay for our
hobby you guys are the second class
citiz it's over we're taking everything
from you we want the whole
slate put everything in the bag
everything I can't with you then we got
Hollywood rules $2 Super Chat uh compare
and crew are the definition of casual
yeah yeah okay I don't know what's going
on that that that was that that podcast
I don't watch it I don't know what's
going on
continue
and we got the homie hard chanani $5
Super Chat how long will the true
Playstation only fans go before they
just get an Xbox the floodgates of games
are about to open up oh oh so that sound
like okay hugy I see where you
going then we got hary chotty once again
$10 Super Chat sorry s the sales on
Playstation side aren't that good I
didn't compare the sales of Xbox to play
I just said xBox wasn't that's all I
said found that uh found that out to
leaks Xbox is doing fine on sales and
Subs physical is having issues physical
is having issues like I said I didn't
say they were throwing out Starfield
codes I
said physical
discs is having issues across the board
and more than half of Xbox is digital
only yes which makes sense because they
are telling you that they want you to go
into the game pass and not buy game so
um let me see Hollywood r on Super Chat
Co keep making those Sizzle yes I got to
see what's going on this
is It's Hot these streets it's hot in
the streets dudes is
emotional J G2 Super Chat pathetic Port
begging hes got no games # no ps6 thank
you for your
Pat as always gang gang J gang gang g g
j g g my shooter D is emotional today I
love it Hollywood rules $5 Super Chat we
GoPro cam on Cog while he's watching the
49ers a collective H in San Francisco
Nation I ain't even going to hold you I
my heart ain't never beat that hard for
like a sports game in a minute that game
bro I I I was going through all of this
yeah salute you're right you're right we
we did we on to the next we survived
somehow let's move on I W W there you go
w w w man we got let me see then we got
JD gamer again $5 Super Chat pathetic
Fort beggy PS fans stop begging for Xbox
GES you have no games ain't get no games
ain't never gonna have no games now live
with it good god bang bang got his G get
him there we got J gamer once again
super CH Lieutenant JD gamer reporting
Duty and I say these pathetic Port
begging ponies got no games we're taking
it all now live with that it's ours M
carry on Soldier Howes how does a
soldier end with a kiss
m going hard the
street then we have uh ryuart gaming $2
Super Chat Pony BTS Port begging for
successful Xbox game s
okay then we got Hollywood rules again
$5 Super Chat Square enix's name was
looking real Co next to the rest of the
first party teams
call look like we got your boo is that
your
cheick oh man not is that your
chick I like it we caught up CAU up cool
no doubt no doubt no doubt so we going
to get oh no no you're not no Hollywood
rules again $2 Super Chat the general
had to give someone some
work TR sh
the these
these
pathetic I got triple P triple P God we
got Sage $10 super Sol Game Pass brings
in more revenue for Xbox per I'm talking
about a physical disc getting thrown
into the garbage I
said Revenue me have you bought have you
bought has has Xbox sent you a a a a
disc of a game that you purchase through
Game Pass I don't think so right it's
not Netflix that's what I'm saying
brings in more revenue for Xbox's first
party than the 43.9 million first party
game Sony sold in fiscal year 2022 even
assuming they all sell for $69.99 Game
Pass still wins okay Sage thank you
thank you for your patronage I
appreciate all right all I said was they
were burning
Starfield we still got more the chats
are coming in dud don't like
that it's a Fired Up Show today like
they don't like s news work they like s
they like
me we got J Boy On The Run oh he on the
Run he on the Run Breezy in the house we
need to end it all it's getting bad now
the go poost being moved now it's not
working remember we had no games we
didn't beg that's I don't know about
that part I ain't back for nothing from
them those man they man still got one
there we got Andre Doyle $2 Super Chat
Xbox has way more than hash just one
moving forward I agree I like that I
like that yeah all right we going let's
let's get to the time before they go so
all right developer direct obviously the
Lords have they did a stream you know
what I'm saying on this and we did oh
man JD
G JD Gaber we got your Yakuza Persona
Mana card we got your mascot crash
what's next are you scared we getting it
all remember you started it never poke a
bear he the north remembers the north
never
forget I just listen I I don't y just
yall angry like it happened
yesterday y really like y' been when you
got slapped yo he remember like back in
the day he was a shorty when you SL like
it happened yesterday bro he carries
that forever he got that SC but he got
beef with you
forever it goes man we don't let go bro
I feel hey y'all order it y'all order it
gay gang so look yeah develop the LA as
we did the uh the stream and um our
reactions obviously s we get your
opinions and stuff but yeah it's um the
post mem you know now we got time to
settle how we feeling obviously we had
AOW set it off first hellblade 2 went
second um we got the May release date um
new news on uh hellblade actually being
$50 digital only release um so just want
to put that out there that came out
after the stream and then all visions of
Mana Square Enix you know what I'm
saying making their presence there AA
history Untold launching fall 2024 PC
joining PC gay pass day one Indiana
Jones in the great circle launching 2024
as how they closed out the show so how
we feeling postmodem um let's get atct
them first cuz I want to um now that you
have time to to settle we all had time
to settle on it you know I know how you
thought at the beginning um still
standing on it how you feeling with you
know with everything now no just stand
on what I said like look like I I had no
issue with the show I thought the show
was good I thought the content was good
I thought the pacing was good I just
didn't like that there wasn't enough uh
release dates on there and you know
people can disagree with that that's
fine you disagree with your parents your
family I don't give two [__] to you
disag language language language sir you
know the thing is it's just like it's
funny coming from that Avatar we got to
we got to regulate South Park addict
yeah South Park adct is wild South Park
at he outside with it so so you say it's
okay to disagree agree to disagree yeah
cuz it's like people sit there what's
funny is like they our audience does
nothing but like boost us so I like you
know different opinions oh so you say
what our audience I know where you going
I know where you going but then the
moment like disagree on something that
they agree with a you tripping at it
like no man like I love what I saw but
excuse me for wanting to see when I
would be playing these games now I can
understand the concept and the reason
they don't show release dates right now
that's fine but I could still be
disappointed I didn't see them just like
you guys some of you are disappointed
that Indiana Jones is in a third person
action adventure game I could be
disappointed that I didn't see a release
date on that game that we were referring
to doesn't mean I ain't G to play the
game doesn't mean I ain't going to enjoy
what I saw it just means that I wanted a
little bit more conrete on what I was
seeing at the time of that release date
now we could get it and another reason
that I feel very strong about this
because if we ain't seeing a release
date now call nine times out of 10 what
does that mean I mean it could be a
chance of moving around it could be a
chance to lay you don't know what it is
it means it means seeing the majority of
these games in the June showcase again
oh okay okay I see what you said okay so
if that you know I find that
disappointing because it's like I get it
it's probably just like a little tiny
trailer and stuff but it's how I felt
about them reowing Starfield for the
18th time last holiday when they had a
giant direct going on it's just like
look like I want I just wanted to see
more concrete release and that doesn't
mean I ain't going to you know really
it's just crazy that people feel like I
have to like just me criticizing is me
like talking smack about the the direct
like I like the direct I felt like this
is the direct is some of the best pacing
they've done in a long time but that
doesn't mean it's perfect it just means
that they are doing something good Fair
enough fair enough no I get where you're
going you know it's it's totally okay to
to be like hey I I would like to know
you know outside of HBL 2 which we got
to May 21st you know when I'm might get
my hands on stuff we get we'll get into
it I wanted to say um the other gam we
know you were hyped about a vow um I
want just on a game level just
individual like what did a vow do for
you what did hellblade do for you what
did Indiana Jones do for you what did
the squ like what did you feel on a game
level what you saw now like what did you
feel uh I don't really care about the
game that that Square Enix showed I like
more that it was there than the game
itself okay um not I've never been a
huge fan of the Mona franchise okay U
you know I need to get back in but this
isn't turnbas either so it's kind of
like weird but it's like I like that
it's there it's just me particularly
this game didn't really resonate with me
I just like that we've seen stuff like
that because the games uh I've always
said you know it doesn't matter if it's
not game pass Microsoft just to be
aggressive and make sure these games at
least come to the platform and I like
that was in the platform you know when
it comes out about I liked what I saw of
V there's like a lot of weird energy
around of V like I still don't
understand what like look I was the
first person and I still hold by you
know what they showed of us at that
first starting trailer did this yeah it
was very darker it's very it's not
representative of what we're seeing but
that doesn't mean the game's going to be
bad like once again I can love something
and still criticize it may I have to
repeat that I don't think that's
possible something and criticize I don't
think I think we got to beef with each
other and call each other names when we
disagree I
just people that's what we do now that's
what we do we disagree got disrespect
the person and then I saw people saying
that that a vow needed to be a third
person action adventure game and I'm
just like what like do to me if you're
saying stuff like that you don't even
know what this game what what what a V's
doing like like if you expect it to be a
third person chances are you'll probably
be able to play the game in a third
person perspective because they the
these St these companies have done that
before but to like sit there and say it
would have been better third person what
I I don't get
that no fair enough fair enough and no
AA love you
strategy n it's not coming to Xbox and
I'm not really on my PC that much and
zxt that's play on man here's the thing
I like I like
Civilization that has like a co-op
aspect and as bad as it sounds it's got
to dumb it down because there too much I
want to play it with my friends no you
can play I might be able to understand
the civilization formula and how the
game works and you can either went
through a technological site uh science
or religion or or wealth or battle 88%
of my friends don't know how any of that
works so it's like unless unless I'm
playing like a dumber down version of
that game I don't think I'm really going
to enjoy it because I'm not going to be
able to play with my friends no doubt no
doubt all right The Sovereign this is
the one I've been waiting for because
obviously you know so couldn't make the
stream live whatever we got the Indiana
Jones bars mostly but I get a chance for
the rest of the show like uh will you
feeling about a vow how are you feeling
about hellblade 2 you know how are you
feeling about arur and obviously
division of man
announcement and then uh like kind of
what was your radio to show after now
analis so break it down on a game basis
and then give me your um you know your
your kind of review of the Xbox direct
okay so um well let's start with AA
right arura it's the same thing it's
like I don't have time to play those
type of games anymore um but when you
look at the pedigree of the the team uh
these guys a former Faris guys oxide is
like it's Faris civilization it's Civ
devs you know that the expertise behind
making this type of game is there so
that said I'm confident that it's going
to be a very very good game and the and
you know that the idea that these
veterans in this genre are trying trying
to sort of elevate the genre and take it
in some new different directions and
sort of when they say we're making the
game that we've always wanted to make
and you have to do that right when you
have the these these set franchises
already you kind of you work within a
certain structure now is like we're
creating we're creating the structure
now right so I I just think whatever
that game turns out to be I think it's
going to be a very good one of those um
and I hope it does well and I hope they
figure they figure out a way to get it
to Xbox we will see um so that that was
that um second let's go to vow second
well no let's go let's go to visions of
Mana okay I think I think that was it
was important to see I I don't play
jrpgs the way I used to back in the day
that's used to that pretty much I played
back in the day was jrpgs right um but I
think it's I think it's important that
this happened it shows that square like
you know the new management over Square
Enix is really truly um honest when
they're saying hey we're trying to you
know get these games onto more platforms
we're working in Earnest with Xbox um
you know I don't know what sort of
pre-existing deals are going on and when
we when and if we'll see a final fantasy
right because like that's what everybody
wants to see right this is this is this
is huge and the fact that they're there
but again everybody wants to see the big
boys right and see if that's happening
if that's coming but this is this is
what you got to do right you gotta you
got to grow that relationship you know
and and the fact that they are on a
stream where this is all Xbox umbrella
first party it's quite interesting isn't
it huh it's very interesting but I'm
like you know what it's a scenario I I
can't even re I don't even want to
verbalize it because it would be so
World destroying if that happen oh K
would be out of pocket you it's a thing
like if that happens I would be insan
like it really ad is going to love it
cuz he going to watch the world burn he
going to and that's the thing it's a
world burning moment I'm not going that
far because the the people make ARA like
they're not owned by Xbox so I feel like
it's just like what's going like this is
primarily around revolved around theirs
but whatever Big Marketing pushes they
want to do they'll throw those in here
to fill the gaps yeah and the fact I and
they wanted to show that right cuz the
game isn't in Game Pass as far as we
know right so it's just a matter of
showing that that this relationship is
strong it's real we have a brand new
game coming and it's going to be on Xbox
day one and that's that is a big big
State game game right it's not in game
path so but it will be on Xbox day one
Cho which hasn't been happening right
with all the square releases exactly it
has not been a choice in the past so
that I I I was glad to see that happen
and I had a feeling there was going to
be some some kind of secret thing um so
then let's go to AOW yes I'm curious how
you feeling about that obsidian the
black see the Black Rock they did the
Black Rock for a reason right they are
Black Rock Xbox yeah the Black Rock Xbox
right let's
go they are as consistent as can be you
can't so when I looked at the game I'm
like you know what again had to put
aside expectation and expectation for me
with them is like man eventually the
team will get yeah I know they're
working on multiple things right so I'm
like eventually they're going to take
that expertise they have in World
building and storytelling and just give
us like the highest Fidelity possible
like most polished version of that type
of game it doesn't have to be of the
scope of a Skyrim right I like the fact
that they're smaller because I think
their story content works better in a
smaller Zone sort of uh Zone environment
instead of one humongous open world I
think they're the masters of that and I
I I'm happy that they decided to
eliminate the multiplayer stuff really
and focus on what they're good at um and
I think I'm not worried about any of
that when it comes to this game right
the only thing that looked a little
weird to me still what's up and and
especially in comparison to the more
polished stuff that we see later on
is the things that you see in in these
games which is the facial
animations the stiff the stiffness
so you think you think reason Xbox put
them at at the first you start you you
Dro it in the first quarter and then we
going have these other dudes we see
their faces you're not you're not quite
ready yet we have to build Crescendo we
got to build up looking stuff I got you
I got you and this is stuff again this
is this is stuff that isn't their fault
per se it's you know firstperson gaming
is that way like it could be a little
wonky a little janky um but again the
bar has sort of been raised for this
stuff when you got studios in building
right you got stud in the building right
um even when you look at something like
the things that balers gate does in you
know in close proximity story stuff
right you're like okay there a different
level of Polish here are we going to
start getting there but that said I have
no doubt the game is I I I you know I
trust obsidian implicitly I have the
stories I I feel is going to be great
the the choice and consequence is always
very big in their games I think that
they can expand upon that um and when
you look at it watched it again in 4k
right so I'm looking at it go back to
the point about I think this is the PC
version right it's very super super
crisp super polished um the the facial
um the character models look good it's
like not they don't look good the
texture stuff on the clothing looks
crazy so uh you know it definitely is a
step up from Outer worlds one so I I I'm
excited for it I just want to see how
the combat plays out right cuz to
addict's point that original reveal had
you you know with a sword in hand and
sort of doing these sort of symbols in
midair to sort of bring magic up right
and and we didn't see that right you
could you could Harry Potter it with two
to two wands or you could be you know
with you could you could dual wield uh
you know weapons or whatever so it
that's going to be super interesting the
fact that they said you can change these
loadouts on the Fly and sort of change
the Dynamics of fights in a split second
to me is super interesting um I just
want to see how it plays out because
again it's the the the enemies looked a
little dumb right just coming at you a
little bit so that was that um now we go
to
hell here here's the debate that we I
know it's coming I know it's coming let
me hear it so look again like I said
putting put putting aside expectation
and what I want and just looking at
what's there and it's funny because the
guy the first guy that spoke he said it
immediately he's like yeah hellblade is
going to be around the same length as
the first one the same type of it so my
thing is like okay
fine when they got Ninja Theory and I
saw and I saw um senua I said okay this
is their chance for that hasht just one
take this character make her the make
her a mascot right make put it on the on
the box and make it into this this crazy
amazing action game because I know that
they're known for their action right MH
but that's not what Seno was from the
first one oh okay go was okay no no and
I again I had to be like you know what
they're not doing it this is not they
don't have that have that Vision they
don't have that vision for son I wish
they would have had that vision
for but they don't have that vision for
you can look at the game the game looks
ridiculous but you you know that the
money went to all right the Fidelity let
me delete my diss track I had a diss
track for you let me delete I'mma act
like yo producer delete to Sol
this first
F first yeah I I literally had bars
typed for and he completely dismantled
me and I'm like damn I got to delete the
diss track nobody can't know I was about
to do that fin he
was I was going to K slay I was about to
hit the radio I was
ready I got I will still say all right
cooking I saying
it's obvious that the money went to the
look of game you're right you're right
you're right you're right is going to be
an eight hour amazingly beautiful
cinematic experience Ain Spider-Man
eight
hours I don't know I don't think
it's pass all the book bags you if you
do that that's if be L I don't know
anyway go first
off so again there their whole thing was
Sena in this C no you ain't talking
about me you
what you
hawaian you been on my you love my sty I
was ready man damn take my I had drop a
j all over I had no at all you do you
got you got to diffuse you got to you
know what it is cuz I'm like I'm too old
to be like to be harping on know should
have could have would I can't I can't so
it's like you know to me when they got
this character I'm like yo they can
expand this out make her you know make
make her this this they just one and
really blow this whole thing out and for
them n Theory they see Sena as this is
the character we're going to utilize to
tell this very personal and emotional
story about somebody with mental illness
and so that is what this character is to
them and I I respect it I appreciate it
I'm going to enjoy the game for what it
is respect um so that said like they
there's nothing touching these
animations there's nothing touching
these
facial these character models are
looking crazy um and they're gonna lean
back into you know what what that first
game was um my only thing is and this is
where the disappointment is still there
it's just like you couldn't give me a
more if again I'm assuming but from what
I I saw the combat it still feels stiff
it still feels heavy it's visceral and
violent and and bloody and gory that
doesn't make it necessarily more indepth
to play right doesn't feel like they've
added depth to that combat it's still
going to be more of like hey you're
gonna see the guy coming in all away
with the swing or whatever but again
accepting the game for what it is I
cannot say I looked at that was like oh
this is
whack um so again no doubt it was I
wanted them to turn it into something
that they don't believe it is and that's
fine so uh I'm going to accept it for
what it is I love
that I didn't exactly and I didn't
appreciate being vivified as yeah
because let's go back in the time
machine the first person standing for
the original Sena on this podcast was me
you know why I
know CU it was on Playstation fact a
fact that's a fact but why we got to
bring up the truth though like why we
got to but we got to do all this truth
the fact the fact that CA unreasonable
love for this mean you know so what I
was in my feelings and I was ready for
you n you're right you're right now this
it's all good you you you you were the
one that introduced it first on on the
show and we was talking about how great
it was what it was and then I came later
when it I think when it probably came
when it came Xbox then I came over came
over he got me he got
me S essentially did what like that dude
that what Eminem did at the end of that
movie well I mean he know H at the stuff
I me he going to
do basically said the bars that the dude
was going to spit to him it's okay now
what you got you got that's what's
happening to me right now what cool
continue so um now the $50 thing and All
Digital thing it's just a a perception
when you think about the amount of money
that you know went into that motion
capture and all that stuff when it's
like what what's the thinking about
putting at $50 I don't you know like you
could you I don't were they afraid of
that like you know heyy the game's only
8 hours or whatever the case may be
let's bring this price down like it's I
I I just to me cuz look since the Advent
of the digital age right really going
into for us the Xbox one generation but
for like you know for me King people
that have played on Steam it's been
around for a long
time the expectation was always hey the
digital digital purchase allows you know
these developers to then you know sell
direct to you or whatever they don't
have to worry about you know paying to
put this on the storees shelf or
whatever so you would think that the
savings get passed along to the gamer
and not necessarily you know and we
haven't seen it really in that way where
it's like you know you 70 games or $70
in the digital games and you're not get
you know and that's all revenue going to
you know the dev or the or the publisher
um so I just you know I'm interested to
see what you guys think about the $50
price point because I don't yeah I I
don't honestly don't really understand
it I the the quality of the game from a
you know visually looking at it does not
it looks like a product that would
warrant a $70 price tag and it's
something that not if not for Game Pass
I would still be happy to pay the 70
bucks for so it's it's a little strange
to me surprising to now we going get no
this what's up and uh um I think yeah
you said your your your Indie bars any
other additional thing on indie no yeah
to me andd it's all a matter cuz some of
the stuff like that we saw like the when
he jumped from playing the plane right
you look at it closely it wasn't really
gameplay it was it was like a cinema it
was it was very it was very directed and
it looked kind of like a like a like a
cut scene a little bit so I just want to
see kind of like
Uncharted where does uncharted look like
a cut scene no that was definitely a set
piece
set you know I do a lot of set pieces
and TR it
too you haven't finished oh they bad ass
off they say complaining about saving
money is absurd they bad one which one I
haven't finished a
four how would you know I don't know
because you talking I I all I know I'm
just trying to figure out how I'm just
saying every set piece in that
game every set piece in that game is
playable oh every set piece yeah pretty
much you sure I mean I don't I'm not
saying here defending the Uncharted but
every set you acted like you defending
it but every set pie play every set pie
I'm just sometimes you just speak for
the sake of
speaking I'm just saying I'm just saying
if you were talking about set pieces you
going to tell me that in that instance
I'm just saying I jump I didn't get a
chance I don't have it I don't have it
so I don't know I'm just say when he
jumped from one another like gaml I I'll
let you know when I jump from one plane
to the next right I'm just saying that
didn't look like game playay well you
know I don't know I just why do you why
do you need to defend it so I'm sitting
here standing for you know what I'm I'm
stand up I'mma stand up for my unborn
children
Boy Child what but what if you come out
ugly but what if you come out ugly what
you do what you going to do you going to
love them just the same are you going to
love them just the same we we know who
abandon they
baby we know we know Uncharted as a
fatherless dad right now oh man they
don't want no more of those kids until
until they announce it later this year
until they remake it right they till
they put that baby back in the oven and
fix it up like how they want it can't we
making remaster get out of here I can't
I can't wait can't wait till we're on
stageing MAR yo there's going to be
Shooters and there going to be Shooters
in in the balcony when we
go yo Co first off I told you I was
ready I told you I was ready I would be
like yo yo King what is that red down in
your chest bro it's going to be wild in
the street it's going to be the mustard
hearts in the back
shout out I'mma wear must hard shirt I'm
a must hard
shirts
must you mean mustard Hearts like like
the management that refuses to tell
their b c going thir part we really
doing this today you mean like that all
the all the management
that a whole lot of great going on here
come on all the
management all the management that's out
there selling stock and ain't telling
people everything is going bad yeah he
leaving he leaving he has no Affinity to
them but the dude that has Affinity to
you will not tell you his card didn't
work game of the year high five Rush is
going some place oh here we do this it
wasn't it was it wasn't Game of the Year
sorry
but all so now it's less than now it's
it's the side piece here we go game in
the year though but that's that's
something that you felt in your heart so
I can see why you
upset
all I know all I
know all I know you got you got all I
know is that y'all got Executives shook
to tell y'all the truth this is where y
right now that's how the call goes your
Executives don't say nothing to you like
don't say nothing to kid they don't tell
you nothing they just slide
door I I rather I rather they don't talk
to me than they lie to me don't talk to
me that don't talk to me that L you lie
to me when you love me you lie to me
when you love me when you afraid you lie
to me when you slide that note under the
door you ain't got no respect I don't I
rather that you don't need to respect me
just give me games don't respect me
don't respect me just give me G stop
today no games and no respect CU you
know why you know why cuz he's cuz he's
better this mustard heart thing is what
just come up with something better it's
trash you get this turn from listen your
man is loose you got go get him listen
he upset he got mustard
heart wait so so got a mustard heart now
he tried to Yo the thing is he got that
jelly spine he
got he is better than this cuz just I
know listen just cuz I'm not a second
class citizen that's your fault that's
hey man don't worry about it he upet he
he fighting for the wrong team y got one
game last year that you don't like the
Finish oh my God we got
to through this top you got no Ro M with
King leave it alone you got no role mat
with no respect just saying though oh so
he capping for no Ro
that's yo let let me know when your
Secret Show pop up all right we got to
break this up so this this is the funny
thing right this is the funny let's
refocus it's it's so funny how I get
vilified because I refuse to drink
the you know the me part is two times
today they've been going in my segment
yeah yeah they going
this is wild crazy I can't let this
happen no I can't let this
happen ridiculous we going to be moving
on finally yeah cuz uh as a matter of
fact no this was you you're the one that
jumped in my second hold up can I uh
actually I thought you were
done go ahead yeah so I mean when it
comes down to you know the the overall
aspect of yes
yes mushro oh
dud I can't rock this like hellblade to
me like it's that $50 thing is just
weird it's it's not necessarily a bad
thing but I do feel like perception wise
it it doesn't sit right because it's
like even people like oh because you
charge 70 for red
ball like yeah I'm just trying to like
have a mental barrier like do you have
more faith in what you had of red ball
than you do hellblade do you not think
that hellblade's going to sell if it's
70 like that that's just my mindset
because it goes off of what like the
industry standards is and it's just what
do you see when you see like a $50 title
like you kind of think like you know
high quality indie game double A and
even that stuff like Dead Island 2
that's a 70 $60 game isn't it 607 game
like even Indie developers not indie
like doua titles do that so you know you
look from that I don't necessarily think
it it represents like the game or
anything like that but I can understand
where people are like it's interesting I
I think that is the point that is it's
okay to bring up it's like what makes
this title unique are they going to do
this do you think AOW is going to be a
$50
game interesting um we what about blade
I lost track is King The King you get
your balls I never said
a let me get you these dudes today
boy let's go k thought the show and
everything let's let's go let's go all
right well the show is a eight for me um
the fact that Arya didn't have um a
release date for consoles and um a
controller for the consoles okay I think
they really gota if if you want to do
realtime strategy games and you are
worrying about the PC market without
isolating the console Market you really
need to have an engagement device that
allows them to partake the same way that
the PC guys are partaking that was my
one um L from that uh from the show um
the next L was the OCD part for me
because when they put out square that it
wasn't Unified no more had me thinking
that another uh company was going to
come out um Oh you mean the five yeah I
don't like that that that broke me that
broke me I don't like
that it's not even it's not even that
means they doing a good job we got you
anticipating that something gonna slide
into the SL the whole time I'm itching
like I I can't do this I can't do this
um all right so Square being
there that's eye opening because this is
the stuff that I asked for I asked for
them to show what you're doing over
there in in in
Japan with the Eastern Market I wanted
to
know is is this stuff going to bear
fruit this is the second time that
Microsoft has been associated with
square the first time was Phil jumping
on their stage and now we have this and
the fact that we have Final Fantasy 14
uh showing up with more thoughts and
conversations with Final Fantasy games I
love the conversation swirling around
square and for them to show a pair
furthers that conversation and maybe
they like to see that traction maybe
they like to see their name in positive
lights or an association with uh
Ventures and new stuff and to see that
you know people over here are
anticipating their games um a vow I
really wanted to see a vow first I'm
glad I
did I saw stuff that people were saying
that the the combat look clunky I don't
know if in certain parts they were
showing like when you Perry it was
opening up for different aspects of
different things I don't know if certain
things that you that you didn't get a
chance to see yet that they implemented
in the game what they did want to show
you was they didn't want to show you the
interaction between character I got
distracted yeah now that's more addict
adct is out of pocket I'm sorry um with
the you know they did get a chance to
show you the interaction between the
characters and the world and give you a
chance to see how colorful the world is
how the characters do work so we know
obsidian does do well with this stuff
you just got to think about the outer
worlds and outer worlds uh thought
process with the dlc's and everything
like that and expect that to be bumped
up a notch that's all in in in the sense
of the Skyrim with a sword and you got
guns and stuff I I know what I'm getting
from that right right hellblade
hellblade let's go visually is probably
now the standard in the
industry if not before because a lot of
people got a chance to see the tech and
stuff so that that's why inanc can make
comments like that that this is where we
want
our that in the leaks Allan Wake those
faces are crazy and this blows blow
blows it away because I'm playing um Val
Howa and I like the eyes I like the
faces I like stuff like that and this
thing is is is least beyond anything
right
so I know what they're showing they're
answering every little bit of
questions piece by piece
they answered the question if it's a
daylight if we get a chance to have
daylight they answer a question if
there's going to be multiple people on
the screen when stuff is happening they
answered a question of uh is this real
gam play what the world look like every
time you saw this game they answered
different questions about the game
without giving you the totality of the
game now they gave you a date and they
gave you a price they had to give you a
price but the price was an answer to the
fact that there's not going to be a
physical the fact that Sovereign can
tell you that you know the Sovereign
Network can tell you
that the physical copies of video games
is being burnt or whatever I think
that's hyperbole but again okay at the
same time let's not start this again
please at at the same time um y relax
you also see large stores in droves
shrinking diminishing and erasing their
physical stock
video games across the board that's for
everybody there no longer will be shelf
for our beloved section that won't be in
the stores anymore so when you go and
Best Buy you won't have a gaming section
anymore unless it's a PC situation and
you probably have like little gift cards
and stuff on the wall to purchase from
your favorite
stores this stuff is going away so for
Microsoft and you know when Sony you saw
the uh from the leaks they were going to
break down Spider-Man into three
different segments of $50 a piece
games Microsoft is beating them to the
punch think we Microsoft or we might get
hell bladed Parts you think there a two
of the three we might we might we might
break this up I believe so but I believe
that the game is 8 hours just like the
the last one right so maybe they view8
hour games as $50 As the metric okay
right and no no I'm sorry I've been
interrupting yeah no no it's just the
fact that it's all digital we're we
don't have to ship here we don't have to
do this it's just push click go push the
service you purchase
$50 and if this I think this is a test
bed if this works is a valve digital
only
$50 is um Indiana Jones digital only
$50 is are these
things prude to what's to
come and and to get to Indiana
Jones um I love the fact that like
$50 sorry spend 70 buy buy two give one
away and whatever um
whatever if that makes you you know
happy take buy one for buy one for buy
one for $50 sir buy one for anybody
that's upset about the $50 buy it for
$50 and donate your $20 to charity I
don't think no one's upset with the $50
I think they're just like scratching
their head because this isn't this isn't
standard the way the industry generally
confused confused yeah anytime they get
a deal confusion um oh my God I'm I'm
I'm confused they gave me a moneyback
rebate he doesn't question anything no I
don't I don't I don't why should I
question somebody giving me a break so
you a consumer first that's all I care
about is my wallet what the hell I care
about them for I don't if they told me
uh hellblade is $2.50 what what guy got
my there you go just just in case you
didn't know just in case you didn't know
Starfield is three cents right now oh my
stop stop being quick question three
cents right now I want you to buy me 50
copies so I can give it a winner oh my
God question it's the three cents 50
copies hold up do you think that the $50
standpoint is going to be like the
common practice for Xbox from now on I
said there's a possibility that this is
a test
bet I said that if this thing sells in
buckets at
$50 do they
re-evaluate what they're going to do
going forward with their games because
it okay so let's say overnight it sells
10 million because of the $50 uh price
point visually is stunning soundwise we
know it's going to be stunning we just
want to get this thing in our hands so
Game Pass dudes is going to have it does
that make you click faster that you
seeing a $50 price point analyze the the
metrics no it's it's not about clicking
faster not click faster it's about just
pointing out stuff that doesn't normally
happen it's not like people are saying
oh it's saving me uh more money I'm okay
with it oh it's it's it costs less I'm
not okay with it it's just this isn't
normally what happens and they're just
wondering
what with a test this is normally what
happens with a test when you test
something that's something that's
normally not done that's called a test
okay no I I see how I actually agree
with both of y'all I think both of y'all
I'm not I'm not saying that I don't
agree with him that you're supposed to
have the qu ey um but me personally when
is a qu ey with me saving on something
that I was going to get anyway oh we
bring it is it um is it uh Steam and
epic day one or just uh Xbox store PC
when it comes to PC I would assume
Ste I would assade one noade two it says
series XS PC and Cloud so I'm going to
assume it's coming to steam what do you
guys think the sells in the first month
I don't know I it's a good question
because that that $50 price point that
that's that PC price point cuz PC Gamers
right PC gamers are really used to they
won they're not paying 70 most of the
time it's at at the very least of5 to
$10 discount over whatever it's selling
on Console what do you think cuz I'm
actually interested in what do you think
it would realistically have to sell for
them to start looking at other IPS to
make 50 I mean let me jump because I'll
say my I think for me I was going to say
this with his M but I think it's value
proposition yeah I think it potentially
could be a test bet or V the thing that
I noticed is right off the gate when he
jumped out uh your man the lord of the
studio from he did say look this is a
shorter experience right and and when
you to me you're setting expectation and
then we got to be honest like the
difference here I feel is that it's a
single player game that really the
horror the the The psychosis and all
that that doesn't have you can't put
monetization on it you can't you know
what I'm saying do all and to King's
Point if they had DLC or they had more
content maybe it is a test bed for
single player story based content you
know what I'm saying where you go okay
we'll give them the 50 we give them the
you know the 8 to 10 the 10 to 12
whatever and then let see if it does
wellc we have to say this the Insomniac
leaks we did learn this is what Sony was
thinking he said these budgets are
getting high right and maybe instead of
doing Spider-Man 370 you know whatever
we do split it in parts and do this this
is something we've seen that there
they're thinking about so to King's
Point it maybe Xbox is using this as a
test bed the only push back I got that
I'm let me be corporate C for
the only push back on Xbox that I'm a
little surprised a corporate in me that
they're not doing is I'm surprised I
this digital only okay but that's I'm
surprised you ain't doing the collectors
edition or like the constellation
Edition a $100 version or something with
the Statue or something so that and then
you say Hey you get it the five days
early the 3 days early or whatever
whatever cuz I thought they it did so
well for
Starfield that they would do it with
this but maybe to counter my own
argument because it's a single player
game it doesn't have that sof field
expansion pack but S field kind of acts
like a live service single player game
in a way that maybe they figure that
they they G gonna do this what you guys
think I don't know this
one I really don't know part of me
thinks that they don't have the faith
that they had in Starfield with
hellblade but the other part of me's
like maybe they are trying to combat a
little bit of the cannibalism that goes
on with their first party stuff in Game
Pass and they feel like if they sell it
cheaper more people would be open to
buying it like there's just so many
different yeah possibilities it could be
and I I don't know which one it is the
fact that it could be a timing thing you
know it takes time to print disc it
takes time to print pre-orders bonuses
and collectors editions and maybe
they're on a a like a really tight
schedule with all the all the stuff
coming out or does this set the trend
for the digital only releases from Xbox
first party moving forward does does a
vow have that does you know Indiana
blade it's going to be I I'm with you
like I don't know where this is go the
odds the odds of AOW and especially
Indiana Jones being $50 is like close to
zero like I highly doubt it like I
highly doubt it I know king sorry finish
finish your Bo no I'm done okay yeah so
look I'll jump in y said pretty much
everything I wanted to say um with a vow
I'm running from Sol
today guy is a damn terrorist yeah he's
out of Po he's loose today this the this
is this is this is payback for all the
time you and freaking addict interrupt
me so why you attack an addict though
why are you going after me because ad is
quiet today cuz his mouth
hurt oh so so your joint is attacked
them while they separated see that adct
that's what you get from not standing
close and I can't I can't let y'all go
on you know un Challen yeah once you
have every time there's a there's an
Xbox thing going on and I can't be on it
y go and check they go and and the thing
about this is my Avatar's teeth are
intact so oh my God anyway look AOW
you're messy you're messy AOW I am
listen I'm a huge fan of obsidian I am
not I understand some people's concerned
with the combat I think that's fair you
know what I'm saying like as far as you
know but that's generally how that
combat is I don't like people understand
like it's literally how that combat
generally is like this is the death
there why do they make it like a
Bethesda game because that is literally
what they make half to no they they do
make that I I I mean I do understand
someone that says Hey I want the
reactions to feel a little bit more
visceral St the melee combat the Mele
like the shield and stamin part now they
can make it you know feel more heavy and
stuff like that but I maybe there's a
reason they don't want to do it yeah I
mean they have it in the game we're just
going to see you know what it is cu In
fairness to to people who don't like it
you know people some people didn't like
out of Worlds combat you know what I'm
saying as far as like like my my like we
know they tell the greatest stories
greatest narrative the most memorable
characters the writing is top tier
player choice Hub world's amaz like we
know what they do so I'm not I'm with
you I'm not worried about about I'm just
saying for the people who may be on the
fence you know what I'm saying I don't
know if that moved them but I like the
biome diversity I like the I like the
color scheme I like what they're doing
I'm not giving up on the first Vision
addict of the remember when we had the
hand spell thing the only reason I'm not
give cuz he had the two I think they
were trying to showcase double wanding A
Lot in this new wow wow West you know
thing but I'm not going to give up on
the hand thing yet I want to see if they
still have that so look I'm I'm good
with them pillar Universe they're going
to be fine you know I'm surprised
probably going to be later but I'm glad
I separated from Hell Blade hellblade 2
already went in it like it it looks
absolutely phenomenal um you know as a
person who played hellblade and as
person who understands what that game is
hellblade is lowkey a horror game on
some level like H hell hellblade's whole
purpose is to make you uncomfortable so
to me I don't want 30 hours that I don't
want to be like there was one board in
hellblade where you were like almost in
complete darkness and you got to listen
to someone's voice to get out of a stage
and like bro it like hellblade messes
with you on so many levels right so to
me I'm good with that and then when
people talk about okay it's just the
walking or whatever what people
understand the game G is really a
Showcase of sound the game is really
about her subconscious The psychosis
that's going on the three voices going
on telling her what she should she
shouldn't do and to me it's funny like
don't do it you're scared don't do it
you know like it's just all this this
stuff going and then she now we going to
have characters and with King to me
Ninja Theory has showed enough of these
different cuts that it's going to be so
much for me that I'm satisfied I'm cool
with it 10 12 hours now I will agree
with addict I was surprised by a $50
digital I was like that's interesting
you know what I'm saying why are you
doing that okay cool is it a VI
proposition is it a test like King said
I don't know all I know I'm there I'm in
I liked what I saw I'm good um Square I
already went in it I thought that was a
flex I thought that that's Xbox
showcasing hey our relationship is
tighter than ever be on the lookout for
whatever might come next and we not
missing day and they won square games
ever again and they brought them on
their um first Pace you know know their
first party showcase I think that's that
was significant you know what I'm saying
I went on that ARA that's the strategy
gang I'm not too worried about the whole
console thing I know it's PC game pass
um I thought they showed well what the
game is I thought that um to me I'm not
worried because every they've been
consistent now with like Age of Empire
every strategy in has comeing on has
eventually come out and we got to be
honest as far as who buying what yeah so
you know let's be real even though the
XBox guys like yo we should got it first
on day and that's fair not buying but
y'all not playing that when hellblade
come out yall not playing that when
India like we got to be real with the
buying habits of the console gamer right
they don't rock with those the way the
PC guys rock with it so maybe the
internal decision is put it on PC first
we get it out there faster and then we
give them that so we could have the game
pass you know Equity that's fine um last
thing is um what you call it uh Indie I
I I've said it before like completely
blown away completely blown away like
didn't expect I came in ready to hate
that they didn't go to decision and I'm
just like I looked at I'm like damn
machine games is cooking I was actually
impressed with the puzzles first person
puzzles looked cool like him putting the
Cog took it back to miss yeah him
putting the Cog on the thing him having
the thing like I like that you know the
traps the whatever and then they what
they did for me while I'm okay is even
though y'all know I'm a hasht just one
guy forever box da it's so
cinematically rich with the cuts to
showing him and talking and going like
it's such a movie like presentation that
that satiates me and I ain't going front
that whip look like it was it was doing
some things beating people up roughing
people hitting one wall making them look
this way they doing the summer
blockbuster joint and and and I I ain't
going to front like it was levels to it
machine game show me oh you 60 frames my
guy like you're smooth like I every like
I like first of all shout out to Xbox
their presentation the way they did
they're doing this whole thing I think
they finally nailed the for and I'm I'm
going even say it I'm going to get kill
I think their format is better than
everybody's that now I think the
developed direct format is the best
format like you got us looking like wait
a minute they sliding another oh oh you
know what saying like we went crazy like
it was just like it's subtle where it's
not enough it's no Talking Heads it's
developers they get in they do the
perfect cuts to just to the game they've
got it they they they've got the right
po salute to the team and salute whoever
did that order y'all was cooking cuz
y'all know a had to go first you know
how blade come through the graphical
forel day then they got to the 30 Fray
and then you knew Indiana Jones was fire
you knew they look the best out of all
them and you put them last and I thought
it was it was great and let's be real
none of us thought Indiana Jones would
be showing like this or coming out this
year so I can't get at them crazy now as
far as um the release dat thing this the
last thing I feel addict on that totally
fair I just think the vibe I get from
them to understand why they're doing it
is the last thing you want is to jump
out the window say something and then
you got to keep falling back on the
expectation that you set and you failed
it because they needed more time also to
Kings Point who said on the stream this
is a different Xbox where they have so
many games we know stalk is coming at
the end of the year we know this one's
coming we know ABK is coming so now you
do got to play who's actually ready yeah
and then plug in strategic so that dudes
don't cannibalize each other cuz we're
getting to that abundance of games part
so that's what and then we forgot yo and
what you call there was a quake six
tease yeah hidden in the there was a lot
of teases up there of stuff that
everybody was working on if anybody
really took the time out to look at the
stream no no I got you shout out the fun
that's boring to me K try but I'm not
your high expectation if you didn't like
I I get it and Hell blade might not be
for you but for people who love the
first one I am totally cool with what
they're trying to do they're not the
skill tree game they're not the 30 hour
open world game they've never been that
so I can't sit there and it's like s
said I can't sit there try to impose
what I want versus what the develop yeah
we we bugging all right so we Let's uh
combine yeah is Vibe he must don't have
work he don't have work
today h know I had to get my I had to go
get my dad a haircut that's you see
that's what it is he got time he got
time today he got time today look let's
let's move let's combine the last one
and then get out here with the let's go
I sent something to yeah oh you said
something to me all right so um hold on
one second
uh oh oh oh oh you got you got new
information new information okay you
thought I was just sitting out here
talking out me
bum well I had some bars for you I mean
I had some stuff for you to try to
support your argument so I'll start with
yours um Final Fantasy 16 reportedly
coming this is King's topic to series X
and S oh shout out to special Nick who's
actually in our chat who's where this
rumor originated
from Ni shout out Nick thank you shw
Nick shout out the Xbox era and the
homies you know what I'm saying yeah so
it's reply coming you're messy you know
so um yeah they they talked about that
about when it was um coming in they they
quoted the uh the infinite podcast and
in reference to it and uh let me just
get some bars from that said it's uh in
the works he didn't have details on when
it um come and this is this is kind of
raising the net so uh King you wanted to
talk about this man yes so uh K and
affiliate shapeless
Nick he shapeless Nick now shapeless
Nick special Nick no he sh he shapeless
but he was special with
it uh yo not shapeless nigga's his
cousin oh
M
continue shout out shout out shout out
to Nick um all right so I was hearing
rumbl rumbling before and all the
conversation that was going around with
square I didn't say anything because I
got a DM right before when if you watch
the
stream I'm not paying attention to
anything of the artwork being
shown I saw
square and I start going buck bananas
because I'm believing that it's what was
in my DM oh okay okay all right so I'm
Stop Believing these DMS you know you
know why I'm never GNA Stop Believing
the DMS because obviously somebody else
got a DM too and his conversation was
the
same so I'm not g to stop believing that
because 90% of the time they're accurate
sometimes they're off with the date or
they off with the time like I did know
about ragnaroks DLC I didn't know that
was DLC for the DLC that people got so
all this I'm not going to dismiss what's
being said to me I'm just not that I'm
not Tom I'm not none of these dudes to
sit there go shifting through your
sources I don't care but I do like to
know certain things so but when I saw it
I was losing my mind because I'm saying
they're gonna they're gonna do it
they're G they're gonna kill Kong right
now now Kong is gonna die right now
because if they would have show Final
Fantasy you messy coming to I don't care
what Final Fantasy it was I don't care
if it was seven I don't care remake I
don't care if it was 16 oh yeah we got
to do the we do the I don't care what it
was the fact that square was there in 16
is being talked about showing up because
14 is coming next
month how deep and this is the question
to you guys how deep do you think
Microsoft and square is really rocking
with each other because now we're
starting to see them release games that
were only on the play St platform and
one game is going to be releasing day
and date that means the relationship has
definitely had a
turn yeah no look I I mean I I hear you
on that it's it's it's very very
interesting to see that they they had
showed up uh adct your thoughts on on
square with the Final Fantasy 16 RS it's
just a matter of time before these games
come out I do uh think that PlayStation
is doing everything in their power to
prevent the sevens the remake and
rebirth and stuff from coming to the
platform but you know we didn't really
see them gloat too much on 16 I don't
know how well it sold so I'm kind of
curious if it like did did well enough
to get people's attention but didn't do
good enough to like appe stockh holders
and stuff so you know maybe that is more
willing to let this come over okay you
know PlayStation isn't going to go to
bat for this game they're like okay you
know the year exclusivity up uh do you
want to go back to the to the drawing
table and extend this and PlayStation's
like no let him have it so I don't know
how it is because U you I don't know how
much they paid for something like that I
don't know if they if PlayStation
themselves got their money's worth out
of it uh we have to see it's interesting
because even though I wasn't a big fan
of 16 a lot of people like 16 on
Playstation uh so I'm kind of curious
how well it does on Xbox when it does
come over because I do think it is
coming you know I don't know when yeah
but I do think it is coming and I for
some reason I have a feeling when when
that when that time exclusivity thing is
up on rebirth because re they're very
extra now this
yeah the time exclusives ending this day
I think at that point because of this
new relationship with with Xbox and all
the stuff going on I think we you'll see
a rebirth and a remake on Xbox that'll
be interesting so think I think there
was a point in time where Xbox uh Square
Enix wasn't really pushing to get stuff
on Xbox and at the time Xbox had a bad
relationship with them but I think the
new CEO remedied that Sarah remedied
that P Spencer remedied that so I do
think now it's not a matter of if it's a
matter of when I agree so have the
thoughts on Final Fantasy 16 the Xbox
rumors special Nick in the building yeah
I think it's I think it's it's true it's
coming and to point I just stink all
that other stuff it's it's happening
like we we're at the point like you know
to be perfectly honest like the ideal
situation for everyone really really is
just you know that the walls go go down
everybody put their games everywhere all
right yeah everywhere just every put
their games everywhere that's just I I
don't really care I play anywhere and
everywhere I don't really care about any
of that anymore um so it just makes
sense and like we talked about before
like the you know the management over
where Enix has changed yeah and you know
the idea AA of these exclusives just for
the sake of you know exclusivity this
idea that okay it's not worth it to do
the work to put it on XBox doesn't make
a whole lot of sense considering where
Xbox is looking to be right you know
Xbox isn't just a console you're talking
about PC you're talking about Cloud
which is you know more and more all of
those different Avenues are viable so
the idea that you don't spend the money
which to be perfectly Frank to Port
these games over from one cons to the
other these consoles aren't that
different from one another to be I think
the amount of money that would spent
importing it uh more than justifies what
they would get I was told it something
on the scale Final Fantasy 7 would take
probably about eight months okay so
there you go just support it right so to
me it's something that's totally worth
it and I think the new management there
sees that so yeah I I still I'm I'm so
interested I would love to see what
those terms were with Sony on ff7 right
I would love to see how much they tried
to lock it down um and it's strange that
that they didn't try to do the same with
16 if this is true and this this game is
coming sooner sooner rather than than
later um so yeah it's interesting but
again maybe it was them also saying te
leaves like you know what at some point
you know The Changing of the Guard over
there Square Enix it's like at some
point we're not going to have that we're
not going to be able to make that same
argument that hey it it pays just to put
it here take the X amount of money and
we'll put it here right you know
especially when you talk about Square
Enix and and their Endeavors like in on
the Western Front right what happened on
the Western Front whether it was tomb ra
whe whether it was um Whatchamacallit
whether it was uh Avengers or whatever
um all
crystal none of it ever made enough
money right none of ever enough money
and this is stuff that was on multiple
platforms so to have your biggest
selling game that you know will make
money wherever they are only be limited
to one platform and then maybe a second
platform later on with with a PC release
something like that just doesn't make a
whole lot of sense in in this future
that we're looking at so yeah yeah that
makes perfect sense shout special n he
said honestly not sure on Final Fantasy
7 he said I don't think Sony wants to
let it go it'll be interested you know
the timing of
it and unless there's some kind of
clause in the contract it's up to both
parties to extend that contract uh so
I'm curious if Square Enix at that point
is like look cuz clearly they're moving
a different direction in terms of how
they present exclusives and
multiplatform so I'm curious as long as
PlayStation did put some like no uh uh
no competition clause or anything like
that in there where they have the the
final say curi refal yeah I'm curious if
SC Enix just said thank you for the work
you done with these but thank you for
your
patronage we we we we're going to take
these games and for the street for the
street to me to me like they're going
over here though to me PlayStation take
it out talent to South Beach to
me I do think I do think sore Enix has
gotten to the point where you know you
got uh what's her name that went over
there it's like look you you're never
going to expand what PlayStation you're
never going to PlayStation yeah yeah and
I do think that they they are listening
cuz you see you saw a Mana game being
marketed by Xbox that is huge to me if
there is a conversation that could be
have score Enix they'll unless
PlayStation like yo we drop you like a
bag after a bag then you know obviously
business comes first but if PlayStation
doesn't go that far I don't think that
they're going to uh extend that
yeah we got to see I'll jump in um look
you know the the stars are lighting as
far as I'm concerned we've already seen
all the side once that man came out on
stage on the Square what is it one of
them Square conventions and they hugged
up side by side to me the writing was on
the wall and then the symbolism of not
Phil saying it them saying it we want
our games on Xbox we're believing to
push off the writing was on the wall the
relationship has
it was quick to say he said that not me
yeah not me yeah cuz you know cuz wa you
know what it feel yeah it feel feel
slick with that so I once I saw that I
say yeah it's only a matter of time now
it's just the contractual stuff you know
and I'm with you addict I don't know you
know how fast they can move maybe it's a
situation where they could just announce
it and then it's being worked on and
then you get it from year but I do feel
it's coming you know on some level now
it would be interesting to to special
Nick point where Final Fantasy 16 is um
first in the last I would be surprised
oh I didn't think final F 16 was was
accelerated on the list as far as you
know the order you know kind of thing so
we'll see about that but um yeah no this
is you know I I don't think this is a
Cann situation I think King is on I
think it's going to happen because my
affiliate is in the audience yeah your
affiliate is right there especially my
my my affiliate is in the
audience and I all I do is protect uh
individuals you know shapeless Nick
that's not special Nick
that's that's his alien for over here
with us that's how he signs in but um we
not going to throw him under the bus but
you know he's out there he can tell
y'all exactly what it is so K&N is out
here bringing you the news sometimes you
don't want to hear but you're going to
hear no doubt thank y'all for the for
the football yeah I know you did not use
my Dr for you you messy you messy I
ain't feeling
that I I could just see I can see
kinging like the leonitis 300 de like
this is Kanan talk about Kanan in the
news not what you want what you n we
can't be doing
that I like he kicking the actual
reporters into the into
the I ain't feeling that at all like an
army of reporters that it's not even a
big well it's like it's like just enough
where they can't get out and he just
comes in's like who going to right K
dying die oh man this this editorial
team is crazy what he does is he puts a
laptop in like a little
like a little what's the thing like the
little well the well buckets it was like
who going ride it no I don't like this
so we gonna move on for the last this
the last J this is real quick oh power
world we do it out I got something I got
something to do oh you got something to
do yes yes you got something to do yes
let's do that before we we lose uh yeah
yeah before we lose yes yes okay mute
your mics mute your
mics all right
this episode of The Iron Lords podcast
is brought to you by hellofresh so let's
start with the question what is
hellofresh with hellofresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal kit
whether your resolution is to save money
eat better or stress less hellofresh is
here to help you do all three
say hello to your most delicious year
yet with fresh ingredients and
chef-crafted recipes at a price you'll
like delivered right to your door each
hellofresh box is packed with farm fresh
ingredients and everything arrives
pre-portioned right to your doorstep for
less hassle and less wasted food don't
let recipe boredom strike because
hellofresh has more options than ever
dig into their biggest menu yet with
over 45 dinner options to choose from
weekly and even more Market add-on it
items that suit any lifestyle make
Saving Time your breeziest resolution
with quick convenient recipes delivered
right to you right to you just choose
your meals
apologies don't let recipe boredom
strike because helloof fres has more
options than ever before dig into their
biggest menu yet with over 45 dinner
options to choose from weekly and even
more Market add-on items that suit any
lifestyle make Saving Time your
breeziest resolution with quick
convenient recipes delivered right to
you just choose your meals and select
your delivery date hellofresh handles
the meal planning and shopping so all
you have to do is open your weekly box
of pre-portioned ingredients and
stepbystep recipes to get cooking so
you'll so you've resolved to actually
sit down and eat dinner around the table
but what do you do about those nights
when your schedule is packed turn to
helloof Fresh's lineup of quick and easy
meals including their 15minute recipes
designed to help minimize Meal Time
stress this time of year everyone's
looking to revamp their eating habits
look to hellofresh as wholesome Health
forward options like over 30 calorie
smart and protein smart recipes each
week they also said that breakfast is
the most important meal of the day and
hellofresh agrees in fact they're giving
all subscribers free breakfast for life
and that means you'll enjoy a totally
free breakfast item with every single
hellofresh delivery now that's worth
waking up for now for me in the past
I've said there's no cooking on the
weekends in this house but the truth of
the matter is that eating out is very
expensive in this day and age eating out
is ridiculously expensive so what lady
Sav and I have decided to do is to take
uh a little bit of what we do during the
week which is cook a little bit more and
add that to our weekend regimen so now
hellofresh comes in and Saves the Day
once again she and I cook a number of
different things on the weekend while
saving money and and and the truth of
the matter matter is it's it's a kind of
a bonding experience so for us some of
the most uh delicious ones that we've
had so far is the Mushu pork Bowl which
is one of my favorites then this a
chicken sausage Boling which H is out of
this world and me I like me a shepherd's
pie and their Pub style shepherd's pie
is absolutely amazing and again it's
something that she and I get to do
together um so it's very cool because
you get used to sort of the same recipes
all the all the time and for us you know
we're too we're two Puerto Ricans we
cook sort of Latin fused uh meals all
the time we don't necessarily step out
of that comfort zone this allows us to
do something very very different and
again for what we were paying going
outside to eat this is a big big deal
so if you want go to hellofresh.com
ironlord free and use code iron Lords
free for free breakfast for life that
you heard correctly free breakfast
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box while the while your
subscription is active that's free
breakfast for life at hellofresh.com
iron Lords free with code iron Lords
free get all of this with hellofresh
America's number one meal kit no doubt
getting that hello fresh on you know I'm
saying little bonies I see you like that
shepherd pie a little too strong though
yeah I like shepherd's pie wait what was
the pie that we had oh no it wasn't
shepher
whoa yeah that's crying crazy you just
saw that movie I mean I mean that
play
oh meie no um what was the name of that
um that bowl that we had when we went to
your birthday at um that um medil times
remember they came out with that vegan
meal they had the
best oh yeah cuz KATU was like what's
that you eating continue to eat chicken
well the chicken was good too like
chicken like that that food was good
like it was really good it was really
good we just had to eat with our hands
yeah more
L felt very very uh Med yes
more finish this joint up so yeah this
is me this is kind of the bonus topic we
had to talk about it is absolutely
breaking the internet right now pal
World y'all pal world I cannot keep up
with the success because every time I
have a stat I got to keep refreshing the
power world account to see what is going
on so as of today latest tweets from
power world and um from pocket that's
Studio pocket pair games P power world
has sold over 4 million copies in only 3
days momentum has increased since
yesterday with the latest sales at
86,000 units per hour thank you everyone
for playing Power please leave a review
if you're enjoying the game came about
two days ago two days ago now mind you
this update was 8 hours ago prior to
that like every 16 hours they would have
an update like yo two million 3 million
4 million yeah like it's crazy then they
also power has the highest concurrent
player count of any paid game in the
history of Steve they are now number one
overtook cyber Punk we can't believe it
thank you so much to everyone you know
um he says uh we cannot really think the
team is working that hard and make power
even better as we speak the game is so
popular they had they've been updating
the server outages players as a number
of concurrent players across all
platforms exceeded 1.3 million the Epic
online service is currently exeeding out
outages due to the unusually high load
work worldwide so it's been on they've
been on and popping the team was working
around the clock to try try to
substantiate the need it's crazy
obviously what king would one love is
this game is also on Game Pass in game
preview um you know the dev the devs
have said for now that you know it is um
XBox and steam and no PlayStation for
right now who knows what happens in the
future but they going by the old tweet
um it's it's crazy I I wanted to talk
about I'll jump it off I wanted to talk
about it because look yeah what I'll do
is uh I'll switch my uh a media card so
they can see the game playay oh yeah
what you do and I'll um what you call
I'll switch over as soon as you uh do
the game playay or you can just share
your screen and take over on that but
look um I got to be honest like this is
when
s the hardcore and I'm I'm guilty of it
sometimes we don't know how this
industry gonna go yeah no we don't we
don't right and we sit not for us
anymore like we sit there and tell them
y'all need to make this why did y sign
this game now in my defense I remember
seeing it at the Xbox oh yeah thank you
ad you got the job my P I remember
seeing it at the Xbox um what you call
the Showcase M and I'm like okay one
thing about meog don't usually like the
QT stuff but if you got
violence and you you got pillaging or
some crazy mechanic that makes it mature
then you have my interest and I was like
yo this this like this Pokemon is
violent out here like they they really
doing stuff and then obviously shout out
to my man I got Travis when he was
talking me about it and they were
talking about the the enslaving mechanic
and making it work for you and then you
can catch humans and you catch people
slipping them too yeah then it starts
getting hilarious right so it it's like
now it's mature Pokemon but then what I
learned more about I only play for like
a two hour it's really yeah it's got
Pokemon aspects no question but it's
really like Arc in a way survival it's a
survival game coupled with a little
grounding mechanics I haven't played the
co-op yet so I got got a ton of
questions for ad but what I'm just
trying to say is that this goes to show
you never know what's going to be the
next best thing and the only thing I
also got to give the Xbox Community a
little little smoke right now these are
the same guys there's this talk King
about I don't remember after remember
after this direct dudes are like all
right we got the the the the reveal for
for for the year it's stacked and
everything but what are we going to play
from now until May there's nothing and
I'm just like we acting like gay pass
don't exist we acting like all backlogs
are not crazy and lo and behold guess
what Xbox got guess guess what Xbox got
right now game that's who we play right
that that so it's so funny how entitled
we are as Gamers with it's stuff you
know what I'm saying that we don't care
about but it goes to show there stuff
for everybody and the other thing I
didn't get to say at the developer
director that I really did like yeah
everybody that's on
Xbox I didn't say that you're not on
Xbox you got papey biscuits I didn't say
that I was going to say that Xbox the
beauty of their Ro lineup is they got a
game for everybody this is the Nintendo
guy right that he you this guy is like I
play Pokemon all think about something
like this he might be interested already
all that the strategy people for the PC
might be the hashtag just one for the
hellblade they might be interested the
guys who want the the the traditional
Western RPG fantasy they might be
interested and then you want the
Blockbuster of the summer you got the
Indiana Jones you
got on Xbox King it's on Xbox it's on
Xbox so it goes to show you Game Pass
diversity is crazy so I'm I'm really
happy for this team I'm really happy
like here's the thing I really want to
give credit to Xbox shout out to Global
publishing shout out to ID Xbox because
s you going to appreciate this we
remember when PS4 when Xbox One first
came out one thing we had to give
PlayStation 4 their flowers was that
they remember they were like where the
Indie station we support the Indies we
got that's when they was broke and they
needed help res no they have faded from
that since they do have like we got our
money up to get get out the door
you the Triple A's went up they kind of
slowed on that they still have any but
not to the level that they were in the
beginning and then I remember people
challenging Xbox yo why the developer
any developers is so difficult to get on
your
why does stuff cost so much Xbox
policies are bad then to see the
transformation in the in the series X
console and S console generation they
have been on fire with their choices
they've been in fire with their finger
on the post of what in these [__] pop or
what's going to go on they been giving
the right Global publishing deals this
you got to give whoever was on it saw
power world and was like yo let's lock
them down now the question I got for
y'all which is leading to the PO
I mean this thing is bro this jug this
is you start off with this kind of
energy this kind of R seems reminiscent
if it keeps trending this way like how
Minecraft was going how like Pokemon was
going at the very beginning being that
you have this relationship already with
the game pass it's in game preview not
the full thing but it's in game preview
on game like what do you do with uh this
pocket games what do you what you do do
do we Minecraft them do we what what do
you do I'm listen I don't think it's
that far this is a phenomenon right now
I don't know bro I have two words for
you genin impact
oo they missed out and and Phil knows
they missed out Sarah knows they missed
out I don't know bro 4 million in two
days two days that's somebody's that's
like some people don't even get that in
there for like five years like they they
dropping they going diamond on in hours
like this is crazy what this game is be
the show numbers I guess I'm I'll have
to see how they handle like supporting
the game in the long term before fair
fair but but but do you think Xbox
should jump so's house is a
man no doubt and the fun question I got
for y'all is we no Nintendo's watching
oh is is Nintendo steaming right now are
they saying how dare they should we take
them to court they they cuz adct showed
me adct got the thing he showed me some
of the close
resemblances to some of the some of the
most popular Pokemons I I think I think
it's an uphill battle for them first of
all this isn't a game that dropped like
Shadow drop they didn't know about
they've known about Pokemon with guns
for a long
time like if they if they didn't shut
this shut the door on this back then
it's cuz they
can't but you know how dudes get
when you start making
billions you know how the they don't
care about you until until they like oh
wait a minute you like you you you as
big as the Joe Rogan experence like oh
you got money now like
like what you think Nintendo's never
been the kind of person to go after they
make the money they've always are very
hypert trigger when it comes to like
suing and and to me if if Nintendo was
able to Nintendo already done would have
done it they would
this before it even came out people
people don't remember there was a game
called Tim Tim that jacked more Pokemon
than this yeah you're right you're right
you're right you're right yeah there's
enough there's enough enough
differentiators probably they didn't
they say something about they put they
put the like the they they created like
the the Pokemons the pals they create
them through some AI thing where they
just it's analo the AI art in this game
kid is the AI art so it's this the
number one game using AI art King you
know what's
fun CU like as is like deep resembles
hold on let me show there's a Pokemon
yeah it it this Pokemon right here let
me wake one that's oh my the one that
sleep this Pokemon right here yeah
wow that's crazy he's playing right now
he playing right that Pokemon right
there there's literally one almost
identical to that Pokemon
in Pokemon but he he's on four legs and
not
two and the game play is so different to
Pokemon 2 it's not an RPG right it's a
survival game right so this bird looks
like Pidgeot
PID I don't know bro it was a hot line I
thought it was a hot later I I don't
know but I have a feeling H already made
no h hement i got H did yeah hog was
like um hold on I tweet the I got the
hog joint for you cuz I I was curious
where hog was at with it so hog give me
one second hold on leten is that the hog
tweet give me a second I almost got it
cuz I what is I've been retweeting so
many pile World success tweets that it's
F it's hard to catch up to Mata give me
give me nope nope no not there basically
the gist of it was that I know I'm sorry
the gist of it was like look there's
likenesses but the reality of them
actually being able to do something you
say you can sue for anything but the
reality of doing anything with this is
is pretty much fan so yeah you know
what's crazy about this game I I I'm not
strong enough but there's like these
guards I can literally just plunder this
whole village like steal everything
there like but that dude that dude with
the gun there yeah he he kill everyone I
have oh I found it anybody could sue for
any reason hold G so I can't tell you
what Nintendo do will or won't do with
power I can tell you how that they'd
have a tough time winning on any
infringement claim that isn't arguing a
direct design C Cy he said the game
itself is a Minecraft Zelda monster
monster hunter mashup unlike anything
Pokemon has put forth so there's no
winning there the pal designs have
elements that are similar to Pokemon but
even though they F they fly a bit I love
this line they fly a bit close to the
Sun for
my that's a really hard case to win
Nintendo would be better serve seeing
what elements of the game might fit with
its old brand he said yo Nintendo need
to get this
stuff hog is cooking so yeah that's what
hog said on that one but continue y the
the interesting thing is like they got
like these World bosses like literally
it these things are designed for
multiple people to fight uh I have I
haven't really beat any of them but the
cool like you can catch them Chicken
King you can catch them too you you can
catch them too and what's funny is um
there's a Pokemon called lario on on um
oh yeah on Pokemon and then there's
another one called Anubis on here and
and they I'm not even joking they
they're almost identical yeah I saw that
I saw that one it's just like the color
the color palette it's just a
coincidence it's just a coincidence I'll
go I'll go to Anubis real quick friendly
coincidence it's a fairly good look we
can't look look at the glider the GL oh
oh yeah yeah that's kind of that's kind
of well okay so this company is the same
company that they they put out some
other game that was kind of like breath
of the Wild
so this is their thing just biting off
Nintendo what they do yo Astro par Ste
said can you catch mustard
Hots bust them in the chest and put them
in a box and sell them I I would say I
hate a better
tur those shirts is selling you better
mind
your goaded there's
AOS is just like that one bir when I as
a person who has the most hours in this
game like one thing that surpris me cuz
you I'm level 21 yeah you gave me like
you were I was like get to the topic so
we can finish this is it I was just like
y you you blazing like you feel that
they got he's actually just playing he
out of I'm about to stop him right now
CU he GNA take over this GNA be a stream
with adct in a minute that's all he
doing so yeah I just say like you do cuz
I spoke to you you was like yo I was
like is it real cuz I know ad going to
give me the real after been blazing like
do they got something you were like [__]
yo they have something I'm just curious
how they handle it they ain't got
nothing for me oh okay gohe I put the
game on I was like all your
power put it on I said the frame rate
I you can't you can't wrck with that
frame rate I said my ey my
cataract they working on optimization
yeah they better work onization because
I work
distalization okay like uninstall a this
right here is BAS damn I don't care what
it do for you but it ain't doing nothing
for
me I think this this game is more like
Arc than Pokemon art is subjective yeah
I think it just arc Arc
whatever they
just the thing that they did is they
took the
took they took the capture system from
Pokemon and and like instead of like you
taming them in Arc you you beat them in
submission and make and what's funny is
like what's the what's the things called
again the pals they're called Spears oh
instead of Pokeballs that called pal
Spears and what's funny is like if you
look at the design of them they look
like almost identical to the Tim Tim
pokeballs like like it's just like look
that's why like I see a lot of like
Nintendo people getting really upset
with this mad mad this is like a dude
coming out with watch the line instead
of
hold yeah watch the line yo I mean what
what what what if it's the the the what
if Pokemon is is the pubg and they the
fortnite this is this is what's going on
right now I mean I'm literally looking
at a carbon copy of of of somebody this
is how we used to talk about fortnite
fortnite had this type of this crazy
inertia the energy that's the same type
of energy and it became what it is now
oh no I'm not saying that it's not oh
okay I thought
it no no for me yeah you just say like
theame fix the frame it defense of them
K they a't gain preview though they they
got fully gay pass relas and what am I
not I'm not a beta boy yeah you're not
unless it's the game unless it's the
game I encourage everyone to look up
lario on Pokemon and tell me this is
literally a color palette swap of that
dude I would never mess with him cuz
he's level 40 40 something but this is
literally a copy Fair off your boss we
got to go we we Wilder yeah we we oh on
this like no we Wilder just on General
today but yeah yeah no what you know how
long we going we Wilding this ridiculous
stop it yeah man this is yeah they they
need to get these dudes um looking the
bag look look at at now look Len
at this point yesterday's price is not
to price you need to jump you got to
jump on it you got you got to edit that
deal now here's the question do you do
you lock them in and keep them locked or
do you mine craftting where you like yo
we can make a like
a
king you open to live service money King
I think I think
play you just hit up them up be like yo
we're not because I I don't think they
should buy them okay but I do think they
should hit them and be like what's it
going to take for this to be only on our
platform in in Game Pass for as long as
you guys are around we just we just
talked about why this is not the
greatest decision to make like I don't
know man like I I I I guess to me like
they they they they don't even really
necessarily have to like lock it down to
a console exclusive it's like just make
sure this never leaves Game Pass
like all right all right all right no
it's a then you hustling backwards right
all right so what you want give them as
much money as they need to get it okay
and then you can choose you can make
that choice whatever M put it on PC put
it wherever Game Pass is Right
ironically none of their games because
they've made a few have been on
Playstation that's what I on Twitter I
don't know if it's true keep it like
that like that like
that if it's true but uh someone posted
all their Gams on Twitter none of them
have came out on play really good I like
I like I like our odds now um oh my God
they know they know where they bread is
but oh my God it's F
KS buy them buy and and and put them in
Game Pass whatever game pass if it's if
it's on PC whatever put it in the PC on
to those deals don't put it on
Playstation but you know what would be
crazy you don't see Pokemon all over the
place that's what I'm talking about lock
it to you okay we're looking at this the
wrong way want to Nintendo buy them and
have them replace them with that's get
them get them get
get them first Nintendo would buy them
and and and burn them to the ground no I
actually I actually think this kind of
concept is really good and if Nintendo
were smart they would buy this company
and they would replace them all real
Pokemon but this is a this is the thing
though right this is I think put their
polish on it the nintend the the Pokemon
fans that are actually playing it and
not hating on it are like this is the
kind of stuff we wanted from Game Freak
forever like I think that's why it's
it's gravitating to
again I'm not in the Pokemon Community
but ad you told me like a lot of people
are very frustrated that's in that like
yo they're not making advancements or
the the way it runs trying yeah so now
like some studio came in and kind of
fortnite the situation and giving people
what they want and now you got this
potential phenomenon let let me jump
real quick let you finish so whoever I
interrupt um yeah look I just feel that
it's a tough one CU I understand what
king is saying but there is a part of me
that with live service you leave so much
money on the table yeah you know what
I'm saying and it's just like I know you
know Xbox Community is like n we good
let them you know what I'm saying but if
this ends up being what what J goon
calls it one of those Legacy style
titles like a Minecraft like a Call of
Duty you could be bankroll fresh on this
you know what I'm saying like so I get
it either way I I do think like s said
yesterday's price is down today's price
but definitely you've got the
relationship and if what addict saying
is true that they've already highness
this this relationship where they only
messing with Xbox or they're small so
they just yeah you forced that y'all
going to like the poll let's get the
super CH she she made her own loyalty
without you even I ain't GNA take
no right shout out to ID at Xbox or
Global whoever saw this that get that
corporate Cox get that man of Shield get
that man a ra because y'all might have
last year Phil said they they sad about
what happened about genin impact you may
have something that may have shaking the
Earth right now you better do something
figure it out yeah make that make that
make that next week when you know when
y'all come in on Monday make that the
announcement we purchased power what's
up let's let's see let's see what
happens let's give them a budget so we
can get them frames right yeah get yeah
and get out of game preview and move the
servers for what is it 4 to
32 let's get it yeah I will say that is
one of the the frustrating Parts like we
don't have a lot of information right
but like if you're playing on Xbox if
you're playing this on Xbox like you're
literally doing yourself a disservice
like it it's it's been butchered
compared to its like actual release yeah
and it's just like to me it's get Jason
that's frustrating because Microsoft
spent money on a Game Pass bag so it's
like we're not even getting the same
product but you're right I don't want to
minimize what you're saying the only
thing that they're going to come back at
us which is a little valid is this is
technically in game preview on it's in
game preview on Steam too oh I didn't
know that I didn't know apparently yeah
apparently the Xbox version is a couple
of of of updates behind behind that's
what I heard but their team is probably
small it's probably a small team but but
yeah hit up call Jason and the team and
his team Jason ronal the great wizard
get them in there and do what you got
this is too big to be playing around you
got to do something so that's why I got
you want to get super chats and then um
I'll do the poll or you want me to do
the poll whatever how you want Super
Chat I got on it right now all right
cool all we got scrubber own for Life
two scrubber own for Life $2 Super Chat
P begging bums get a PPP loan and pay
off that PS5 I can't believe they
calling it a PPP loan that's ill that's
kind of lill beging oh that's crazy oh
that was a I go for that was very messy
you gang gang but that that was a ill
flip right there you did P Lo that was
Ill sry I'll give you that with Y
fightday we got they don't buy all
out and we got doc doc 505 Super Chat we
got Troy Baker to p ps ain't getting
nothing yo Troy did a good job though he
really does inde he does he does J Boy
On The Run $2 Super Chat your F you're
fam addict so we disagree you you said
with uh you said with fam so LOL so fam
is fam can agree to disagree it's all
good black Ronin 357 $5 Super Chat we
can criticize things and not be
Hypocrites like some people who sit on a
high horse and don't like fanmade
scissor reals
wow I'm about said what he said got to
tell me what happened later ler I'm
about to peace lovehe exactly that isn't
not that is not what he
said Jesse Derby 20 that shout out uh
shout out to I still feel like that was
out of pocket he shouldn't have said
that shout out to our five star general
King David blessings Big
Chief put put the CR in the chat for
Ohio boy welcome to the realm Lord Ohio
in the building buck eyes then we got
the homie F gaming member for 32 months
Lord bronze always great discussion Lord
but why is cartoon addict looking into
my
soul Park Attic in the building yes yes
then we got senjutsu Sage
$5 in my opinion visions of mon is
coming to Game Pass but it won't be
revealed till closer to release to not
uh pre-release sales too much that is
true also it could last minute then we
got J boy on the run again $2 Super Chat
s we paying game pass the growth is
happening so $50 okay listen I mad about
paying less don't get me wrong I'm not
mad L there we got Sage once again
with that sa is practicing for LSM live
yes I am you know uh you know it's love
but I got to make some jokes of course
brother it's always love always love we
got Sage once again $5 Super Chat check
s's bank account for a recently
deposited check from Colin he's
be he's becoming Clarence Thomas before
eyes Colin is Haren Crow oh my God y Dr
Clarence Thomas listen listen man if
there was a checking there
I are you astr turfy Conor are you
listen you guys you know you guys like
we said you hear what you want to hear
sometimes you guys twist things and it's
not what
we I'm the first one to be like if he
said that he said that man you G have to
eat that that that heat
but be fair let's be fair what else we
got rap Legend Freddy Fox $5 superat yo
Freddy Fox in the build oh salute the
fox yo that's all right NFL 2K5 launched
at $20 and still better than today's
Madden he 50 will not diminish its
impact and graphically it still beats
anything ever you ain't lie you ain't
lie I said that in my um what you call
it uh most overrated game was uh mad
series and 2K game facts continue Chris
R $5 super chat if Microsoft sets a new
standard where I pay less money I'm all
for it it's the most value company in
the world the lights will stay on yeah
not worried about their pocket I really
don't care about that salute then we got
Andre Doyle $2 Super Chat Game of the
Year nominee Allan W 2 is also $49 yes
it is good point and digital only and
digital only good that's a good ball
right there you're right I forgot about
that then we got J Mack $2 Super Chat
$20 price point made 2K football a hit
yep everybody copped I Ain even play
football no more at that point and I
bought that game we got Ty casares $3
Super Chat you guys are still gone have
a good day L have a good evening to you
this is unpredicted just too much wild
stuff fighting amongst ourselves being
that we got Lord
KATU $2 Super Chat power world Xbox sht
holding back console version Oh the
certification okay he got the bars okay
so yeah get in there team get in there
make it work get that version up then we
got black Ronin 357 $5 Super Chat go
watch solo leveling arise Su Jin wo is
here enjoy your Sundays and let's go pal
world is fun solo leveling is a so far I
I haven't seen the the episode that
dropped yesterday yeah but it's it's a
really good thing it's like an anime
that's pretty much about someone that
doesn't grow at all and he's just the
same level in the lore and he got like
some hack where he can actually be the
only person in the world that can level
up like oh nice right let's get out we
all right po new po you like you're
going to like it with the unbelievable
success of the power world launch should
Xbox to expound upon their current game
pass/ game preview relationship with
pocket pair games the choices are a yes
Microsoft should drop the bag at all
costs like Minecraft B wait monitor
their success game is already in Game
Pass or see I don't care when Nintendo
lawyers get a hold of this it's on
site shout out to all those the PA will
go up later today
shout out to the legends of the New York
video games critic Circle that came
through and blessed us Harold Goldberg
The Legend and of course the new
executive director Ryan o Calahan much
love to them and of course the New York
gameo which all the Lords will be a part
of on Tuesday if you're in the New York
area go get some tickets it's um I
believe I'll put the link back in the
description the uh New York games critic
uh.com and uh you can go check that out
I'm going to put the link for that if
you happen to be in the area want to
support Neil dman will be in the
building getting his legendary award
Reggie Fe will be in the building
building you know what I'm saying and of
course the iron Lords will be might see
key in a sweatsuit again in in in the
building with the with the hoodie and
the and the watch dogs look you mean he
low he low but yeah come check us out
man support you know um what's going on
in the community and again giving back
to underserved communities as well as
the uh journalism and video games asp
back so come check us out and if you
can't make it go check out the stream I
put in the um the website so we it'll be
streamed on YouTube twitch all that
stuff so if you can't make it you can
still see us and support Lord addict
where can it find people find your
metaverse Multiverse
character whatever you got going on you
in power world right now this individual
is uh exclusive to to I oh exclusive we
got the contract we dro the bag so so
yeah I I'm good I'm good you you can
find me on Twitter at Lord
addict call me on YouTube a gaming
addict I probably ain't going to release
a whole lot of videos this week uh but I
will be releasing maybe three because be
in New York York we gonna be chilling I
I go get you the ball you can also find
me on uh streaming at uh addict Arena
I've been streaming power world a lot
here lately now that base that you guys
saw that was done offline with my girl
we we we didn't stream that but yeah
yeah it's it's
massive not pause yeah he said paing
that so apprciate we're coming through
we had we had like 850 900 people in
here it's going to be a great week we
have a lot of cool guests lined up for
you guys oh yeah uh you know we got a
lot of stuff going on man we got a lot
of stuff going on yes I I am an AI
algorithm I come from the Future No
Doubt Lord Sovereign I'm here to tell
you that there's a PlayStation 6 oh oh
this AI is bugging he he's from the
Multiverse he's not from the main 616
he's not for the 6 for the other okay I
got you you're timeline a whole
different timeline all right where they
didn't get shafted on by XBox XBox
doesn't exist in his room
Lord he might not be
wrong Lord s in in in our most of our
King is white oh my Lord you messy we
going to move on from you we going to
move on from you f the
line Lord Sovereign we going to find
people find you and being very
disruptive and spicy today yes you can
find me running to the bathroom yes
yes you can find me running to the
bathroom my bladder is about to explode
right now yeah we got to get you Manny
says addict Avatar blink please bro but
yeah he than shout out to to I blink
when I need to to Harold and Ryan
excited to be there on Tuesday excited
to be presenting it's a cool event so
like Cog said go out there if you can
there still some tickets available if
not support the stream let's grow this
New York Gaming scene let's do that um
yeah excited excited I want I want each
of y'all to watch it because we GNA be
on it we going be on it be on it we're
going to be looking da
very flat very small do they stream it
yes yes put the link in I just put the
link in the description yeah ladies
lady no
no s
gentlemen yo
dudes
yo hey guys hey guys s's going to
be this is your chance joystick if
you're in
town I'm I'mma stand right behind Reggie
yo Strange Love if you're in town the
New York hey guys play with my you know
what's funny I'm looking at this this
Avatar going look crazy in shorts oh my
God you messy so yeah so continue
otherwise you can find me playing Prince
Pur of the Lost Crown thank you yeah
Lord King where can if I find you what
you got going on to man you can find me
putting out videos every day keeping a
boot on these Sony Pony necks we're not
stopping hash no PlayStation 6 the hell
where that guy's
from M but yo um had a great time with
our guest today yes Harrow's always a
great uh you know uh talk to and and
today he was just ushering and you know
the next guy so you know that that that
was nice to see know very humble all at
always you know I can't wait to you know
sit down to talk with Ryan yeah I like
you know about that I like I like where
his head space is at we can talk school
stuff think we all bind it on Ryan on a
deep level or certain parts of what he
was saying every part we all have in
fact you know coming to the Bronx it's
kind of crazy and um if y'all are here
listen excuse me you guys don't have to
be invited by us all the time to see
where we're going we're inviting you
yeah there some tickets left if you want
to be part of our gaming culture this is
what we do if you're in the tri state
area or live close to the tri state area
please find out about the tickets for
the New York City gaming Awards and try
to get in there just to see all the
people that's in the room and just to be
part of that experience is it has a real
New York City feel um it's a real
eclectic group with you have uh from
some from the richest people in the room
to the not richest people room some the
most known people in the room to the
most not known people in the room but
what we do have in common is video games
and you will be welcome there and just
come up man because we're going to be
taking pictures we're going to have fun
let's just have some fun is a night for
video games and we have come a long way
celebration oh God as
per yeah let's definitely have fun yeah
let's oh my my God I can't with the's
funny he got a bucket son he got the
bucket the
bucket New York he coming to NY styling
on him I can't wait to put him in that V
law suit he going to have a bucket with
some Air
Force no glizzies for adct cuz last time
we had him out of town he he was popping
glizzies and I was like what
you I got thees and I'm not like King I
can enjoy food and not act like it's a
childish thing yeah he said he said I'm
not like King I can enjoy a fine
Gizzy you're the one that put all
the you're the one that put all the EX
on it I would like a fine New York City
Gizzy that's crazy that's crazy with
mustard
on mustard hard on top this is how I'm
going to look identical to eating that
Gizzy oh man we going to move on we
going move on this how I'm going to look
exactly eat thaty yeah we got to end
this show catch you guys anything else
we got to do we got we got
one got splus member 23 bronze Jimbo
your fan base what a favor before you
sell them all stocks and leave uh beg
for the be beg Father Phil so he can
please put blade on Playstation oh my
God they got a lot of more Warriors they
want Indiana Jones first we good
everybody's good we good all right
everybody Jo big get out of
here all right yeah tell him AI addict
sit AI addict set y
over not the cowboy hat now you look
like astop tell AI addict s you there
from the future you you here you heard
Gizzy addict said hello gzy addict sent
you from the future all right
deuces
[Music]
h